morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly
Affairs we have several bills that we're
going to be discussing this morning uh
We've also going to an executive session
midday and then more hearings this
afternoon but before we get into any of
our committee business I'd ask that you
Allegiance Pledge of Allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all thank you everyone uh before we get
to our first bill I I do want to point
out to members that um represent former
representative ssuch I think it's former
representative right I don't believe
he's in the house currently but he had
testified on HB 1683 and he had
neglected to leave us copies of his
written testimony he mailed those to me
and I've left hard copies at everyone's
uh place um here this morning so if
you're wondering what that how that got
there that that was me so I wanted to
Let's clarify that uh the first bill
this morning is uh House Bill 1280 I'll
open the public hearing on that and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative kushman uh who's also a
member of our committee good morning
representative kushman good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee thank
you uh for the record my name is Leah
kosman I represent the town of wear and
I bring House Bill 1280 to you this
morning an act relative to informed
consent and patient
rights uh the informed consent and
patient Rights Act places in statute
requirements for Physicians to provide
informed consent and document consent in
the medical record as well as
delineating patient rights within the
patient physician uh relationship
language is taken directly from the
American Medical Association code of
medical ethics um chapters
1.1.2 and chapters chapter 2.
1.1 over my time here as a member of
this
committee uh I have heard many stories
of deficiencies and informed consent
processes um mostly from patients but
also medical professionals who feel that
informed consent is not thorough it's
not explicit and it doesn't meet um the
criteria that one would expect when you
read the American Medical association's
code of ethics and others other similar
codes um I imagine that
the any opposition to this bill will be
about documentation time and um you know
that this will be added paperwork and
it'll create a burden uh for
providers um I've worked in various uh
different healthc care settings with
different documentation systems and um I
don't see that that's going to be such
an issue the the software has the
ability to bring in forms that are
fillable um a lot of notes are copy and
paste and then fill in the variables uh
this is something that can easily go on
the chart and you can just put you know
say it's a a drug medication name
explained these potential side effects
explained this prognosis I mean I I
spent a ton of time doing patient
education when I worked for the VNA and
um the forms are you know the they're
digital the the documentation systems
have the capability of doing this and
then if there's um if the facility
already uses specific forms like some
nursing homes um I believe it's a
Medicaid requirement they have to have a
uh informed consent form filled out for
psychotropic medications then that could
be put in the chart or or referenced in
the note from the p patient um physician
encounter
um the bill only addresses Physicians
but I think there is an expectation for
informed consent to be a standard uh
process delivered across the spectrum of
providers uh so I'm willing if the
committee wants to expand this to the
other providers happy to work on an
amendment for
that so going through the bill if you
page um page one of the text it's the
back of the first page um if you go down
to Roman 2 the Crux of the bill is
pretty much Roman 2 in Roman 3 so if
there's language like this is literally
I pulled all of this directly from the
code of ethics and the physicians in New
Hampshire are already bound to this code
of ethics per
rules they're they're bound to follow it
but I think that it's important to have
this information in the statute and have
it available for patients to
see um so basically the the four
components of informed consent are
diagnosis the nature and purpose of the
recommended interventions and then um
risks expected benefits and alternative
options that's really four the way I was
taught it is risks benefits Alternatives
and
prognosis um but this does cover that
just in a different makeup um and then
Roman 3 document the informed consent
conversation and the patients or
surrogates decision in the medical
record in some manner so there's room
for people to do that in whatever way
suits their
organization when the patient or
surrogate has provided specific written
consent the consent form shall be
included in the record and then reading
through there's exceptions for
emergencies and then beginning on line
24 is the patient rights
section it's all of the things that you
would
expect that doctors provide to patients
anyway um we have the patient Bill of
Rights for medical facilities and it's
required for that to be posted in all of
our licensed medical facilities in New
Hampshire but we don't have one for um
just just for that patient physician
relationship and the understanding of um
what the patients's rights are and I
think it's important and perhaps this is
something that we should also have be
given to patients this part of Statute
and say the you
know that um whenever that relationship
begins
or um I'm open to suggestions on that so
really I I just see that we've had a lot
of issues with informed consent before
us and I think it's time for us to now
make sure that we have something
standardized for the professionals
across the board I think it'll increase
trust in the medical system it'll
improve the patient physician
relationship and most importantly it's
going to ensure that patients are
thoroughly informed about interventions
that they are
contemplating and being recommended to
take by their Physicians and I will take
any questions if there are any thank
you representative Nagel thank you thank
you Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question I I have to say that I really
appreciate this effort and the other 4
and a half hours of testimony the other
day that I mean really centered on the
same issue and I I agree with you that
it is a problem what I would like to say
is that um this is a comment with a
question so I know I don't look it but
50 years ago my when my dad was trying
to convince me I wanted to be a doctor
which I really didn't want to be he he
went over the entire practice of
Medicine and he informed me at that time
that the most common reason for a
malpractice suit was failure to obtain
informed consent and that was 50 years
ago um
um as you said everything that's in this
bill it's it's basically a cut and
pasted bill as far as I can tell and um
I did go through the AMA code of ethics
yesterday and um everything that's in
there were already bound to and people
still aren't doing it to the extent that
we I'm just curious
I I Envision a much broader way of
dealing with this issue than this
statute and I'm just curious what do you
think that this is going to change that
we're not already doing or that they
we're not already supposed to be doing
thank you for the question if you think
that this language as it's written Now
isn't going to change anything I'm open
to you know creating uh a pathway for
action for for penalties or remediation
or um you know I'm into that so if
anybody wants to work on the bill I'm
I'm happy to discuss an amendment I see
it as if this is written out in the
statute the patients
have access to it you know um it's not
just in rules with like a reference to
it I feel that it it's going to be more
front and center for
Physicians um and it's also really
putting into law that the the
conversation needs to be documented with
these variables included they have to be
record I I just love to have a sidebar
conversation about exactly what you just
said because this is a big issue
representative Lon and then
representative kofalt thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
bringing this to us um another concern
that I had had heard raised was that in
the informed consent one person was
changed from one drug that was working
for them and was covered well with a
very low co-pay and they had equal risks
and benefits however the new drug cost
$1,000 out of pocket per month um would
you be open to also including not
necessarily specific costs but relative
cost um as far as the doctor is aware
because if they know something's more
expensive it's a risk if you can't
afford dinner sure yeah I I think that's
a good point um especially if if they're
recommending one over another yeah they
could talk about the Alternatives and
also include the cost I I I don't think
it's a bad idea and and definitely that
transparency leads to a better
relationship with the physician and
Trust representative
Kofa thank you Mr chairman and thank you
um Elizabeth Grady um
is responsible for
um medical ethics surrounding human you
know research with human subjects um at
NIH and has co-authored a paper in which
she um Advocates moving from an informed
consent model to a more of a what she
calls a communitarian model um dealing
with communities rather than
individuals um so I am concerned that uh
we are including any kind of medical
trials or medical
research based on the way your bill is
written um would you say that this
includes any kind of medical trial or
medical research in this definition of a
medical
intervention it's not explicitly
accepted but the way I read it is like
during normal course of a physician
patient
relationship um if we need to carve out
something for
research okay no on the wrong
track just point of clarification what I
was asking is whether we would be
protecting people who are participating
in medical trials as well as part of
this thank you yes if if their physician
is enrolling them in a clinical trial
yes they will they will need to have
consent of that informed consent of that
Weber thank you Mr chairman I think that
representative kushman actually answered
my concern when with her answer
um would you believe that my concern is
that when we start putting in specifics
like a specific discussion of the cost
of medications or the specifics of
Trials as opposed to other things uh
then do you know of the legal principle
that to include one is to exclude the
others and so once we start putting in
specifics we are we risk leaving out
other things and would you agree with me
that it might be a better idea to leave
this a general document rather than a
more specific
one I'm generally inclined to that I
just want to make sure there's no um
like conflicting language with something
else that we want to make sure there's
no problems
there representative Seth King thank you
Mr share uh and thank you I have a
question I don't know if you'll be able
to answer or not
um if there's a state of an emergency
declared um as often is the case the
governor can you know strike regulations
to make things go a little little
quicker um is it true that the governor
can scrap Like rules regulations but
that if this is codified in the law he
wouldn't be able to just scrap that so
this would really offer a lot more
protections for the individual is is do
you see it that way thank
you um unfort well we have in our
emergency Powers um the governor can he
has the ability to change
effectively suspend law so he it it
happened in the last um state of
emergency where statute was suspended
with emergency orders executive orders
uh so the legislature does have more
oversight on that now because of some
reforms that went through but it's my
understanding that
initially uh the executive could still
uh suspend
questions representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking another
question um have you heard of the
different concepts of physician um
basically the idea of an informed
consent where the pH physician tells you
what they think you should know versus a
p patient Centric informed consent where
it's all about making sure that the
patient knows what the average patient
would want to
know I'm familiar with it yes okay and I
guess as a followup I just want want
wanted to make sure that as we work on
this would you be willing to work to
make sure that we're doing the patient
specific as opposed to provider specific
informed consent absolutely yeah I I
think that's the intent here is to make
sure that patients are getting the
information that they really need
and and that that's documented in the
chart um if there if you see language
where we can make that stronger I'm open
to suggestions thank you representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I I I
don't disagree with you or in followup
to representative
Nagel's um comment uh about informed
consent um and I'm not even as concerned
about the mechanical issues that you
raised about the the issue may be the
EMR and how do we you know document it
as
such my concern is that I honestly
believe that we try to do informed
consent as best we can not always
perfectly I get that and I understand
that um but there's a couple questions I
have in here one
is the consequences of of um a statutory
requirement that has very specific
details regarding informed consent if
you have it through the ama's ethics you
know that you refer to as Dr Nel
mentioned one of the the the recourses
that patients have is litigation a
lawsuit you know for malpractice you
didn't tell me what was going to happen
I wasn't informed of this I I had no
idea that you know my arm would be put
on rotated 90 degrees or whatever like
that you know so you can't be specific
to every detail but our our our
recourses or patient's recourse at this
point in time is really one of of you
know you know malpractice lawsuits what
would be the consequences of a statutory
um um um um a bill of this nature if one
were not to follow any of the specific
um um uh recommendations made in the
bill what is the would there be a legal
recourse what are the penalties involved
so as I as I read it the the Board of
Medicine would be responsible to enforce
this as it's current ly written and that
would be left to their purview so and
that's how it is right now because it's
in it's in rules this very same language
you know it's
referenced um it's actually hyperlink
but um
it's I think it would be the same as
it's written now it would be the same
Avenue of um you know complaint and
Remediation and penalty as as is
currently
done follow yeah and I would just say
that you know I am a big advocate of
patient you know consent before any
surgery I would bring patients in two
weeks ahead of time for elective
procedures when they're calm collected
they understood they were in their genes
they understood because they were not
scared when you get an informed consent
the day of an elective procedure to me
that really isn't informed consent
because patients are oftentimes and
that's one of the issues that I may want
to see that you address is the timing of
informed consent because if you really
want to put something in statute it has
to have some you know really logical you
know assumptions made informed consent
at the day of a surgery 1 hour before
you have a major procedure in my mind
may not be informed consent unless it's
an emergency
situation however you know I would say
that one of the things I think that has
protected many of us in medicine is the
communication we have with patients and
informed consent well ahead of time has
done that so one other question I had
and I you mentioned that the Crux of the
bill is uh Roman two and three but my
question is number one cro Roman number
one and one of the requirements here is
that I as a provider and as a surgeon
would have to be able to assess the
patient's ability to understand relative
medical information I'm not really sure
how I can do that I thought about this
when I've read the bill I'm trying to
understand how I can truly assess every
patients ability to fully comprehend
everything that I've told them in a
informed consent discussion
so my thoughts on that uh because I I
deal with the same as a nurse um I
provide a lot of patient education and I
ask questions after to see if they can
teach back what I taught them um I
clarify I I mean when you first see a
patient you're kind of doing that mini
physical exam anyway head to toe you're
you're seeing if their speech is slurred
if they seem to be comprehending you're
saying to them um you know you would
have looked and seen if there's any
diagnosis to indicate some um you know
executive function um issues you know if
there was a diagnosis of dementia I feel
like the history and just the you know
sitting with the patient and speaking to
them is going to let in 99%
of uh cases is going to let you know if
this
person's um in the right position to
have an informed consent conversation or
come other
questions representative
Canon thank you Mr chair
um it in in line with that dis
discussion and I'm looking at this what
about um the person who has a legal
guardian or uh someone representing them
um
the Roman numeral 1es assess the
patient's ability but it doesn't mention
somebody of authority that has
responsibility for that
patient yeah that's a good point um so I
have if we want to put in something here
about the patient or their
surrogate or Guardian if a minor I think
that's a good
suggestion representative
kofalt uh thank you Mr chair um so this
refers to written
consent um but we hear a lot about tele
medicine these days and so I'm wondering
if written consent might include um some
might in might include potentially an e
signature um that is done remotely to
facilitate that
process I would assume so I think our
telea health law allows for everything
to be
like finessed to be able to be done
remotely in the physician patient
relationship and I as far as I see the
digital form with a signature would be
okay but uh if you see if you think that
that's that this language does not cover
that I'm open to grafting an amendment
and making sure that it
works representative Nagel did you have
your hand up
okay kind of okay I wasn't sure if you
were kind of just leaning on your elbow
or until um representative Murphy
brought this up I never even thought
about it but your husband's in the car
industry and my trucks in the shop right
now and he explained all the problems
that need to get fixed in my you know
25-year-old Ford F-150 and I have you
know I think I'm intelligent I have
absolutely no clue what the guy said and
and I think we have the same problem
with patience is that no matter you know
no matter
how intelligent they are they don't
really fully grasp but we're saying a
lot and that makes assessing their level
of understanding a lot more difficult
I'm curious how we address that with
number one because I I I always assume
the minute I meet people they don't have
a clue what I'm talking
about thank you for the question so the
way I I would see that it would be dealt
with is you're documenting your writing
up after your interaction with the
patient and if you had something you had
noted something that might make you
question you know
um the the patient seems to um lose
track of the conversation or and if you
just document it you know it's a
cya you you put down What You observe
and later if there's a lawsuit you make
sure all those details were known
well there was some questionability
about the patient's abil uh ability to
understand what we were talking about as
noted by this this and this variable
that I I saw and then you when you write
down what you presented to them if they
asked any questions you can note that
too and you know that way at least as
much of the conversation as you feel is
necessary to protect yourself as a
physician is in the
documentation follow up I'm just a
followup we're we're in modern corporate
medicine right now where I have 10
minutes to see a patient because that's
what my employer says that I have the
first seven minutes of that 10 minutes
are spent with me documenting meaningful
use and managing and operability which
leaves me three minutes to explain all
this stuff and I realize you said before
you don't think it's an issue but it it
really is an issue that's why I think
that this is a much bigger societal
issue than
than just this bill and I really think
this warrants a really long thoughtful
discussion about how to solve all these
problems representative I would believe
that yeah sorry it's
a thank you um maybe I'm one of those
people that can't understand this but um
I'm a
little I'd like a little bit of
explanation between informed consent
when it's a physician
patient discussion where all these
things are adequately explained versus
informed consent when they um patient
actually has to sign a form does this in
does this is this overarching over both
of those because certainly a form is not
signed in many cases like if a doctor
prescribes a medication to me I don't
remember ever having to sign a form um
giving informed consent so does this
does this
Bill include both of those
situations thank you for the question
yes uh if at the end of so in Roman 2
line 11 on the back of the first page um
it says to present the relevant
information and then number three
document the informed consent
conversation in the
chart
um if there is a specific written
consent that form can be includ shall be
included in the record so I think if you
if your facility like if you're writing
your note informed consent obtained per
facility policy and then you reference
the form and then it's it's in the
record and that form has probably
already got written out like our psych
forms have already written out side
effects um Alternatives everything's on
there already so if a facility has those
already those can be
used follow so this this particular Bill
does not um change anything in terms of
um mandatory written consent versus a
discussion
correct representative
TZ thank you and thank you for taking my
question um could you clarify again
because uh on line five it says undergo
a specific medical intervention so to me
this applies to that universe and not
all care which is what I heard you just
respond about and then oh can I ask more
than one question I have to Sure follow
up
after can you point to where line
five okay oh five and six between a
patient and a physician results in the
patient's authorization or agreement to
undergo a specific medical intervention
so to me that confines everything to
specific medical
interventions so can you whereas what
you just asked about is essentially All
Med you know all all clinical encounters
where there
you know I'm giving you a new
hypertension Med or
whatever um so that would be an an
intervention prescribing a medication is
a medical
intervention so the way I see it would
be
procedures and
prescriptions um
even I mean everything short of
counseling on diet
and and uh you know lifestyle changes I
think would require the informed consent
under this so and as a followup as a
followup to uh followup on Dr Nagel's
question where he used the analogy of
himself right
uh can you help us understand this
assessment Beyond teachback which is
really just repeating back what you've
just heard um when 40% of the US
population overall is low health
literacy and has a difficult time
understanding instructions in general
enal including the example we were just
given where a highly educated person
doesn't necessarily understand you know
what's being explained so can you uh
flush out more like how how you would
see assessment happening
since um basically everything I see here
is basically
current practice for how things should
get done right so I would say how do you
do it
now just keep doing it make sure you
know and and then just document it um if
you're with your patient usually you
know if you what you're presenting if
it's appropriate for
them and or if they need someone else
there to help or if they need
reinforcement teaching later um all of
that can be documented I think it's
pretty this can be applied pretty
broadly um and it can be flexible to the
needs of the patient and what um
situation you're in but
I think just as long as you put in there
you know alert and oriented times four
um able to make needs known you know can
repeat back what was
taught or if those some of those don't
check and say you know this isn't there
um you know this this variable isn't
present so um question about the in
ability to have informed consent
conversation
and then maybe consult with a family
member or if they have a surrogate or
something but it's really like it's it's
kind of up to the doctor in that
situation to just see what they think is
appropriate and just put it in the chart
if you have a question about the patient
being able to receive the
Weber thank you and thank you for taking
my question my question is a followup on
um the last question which is uh you've
suddenly triggered me to wonder okay so
you have a conversation you are not
entirely sure that the person has
understood what you're talking to them
about or they seem a little disoriented
or whatever those concerns are you
document that in the chart but my
concern is how do we know what are are
we putting greater barriers in the way
of treatment because you have not been
able to document that they understand
exactly what's going on or are
we I guess the broader question is once
you get to that point the note in the
chart doesn't either protect the patient
who hasn't completely understood nor
does it protect the medical provider WR
who says I'm I'm still doing this
intervention um despite the fact that
the patient hasn't
understood um and then you get into all
kinds of consent issues because if they
don't actually have a guardian or if
they're not a minor so their parent is
their Guardian uh you who gets to
consent and under what
circumstances so I'm I'm concerned how
do we deal with the issue on the one
hand of getting in the way of
appropriate interventions and on the
other hand um ensuring that appropriate
consent is being given um
my would you care to comment on how that
could push in either
direction um sure so on the side of the
way I see it is you're you're
documenting your encounter with your
patient if your patient's not able to
make medical decisions for themselves
and you have that suspicion then they
should have a surrogate um and we have
laws for that process um so I would
think that wouldn't even be the end of
that conversation
there and um as far as like I understand
that people that there's a 40% health
literacy um but that's why we are
trained to present information in a in a
way that's kind of meets people at that
level but when you're going when you're
putting things in the chart you're
you're creating the legal document and
you're writing down your objective
information so if you put on there that
this person's not alert and oriented
then you're probably not going to
continue any treatment without having
someone there to make those decisions
for
them um
if uh the patient is alert and oriented
and as far as you can tell they can they
can give consent then you write down
what you gave them and what their
responses were if they seemed
appropriate and then you're protected
and then it goes in the chart it stays
there and then say a complaint is lodged
with the medical board they go back they
review it they look and they say okay
yep you noted that you gave them this
information this information this
information you've met the the
requirements they were alert and
oriented um in your
assessment and um we answer answering
questions appropriately no slurred
speech you know all of that's in there
usually
anyway okay any other
you also signed up to speak is Ben
Association
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee I'm sorry I was a little
late this morning so I didn't hear
everybody's testimony apologize I wasn't
here for your introduction of the bill
um for the record my name is Ben Bradley
I'm the vice president of state
government relations with the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all the state's acute care
hospitals and Specialty hospitals um the
association is opposed to hb280 and I'd
like to share a few concerns for the
committee's consider consideration um we
believe informed consent is a critical
process that ensures patients or their
representative participate in the
development of a plan of care
additionally our members strongly
support patient rights however this bill
seems duplicative and puts informed
consent language and patient right
rights language into RSA 329 a statute
specific to Physicians and surgeons in
its conditions for participation the
centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services outlines standards and
requirements for informed consent all
hospitals comply with these requirements
as a condition of their participation in
Medicare and Medicaid additionally The
Joint Commission which accredits the C
and certifies Healthcare organizations
in the United States and around the
world requires those organizations to
comply with clinical standards for
informed consent including discussion
about potential benefits risks and side
effects of the patients proposed care it
also requires the decision maker to be
informed formed of reasonable
alternatives to the proposed care
including risks benefits and side
effects of those Alternatives um we're
concerned that hb280 would create a
conflicting standard for informed
consent when federal laws and
regulations already outline the National
Standard that could be referenced across
state lines and applied Beyond just
Physicians and surgeons we feel the
patient right provisions of this bill
are already covered by New Hampshire's
Patient Bill of Rights in RSA 150 1
colon 21 which applies to any person
Corporation facility or institution
providing health care services including
but not limited to a physician Hospital
dentist nurse optometrist podiatrist
physical therapist or psychologist and
any officer employee or agent of such
provider acting in the course and scope
of employment or agency relative to or
supportive of the healthc care services
uh thanks for the opportunity provide
our feedback I'm happy to take questions
thank you representative
Weber thank you I just wondered if you
had copies of your written testimony or
whether you or whether you might have
uploaded them to the website I will
circulate them so I'm done it makes the
handwriting discussion much easier there
you go there you go representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
so much for being here good morning um
my question um is actually reaching back
to the area I recognize that this is
already in the AMA but it seems that
there's a conflict about identifying
whether a person is able to make their
medical decision I'm not sure if you're
familiar with RSA 137 J which are which
came through this committee three years
ago um which is the one about the about
um having the the name starts with the
surrogates so that when the provider is
assessing the patient they're supposed
to determined that if they cannot make
their own medical decisions that either
whoever is named in the power medical
power of attorney or their surrogate is
brought into the conversation there are
Provisions for emergency care in there
as well um do you believe that it may
actually capture some of these patients
who aren't receiv receiving aren't
actually taking their medication as
indicated or otherwise following up with
doctor advice if this gives us an
opportunity to determine whether or not
they actually need a surrogate involved
so your question is whether this bill
and the provisions
under uh Roman one would give the
ability to follow up if patients are not
taking their medication to follow up
with a surrogate is that your question
no that's not my question my question is
that the current law states that if a
person cannot make their own medical
decisions that um either their their
person and their derable power of
attorney or a surrogate needs to be
named to be involved in that care my
question is since there's been a
disconnect about that law and a
disconnect about the informed consent
when somebody can't consent would you be
opposed to making sure that our
providers know about the surrogacy
because that's part of their process for
informed consent and to bring somebody
into the conversation I'm happy to take
a look at any proposals that might
address that thank
questions seeing none followup um I
guess my other question is you said that
all providers are covered under the
patient Bill of Rights I was in a
meeting Monday morning with the CEO of a
large private um large Primary Care
Organization and they stated that their
organization was not actually subject to
the patients Bill of Rights because that
is in the facility licensing I guess I
was curious whether you were aware about
uh those details or if I'm asking you
too much because you're brand new to the
job and I know you're doing a great as
far as I'm concerned and I'm happy to
testify on this um I believe they they
would be covered uh under the patient
Bill of Rights there are specific
Provisions in the patient Bill of Rights
that outline exactly who within the
chapter are covered
and how they're provided entities and so
my testimony reflects direct language
you representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um I this is representing a constituent
group of mine that's really important to
me but um one of the concerns was
actually raised by the sponsor of the
bill was that this was so specific for
Physicians and not these other groups
and then she offered actually um you
know address that as a a broader
Amendment but you listed all the people
that are included and it was a fairly
long list are potentially included I
didn't hear the word
chiropractor and I and I actually have
Believe It or Not reviewed the entire
New Hampshire statute to see how
chiropractors are included as healthc
care providers and in this state they're
actually not would they be included too
well let me just read from uh my
testimony I'm sorry I didn't hand it out
beforehand but um this this would the
patient Bill of Rights applies to any
person Corporation facility or
institution providing health care
services including but not limited to
okay all right and so um thank you the
list of uh entities that I provided was
not inclusive thank you you're welcome
other
you
no one else has signed up to testify
does anyone else wish to testify yes
representative Phillips yes that was my
next question my next
comment and if I didn't mention it the
clerk would have so um thank you for
letting me speak uh representative Emily
Phillips Rockingham 7 Fremont New
Hampshire I wasn't planning to speak on
this bill but I support it I just want
to remind um I mean I think we all know
as legislators we are um protecting the
rights of individuals and it's um I
think a lot of times when bills like
this come forward we're looking at how
does this affect corporations or
Industries and we're not about that
we're trying to protect individual
rights so if this expands um that then I
would support it I'm a big informed
consent person I just reviewed the bill
but I do support it I don't know if I
can answer any questions but I just want
to make sure that we're focused on
what's best for an individual granted
stator and not what causes more work for
like I said hospitals corporations um
providers it's it it's irrelevant to me
it's about protecting the individual
rights in New Hampshire so okay thank
Weber as a point of personal privilege
Mr
chairman I really resent the notion that
I might not be concerned with
individuals rights and I'm also I can't
speak for anybody else on this committee
but I've heard an awful lot of concern
about individuals rights from everybody
here I I didn't mean to offend you
personally I just when I hear from the
the hospital Association and it tells
that it's redundant that's what I meant
is that we're trying to focus on so I do
apologize if I offended you it doesn't
it's not a it's not a question it's my
statement
person other questions or
sir is this the next bill you talk okay
yeah we're we're not there yet we'll get
this shortly I may have pulled a blue
sheet does anyone else wish to
testify I'm seeing no one okay uh before
I close the public hearing on um HB 1280
I may have pulled a blue sheet too
quickly I did have one person sign up uh
in favor of this and representative L do
you know anyone who signed up online um
I did look on online I was surprised at
the numbers so I looked at some of the
written text um most of all of the 10
comments were actually about the medical
assistance and dying Bill 1283 and not
1280 so the fact that there's six in
support and 54 opposed I don't think we
can count on because there's a lot of
confusion people thought that that would
be heard in our committee as the first
bill but that's in judiciary as the
first bill today so we'll give everyone
a pass there okay thank you Mr
in she oh okay yeah this is only for
people not who are not speaking okay
thank
you okay uh with that being said I'm
going to close the public hearing on
hb280 and open the public hearing on
hb300 and rep uh recognize the prime
lewicki thank you Mr chairman good
morning to all the members of the
committee um my name is John liwicki I
represent hill bro
36 um I'm here today to introduce uh HB
1300 which will increase the ability of
patients with incurable diseases to
access treatments the bill would protect
practitioners from liability for
assisting with treatments uh with
providing there is fully informed
consent at this very moment as we're
probably aware there is a bill in
judiciary to allow assisted suicide in
New Hampshire it would be the height of
irony if we were to allow pH physician
assisted suicide but continue to not
allow practitioners to assist with uh
potentially life-saving
treatments um in some states dead people
can vote here in New Hampshire we can do
better a dead man can testify before a
legislative
committee um I have incurable cancer I
got the verdict three years ago some of
you may remember that I was out from
around this time until March of last
year that was associated with trying um
an unapproved treatment
the experiment was a partial success if
I thought that repeating it would have
any significant chance of being Curative
I'd do it again
tomorrow when talking to doctors about
unapproved treatments the response isn't
that won't work the response is I could
lose my license um what I did was risky
if it had been possible to do it in a
with assistance in a controlled
environment um it would have been much
less risky however under existing
statute that was not an option
under the existing RSA 126 Z colon 1
patients may only have access FD FDA
approved treatments are treatments that
are in the FDA
pipeline however there are many
potential treatments that are off patent
or otherwise outside of the FDA process
since FDA trials are so expensive
there's no incentive for anyone to do a
trial of any of these potentially
Curative
treatments um there's an old definition
of insanity which is doing the same
thing and expecting different results a
corollary to that is um if no one ever
tries anything different nothing ever
changes for many life-threatening
diseases um there has been very little
experimentation not surprisingly um
progress has been slow and for diseases
like mine standard of care is paliative
treatment
only um in the three years I've been on
death r i could have tried potentially
Curative treatment every 3 to six months
um imagine what kind of progress we
would make if thousands of more people
were trying different things I don't
know which uh things they might try that
might be the appropriate solution but I
do know that if we don't try we're not
going to find them uh many of us have
nothing to lose hp300 removes the
Restriction um to only FDA treatments
for incurable diseases it also increases
the standard for informed consent it
might even make sense to parallel the
informed consent conditions to those in
the assisted suicide Bill like most
bills hb300 isn't perfect it might um if
there are questions or suggestions I'm
very happy to hear them and very happy
to uh work with whomever would like to
either here or outside of the Committee
hearing on the back of this sheet um is
how my story of how I got to this uh
condition I don't think it's appropriate
of necessary for me to go through that
uh presently because it's only
peripherally re
relevant so if anybody has questions I'm
very happy to answer thank you any
questions representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair and thank you for sharing
your testimony um so we just my
understanding is we recently got the
federal like right to try through and
and is this duplicative in nature or
does this
expand extra reasons why a person would
be able to try could you just explain
the difference between this and the
federal thank you all right right and I
am not familiar with the federal one all
I'm familiar with is um the New
Hampshire statute and I did speak to the
SP Prime sponsor of that and he
basically got it as a u boiler plate
from a foundation and he was very
supportive of expanding the right to try
particularly in the case where there are
no cures
available representative Murphy thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question um I'm I'm curious as to why
in uh line seven of the first page that
um the United States food and drug FDA
has approved um has been eliminated and
my my question is specifically and I'm
all in favor of you know trying you know
anything when you've gone beyond the
normal protocols for treatment of any
you know severe debilitating disease um
but what would be the filter what would
be the um the ability to um make sure
that what ever a physician because
that's who is going to be writing the
prescription or recommendation of a drug
biologic prod or device what would be
the protection for the patient to make
sure that whatever you are trying is
number one not worse than the disease
progression itself and also in the
attempt to prevent false hope for any
patient that is grabbing in any straw
that might help them so how do we make
sure that whatever is prescribed because
not Physicians would I mean you could
prescribe anything you want once you
graduate from med school but is it
appropriate for that patient and are you
giving them false hope so I'm trying to
protect the patient in this sense as to
somebody offering something that really
has absolutely no chance and actually
may be harmful okay um there is nothing
in this bill that would compel a
practitioner to do anything against his
will and it also you know as I say uh is
in fully informed consent that is not
consent in front of just a medical
person that would be consent with
someone who is not a medical personnel
either a u family member a chaplain or
someone else who is uh completely
impartial or not impartial necessarily
but not part you know of uh the medical
practice that it would be performing the
treatment um does that answer your
question um follow up thank you I yes I
understand that I appreciate that my my
question is really that any experimental
you know drug product device may go down
obviously the the pathway of being
approved by the FDA or any governing
body uh in and oftentimes they will be
used in uh emergency circumstances when
you have exhausted all the traditional
stuff what I'm afraid of is that if you
eliminate any
outside uh protections for the patient
simply on the recommendation of a
physician who can prescribe this and two
other people that concur how do we
protect the patient from a intervention
or treatment that is actually harmful
and really does not have any hope and
hope I'm not sure I think that if a
patient is fully informed you know that
understands basically if they say this
is what I want to do this is why I want
to do it and with the risks um and
knowing that there are risks what I did
myself um I thought I had maybe a 25%
chance of dying I was willing to take
that risk because uh of the perceived
possible upside um and from my point of
view um if the conventional you know
standard of care does not offer any hope
then let people try and some of them
ultimately May succeed and may move
things forward I often refer to the
helico back to pis situation where
standard of care was and everybody knew
one person proved the exception to that
rule and we now have a whole different
world in that case unless we try
different things nothing changes and
that uh you know trying only what the
FDA says is acceptable in my mind is not
um you know closes too many doors for
people who have uh nothing to hope no
FDA thank you representative Lon um
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for being here with us
and being here um we I greatly
appreciate that uh my question um I is
basically around sort of the idea of
this the in intention of this is to be
able to access more opportunities so
that a patient along with their provider
is able to access um as many of the
different options that they may believe
are a good fit for them is that correct
yes okay thank you I'm very very happy
to be here because I last year I was
in intensive care and with some serious
concerns and so it's very nice to be
upright and here followup and thank you
um so as a followup um I do know that
some of these some of drugs that are in
clinical trials they'll have main sites
who are located somewhere and some of
the pharmaceutical companies and some of
the biotech companies are willing to
open up satellite sites so that one
doctor can get a patient on study um
there's a lot of federal red tape would
you be interested in making sure that
we're removing any state red tape to
that so that we can get access to people
who may not be able to travel out of
state for this care or otherwise access
things that are in in that Pipeline and
are being offered especially as a last
chance hope for patients yeah that's
exactly why I put the bill in is to
allow that kind of thing and to allow
things that are outside of the clinical
trial Universe because U as we all know
clinical trials are very expensive
and clinical trials are not done for
things that are off- patent where
there's no Revenue stream available or
no uh Revenue upside for a uh
pharmaceutical uh developer or for
anyone else because there's there's no
money in it and uh there are many things
that have been tried over the years and
basically left by the wayside because um
there was no money in getting it through
the FDA and in my mind the f a is an
obstacle for people in my condition one
more followup followup um thank you um
and as my last followup um um I you
actually might have been uh fighting for
your life while we were fighting for um
a greater ability to um access off Lael
drugs um I guess my question would be if
both you and your provider are aware
that we opened up off label use um with
protections from licensing for simply
the fact that it's off label not just to
terminal patients but all patients and
if you think it would be helpful to
reference that in the statute because
it's hard to find things in our laws
would that help oh no I very agreeable
to that uh and I will go through the
video of this afterward and try to find
these things and I will come back when
you're doing work session or um exact
session and present anything that will
actually make the bill better thank you
other
questions there no other questions thank
no one else has signed up to testify on
this bill em oh it was with it came with
the his card they may have been stuck
together okay I was wondering if that
was for the previous bill or this one oh
actually maybe it was for the previous B
that was for the previous bill so again
no one else has signed up to testify on
HB uh 128 um 1300 does anyone else wish
to testify on this
bill um representative fedus could you
grab the blue sheet and tell me how many
names are on
it or maybe Christina maybe you could do
for okay thank you and online
representative land online there's 12 in
support 33 opposed okay thank you very
much
okay if no one else wishes to testify on
hb300 uh I'm going to close the public
hearing on this bill we do have an
executive session scheduled for 11:00
a.m. uh and we will also have other
hearings this afternoon so for now we uh
adjourned five minutes and we have the
Republicans meet in the committee office
sure
see
course you don't want to
sh
shut
the
many
I
te
yeah
have
thank
you
yeah
words
resp
EX
I'm
that's
the
only
for
start
good after oh no it's still morning good
morning everyone uh we are reconvening
in executive session I'm going to
consider four bills uh at this time and
we'll begin with HB
motion thank you Mr chairman I would
move Amendment 2004
0548 H which you should which I just
passed out to
everybody and the reason for the
amendment this was voted 4 to zero in
our subcommittee okay if I could ask
representative bzour for a second oh
okay proceed representative Weber thank
you my my apologies uh this was voted
four to zero in our
subcomittee as you recall the concern
when we started with this bill was that
the bill is originally submitted to us
required us to set aside both the
intestacy laws of the State of New
Hampshire and a specific court order
based on those intestacy laws and there
was a great deal of General discomfort
with that and I think it's kind of
unconstitutional so uh but to fulfill
the
same um
intent what uh the amendment does
because we had some discussion at the um
when the bill was presented originally
about perhaps instead of setting up a
dedicated Fund in the state which then
has to be administered and has
administrative costs that perhap perhaps
we could simply
direct um an appropriation from the
general fund in the amount of the
intestate money that came from the
estate so what this does it says all
proceeds es cheated to the general fund
which is what happens when you don't
have a will and you don't have any
heirs um from the estate of teasty Banu
formerly of nashaa and um when it came
to figuring out an
organization uh what was suggested to me
initially was the international um
Institute of New Hampshire because they
have one of the school-based
programs um and then the other one that
was mentioned was um entri a Care
Alliance uh and then representative
merer had suggested back at the initial
hearing the Roa Kids Club of Manchester
and that's why we went 1/3 1/3
covers a wide variety of bases so that
was that was what was suggested by the
subcommittee thank you representative
Weber any
questions representative Nagel thank you
Mr
chair um I I really appreciate this
because my big concern was this money
would go somewhere to die you know and
this by doing it here you're going to be
putting it into a group that I think
will have funding you'll be able to grow
the money and not just that's right at
least it's their responsibility it's not
ours yeah yeah I think I think the the
likelihood of it growing much unless you
do a risky in investment is very slight
but it's a it's a lot of good works that
I don't think any of us want to have go
to administrative costs thank you good
job representative Shapiro yes having
been involved in um resettling an Afghan
family who came after um the United
States left and this was an Afghan
family who um the father was involved
with the US military so they were
evacuated um having helped with their
resettlement through entri Care Alliance
I can attest to the fact that asent Care
Alliance could use every dollar they can
get to help with their work in
resettling refugees
thank you representative Missour thank
you yes to follow up uh with
representative Shapiro so you worked
with asentria and I've worked with I and
Roa so I think that the three
organizations here are well represented
in our experience and working with them
so I think what we've done today I think
is a beautiful thing um and the money
will get where it's needed the most and
I like I love that a lot thank you and
if I may sure go ahead the thing that we
are all going to have to do is follow
this to finance because if there's
anybody who can undo what we have done
that's where it is so uh I urge all of
you to follow the bill
along um and I would I would
also um I would also say that there are
many other organizations that do
incredibly good work so the the issue
here was figuring out how to pick and in
many ways I feel like I threw a dart at
um the the ones we have picked uh we
have people who know them and and attest
to their work but there are a lot of
other organizations as well
and um I thought that way lay Madness
trying to figure out if we were
including everybody so representative
Murphy and then representative TZ and
then representative K thank you Mr
chairman uh uh just a technical question
because I love the idea of redirecting
it to like organizations that will do
the same work for refugees um is it
appropriate or is it wise I guess I'm
asking to name organizations or should
we just say one organization and or like
organizations I'm thinking if one folds
goes away or you know is no longer there
you know do we lock ourselves
in representative Weber it's a one time
gift okay so if they're there that's
where it goes and if they're not there
then the fiscal committee or the finance
committee or somebody else has to think
again but we're not talking about a
long-term uh distribution this is this
would just be if it goes through and
gets signed by the governor uh checks
would be written and that would be that
perfect thank I
assume representative
TZ thank you um I just want to explain a
little bit that International Institute
and asentra are the two local
resettlement agencies here in New
Hampshire they have many funding streams
that come from the feds for very many
different kinds of services they have
for years run uh School uh they were
called School impact funds where they
were supposed to work very directly with
the school districts and directly with
the children and families and so I think
it's uh really wonderful to to just send
it to them what I was thinking money
like this could be helpful for is to do
something with the youth that maybe they
haven't been able to meet through
whatever they're already funding like
like scholarships like was suggested in
the um you know the information we have
about the deceased person's wishes I
think as far as other organizations I
appreciate I've heard of Roo Club there
are many organizations um and so I
personally feel like it's hard to pick
among all the many other organizations
that exist to serve Refugee youth my
personal feeling is in general it's a
little more fair if you just try to make
it available to everyone but this is not
a lot of money so I would urge us to
consider just just a centria and just um
uh
I uh but that's you know that's my
suggestion uh representative King thank
you Mr chair at the risk of protesting
too much uh I'm going to be voting
against the amendment and then also the
underlying bill um I appreciate the work
that was done by the subcommittee to
find some groups that ideally we could
all agree on um that being said I don't
know any of these personally and I'm not
willing to put my stamp of approval on
some clubs that I've never heard of they
might be great but I've never read their
Miss mission statement I don't know
anything about them and based on what I
have heard so far I probably wouldn't
support them for reasons that I won't
bore you with right now um
so I under I also understand
representative Weber's Point um about
the underlying Bill and that it may have
problems and so I I I get the idea that
we want to fix that um and I appreciate
that um however it's we're in a tough
situation because we're basically just
legislators picking our our preferences
here and and uh we could end up I mean
we probably won't but we could end up
technically battling over what what we
think the money should go towards and um
unfortunately um the donor in this
situation did not specify um we had a
friend of his come and testify that you
know really got the ball rolling towards
I think it was more his Pet Project than
it was the donor's pet project so um
it's just it's it's it's a little messy
for me this whole system and I don't
really I don't want to set a I mean I'm
sure this has been done before but I
don't really like the precedent of this
so I'm just going to I'm just going to
say no to everything sorry thanks thank
you I will representative
Weber I will say that um the I did draft
two separate other amendments one
benefiting solely The International
Institute and one benefiting solely The
International Institute and entria so if
either of those are um things that
you're interested in I believe
representative Maser still has the
printed copies but they look exactly
like this and I know the bill numbers so
if you're
more um comfortable going with the
established
ones uh but you know as leg legislators
we create winners and losers all the
time and this bill will go not only to
us but to the finance committee and then
on to the Senate so um there are a lot
of people who will have input into it um
but we we benefit different programs all
the time and and but I I understand
you're also your thought and the grand
scheme of things as well representative
Missour thank you yes well I app
appreciate what I've heard um you know
we did create a subcommittee to have
these discussions and we had thoughtful
discussions and um when I walked into
subcommittee this morning I thought that
we were going to come out of an
amendment on it all together which we
essentially did but when representative
Weber mentioned the two I was not part
of that discussion so it the we walked
into subcommittee with an amendment well
she had two already written which I
appreciated that um but having not been
a part of that discussion this morning I
came into subcommittee with another
suggestion we all discussed it that's
the purpose of the subcommittee uh we
all agreed for nothing um on this
information so I think we've you know
we've done some work on it and uh that's
why we came with with the amendment that
we did so thank you representative Lon
thank you Mr chairman um I just want to
say that I appreciate the work of the
subcommittee
I will only support the amendment that
came out of the subcommittee 40 with the
three in that um otherwise the any of
the other amendments or the bill are a
deal breaker for me I want to honor the
work that was done this morning when you
came in
early okay other uh
questions seeing none I'll ask the
collector call the r at this time the
motion is ought to pass no no we have to
adopt the amendment
first okay I thought I'm sorry I thought
you would move the amendment I did move
the amendment but we have to
oh no we have to vote on the amendment
first and the bill but you said the
motion is ought to pass on the amendment
I mean oh okay got it I'm sorry not not
not otpa OTP jumping jumping the gun
here uh so the motion is out to pass on
Amendment 2024 hyphen
0548 H right I've got the right one y
yep okay Mr Park representative Lyon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt
yes representative Thomas yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative fedus
yes representative nut
upam representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ yes and represent McDonald yes 19 to
one okay there's no objection oh
actually we're not there yet never mind
I can do that all the time I don't know
why okay uh do I have another motion
representative Weber yes Mr chairman I
would like to move a to pass as amended
by Amendment
0548 and representative maor yes I'd
like to second
please any discussion on the main
Bill seeing none
Mr Clark when you're
ready representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofel yes representative
Thomas yes representative Seth King no
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
palosa
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter
upam representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative taes yes and
representative McDonald yes 19 to
one okay if there's no objection um we
put it on the consent calendar it has an
appropriation oh okay I'm sorry good
point okay moving on uh the next bill to
be considered this morning is hb1 1661
dfn representative plaz off uh thank you
Mr chair I I moveed to send this bill to
interim study okay and I'll second that
motion representative and would you like
to speak to your motion uh yeah yes
thank you I'm sorry are we doing 16 16
61 so okay since this bill was discussed
uh in the public hearing more data uh
shows that this bill uh uh this uh uh
accountability system is actually needed
uh and uh currently at least two
additional States considering similar
legislation uh Minnesota plans to
introduce a similar Bill and uh one
other state but that's why it's
important for us to to do it right uh uh
we heard some uh objection
uh during the public hearing
specifically from
DHHS um uh for the record um uh I want
to put uh uh those uh two suggested
amendments that I hand out uh one is
or52 uh which uh deals uh with uh
deleting uh audits section at the end of
the bill uh It's always important to
audit things but the audit system
proposed in the original bill
was
unique so it probably makes sense to
create a system itself first and then if
we feel that there's needs to be some
specific audit system just for this
purpose it could be a separate bill uh
so that's one of the suest suggestion
24538 uh so one of the objection
was Mr chairman I have a point of order
sure my understanding was the motion was
interim study yes he's just explaining
and has that been seconded uh yes I
seconded okay thank
you continue representative plaz off
thank you Mr chair uh uh one of the
objections was that uh maybe this bill
is written will create conflict with
other parts of law uh specifically ones
that guide how immunization registry
could be used uh so this suggested
language shows that
uh suggest uh putting this specific use
into the way of immunization registry
can can be used uh
unfortunately
uh uh as we dis as the cus
discussions go there could be uh some
other uh issues with the bill is
currently written for example we heard
about workload that it will be on DHHS
to implement this bill but we didn't
hear much from the people who will be
filling those this
certificates and that's something I
think uh would be appropriate for us to
go through uh interim study hearing uh
to get if Fe back and uh to make sure
that uh dates uh and protocols uh that
suggested by the bill language are
actually uh vocable
and that's why uh I ask you to support
uh my motion to send this bill to entm
study uh even though I I love it
even as written thank you thank you
representative
pmer thank you Mr chair um I I certainly
support interim study because as I think
I said at that hearing is that the being
someone who fills out a lot of death
certificates accessing
the immunization
information would be almost impossible
so um we at least need to solve that
problem before going
forward thank you other
questions saying none okay motion is uh
FN representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Thomas
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter
upam representative
Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative tez
yes and representative McDonald yes 19
to
one um can that go on that can go on
consent as far as I'm concerned you okay
with that there's no objection no
uh Mr chairman uh yes representative
Merchant the prior Bill we had a fiscal
note on it therefore we couldn't go
through consent this one also has a
fiscal note so want to be sure we
consistent um it it it's going to
interim study so we're not actually
appropriate
money thank you that's why I asked it's
only when you it's only when you
actually appropriate the money that it's
got to go before a vote of the
house thank you thank you uh next up is
a HB 1669 FN and representative uh Lon
recognized yes uh sorry let me find my
if I can cheat off of somebody I'd like
to introduce the amendment um that I had
2024-25
69 you want to keep it and oh sure we
can work off of
this and I'll second that okay
representative kushman seconds
representative land would you like to
speak to your motion um yes thank you Mr
chairman um in this bill it in the
amendment it strips out that last line
that would have provided for the
Department to provide people's
information on request of the individual
to other states I's um it's really not I
when I had that in the bill initially I
thought that that would be a helpful
move but that actually complicates
everything people's medical records and
immunization records are already at
their providers and if they wanted to
share it elsewhere they're able to do so
um so this just keeps it clean saying
that our IIs system which is the last
one that was stood up within the country
um and does not currently share
information with any other states will
not share any information until they can
the department can assure that
withdrawals under paragraph 3A will be
honored by the organization um and
that's our withdrawal from the vaccine
registry so this by removing that
sentence we removed a $3 million
sentence there still is a cost because
it would require any process when we do
build out the I IIs uh sharing system to
make sure that there's a log report so
that whenever somebody's information is
sent to another state if that person
then later withdraws they need to be be
able to tell that other state to remove
that record because that person is
withdrawn under New Hampshire state law
and therefore they shouldn't be held in
those other states um so I think that
this is about as clear as it can be um I
would think that it probably could be
done within the bidding process as we
start to integrate with other states but
I recognize there's a cost in everything
we asked the department to do so I
appreciate that they were willing to
look at it and uh work with me to remove
the $3 million
line okay representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um just
want to make uh a short remark uh of
course I support this bill and I I thank
the representative for um that Amendment
and um this is something that's not
really optional this is protecting
constitutional rights under part one
article 2B the right to privacy so any
logistical issues that come up um we
definitely need to contain costs where
we can but um if there's one place that
it's appropriate for government to um
expend money it's to protect the rights
of the citizens of the state and so I I
really would appreciate everyone voting
in favor of this um and supporting those
rights thank you thank you other
Shapiro thank you U Mr chairman and
um Imagining the kind of harm or damage
that can be done if we don't do this so
could maybe you give me an example of um
the harm that would come to individuals
if they were
initially um their vaccines were
recorded in the
registry it got the information got sent
to another organization which it doesn't
now
um for some kind of research perhaps and
um in the names of an individual
couldn't be withdrawn what what what is
the potential harm we're trying to
um prevent well thank you for the
question I think the easiest way to look
at it would be that if instead of having
an immunization information system if we
had an abortion information system and
data was shared and then withdrawn think
about it about the privacy issues around
those areas that are most critical to
you and recognize that if you were
involved in any registry and then chose
to remove your
information would it be important to you
that the state follows through
consistent with the Constitution to
protect your personal privacy and remove
that from those with whom they've shared
the sh shared the information I want to
make sure that we're setting a good
solid groundwork about how we handle
information regardless of what group is
impacted through them because I I can't
imagine that you would ever have a
problem with anybody sharing your
immunization information but there's
other people that do and there's things
that that you would never think of
sharing that other people share freely
so I think that we need to respect the
rights of all and that as we build it
out it's necessary to make sure that any
implementation is consistent with our
Constitution and given that there's a
question about this I think that makes
it even more important that we put this
into
law representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman so here are my concerns with
the bill even as as a I appreciate the
amendment but here are my concerns with
the
um as I understand it um the the
issue as as
drafted it pertains to all data and it
doesn't specify whether that data is is
identified or deidentified that's item
number one so it seems to me that it
might prohibit the sharing of
deidentified data unless there was a way
of clawing back after it was shared and
that I don't know how that mechanism
would work but it doesn't seem to me
that it would be very
workable um the second issue that I
would have would be that
um in General people who don't want this
information shared do not send their
information to the registry at all
because they don't want their
information shared and that is their
right and that is their right under our
law so I'm not certain why we
are
um why we are taking this next step of
prohibiting um that which is um
difficult
to sort to to claw back once we've
shared it because there's no there's no
time thing here there's there's no
limitation on when the clawback happens
as far as I can tell representative Bon
um thank you and thank you for raising
those issues representative Weber um in
a perfect world where anybody who has
entered into the IIs did so voluntarily
um I think that second argument would
have a lot more strength however during
the initial roll out of the covid
vaccines the only way that we were able
to access those vaccines from the
federal government was to implement and
stand up our IIs system and we did not
have any opt out mechanisms because it
was required for tracking to make sure
that none of those were diverted or
given anywhere else um it was a
requirement so anybody who was doing
what they believed was their civic duty
and the right thing to do and received a
CO vaccination at the National Guard
sites or anywhere else early on were a
automatically includ included in the IIs
so anybody who doesn't want that
information shared um at this point if
they did that their information's in so
they need to be able to
withdraw
secondly I'm I'm sorry the first the
first one you raised was identified and
deidentified right this immunization
registry is specifically listed as a
single repository of accurate complete
and current immunization records to Aid
coordinate and promote effective and
cost-efficient disease prevention and
control efforts there is nothing that I
see and hear about any deidentified
information and this is intended
specifically to be able to link an
individual with their vaccination record
um I recognized that this was this was
the backbone which was part of the idea
of being able to present a pass um such
as uh royant Ventures was one of the
areas that talked about having a app on
your phone that would link to the IIs
information so you could show people
that you'd Had Your Shot so you could
participate in
society what if we found that there were
issues with it and you didn't want to
show that you had your shots because
there had been a public backlash we want
to make sure that we can we can provide
people's privacy and I'm sorry that was
probably going off on a Ledge on that
idea but this is your information you
have a right to it and the state does
not have a right to share your
information in consistent with the
Constitution representative Weber my
concern is the use of the specific word
data as opposed to the records and and
data to me speaks in its plain form of
you
know
2,187 people have had vaccines I don't
know whether that's shared or not but um
I think that those are two different
categories and without more information
I I would be Lo to adopt this broad
language representative Leon um with
that I will submit it for redrafting
with the patient record with the correct
language within that so that we can
remove that objection okay I'm going to
vote for it against it anyway but I
think that that would be a better
formulation I think representative
Merchant has representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman I'm a
strong supporter of personal privacy
I've always come down on that side of
the
fence however I do see with this bill on
end consequences at least with the
amendment that's being
proposed I follow with represent Weber
about the issue with data my concern is
this if I'm a provider and I extract
data from the
registry and I put it in my patient's
medical chart or if I'm a pharmacist
putting in records I have at the
pharmacy therefore I have been quote
with the Department sharing that data
with me as a
provider is the department that
therefore going to have to notify every
single person who accessed that data and
that be sure that they withdraw that
data from the medical record and so
forth because that's what the intent is
number two just so we understand about
privacy that when you have a vacine and
it's built to an insurance company it
probably goes through a pharmacy benefit
manager it also goes into the state's
medical claim data so therefore the
Privacy issue we're talking about which
we're trying to guard with the State
goes beyond the state so therefore if
you ever go into a provider's office and
they have a record of all of your drugs
vaccines and so forth most of the time
it did not come from the state it came
from the insurance industry through pbms
so therefore even though we're trying to
lock it down with the state that's a
small part of it because there are other
avenues in which our data is being
shared with healthc care providers and
so forth that this build is not address
at
all representative Leon U thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for raising those
issues representative Merchant once this
information enters a provider's records
by federal law it's required to be
retained for seven years there is
absolutely nothing that can be done to
change that and any withdrawal from the
registry would not impact that because
of the hip Hippa requirements for the
for the retention of those patient
records it's a matter of whether or not
the New Hampshire information
immunization information system can
share that information with other bodies
as opposed to what happens when that
what happens within the doctor's
office representative Merchant thank
you the way I read this if I understand
it correctly the department has to
assure withdrawal of the
information honored by that organization
so therefore if I understand what I just
heard if the Federal Law requires 7
years retaining other Hippa am I not in
a pickle because what this is telling me
I have to pull the data out of the
medical record but the federal law is
saying I can't I just think this bill
has well intended but there's unintended
consequences I think we need to think
through and I would recommend that we go
to interim study with this
bill representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman um you have both raised some
wonderful points that I will bring in a
floor Amendment if uh we move move
forward with this at or move it as um to
try and have it drafted by today to have
that replace this amendment I would
instead make it so that it's not share
um and whatever the correct words are
for the personal um personal registry
information and not share with another
state IM immunization information system
which is not required as a provider to
retain those records under federal law
that's a provider specific requirement
so I would ask um those of us who were
who believe in the intent of the this
and believe that personal information is
personal and that the New Hampshire
Constitution means something to vote for
this amendment and um then to vote in
favor of a to pass as
amended U representative Shapero and
then representative point of order okay
I'm sorry representative
Weber if there's going to be a new
Amendment then I don't see why we're
voting for this amendment if if I
mean representative Lon
thank you uh my question would be how we
recognize that because I know that a
committee report um that comes out from
the bill report especially in a without
recommendation situation can reference a
different amendment that has not yet
been
drafted it absolutely can
um so then would it be order if we had
an ought to pass is amended and then
change which amendment or would it be
more appropriately in order to Simply
move out to pass and then have our
position be ought to pass with the other
Amendment well I'm on the other side of
that so I'm going to let you untangle it
I'm I just wanted to point out that we
can't vote on an amendment we haven't
seen so um if you want to proceed with
this
amendment okay um thank you I'll count
on you to raise that issue in the future
when we have this as well representative
Shapiro and then representative Merchant
yes thank you Mr chairman um in in
regard to the previous legislation that
we passed which people to withdraw um
their vaccine information that was um
put into the registry um during the
emergency when people didn't have a
choice um pardon me for not remembering
but did we create any time frame so that
people had to make a decision about
withdrawing their vaccine information by
a certain date or is this just an
ongoing situation that they can do it at
any time and so will this kind of affect
this situation into the into the future
maybe the very far future this is
ongoing because there's both the issue
of those people who were involuntarily
enrolled in the IIs there's others who
may not have recognized what they saw
when they had the optin or opt out
language and there's people that changed
their mind right so there's no time
frame there's no time frame thank you
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chairman I'd be more than glad to work
represent of Lon with language on a an
amendment to the bill I think if we can
put our heads together there's ways to
draft this in a way
that minimizes at least from my point of
view some of the unintended consequences
I spoke
to representative Lon uh for
clarification are you talking about the
time frame in order for us to meet this
are you talking about recommending
interim study um in L of interim study
um talking
about meeting and talking about an
amendment to address some of the
unattended consequences I spoke to which
means we probably could have an
amendment back for exec session next
week I would agree to that I'd be
willing to withdraw my offering of
amendment uh
032 0302 H and I'll withdraw my second
okay um representative Prima you had
your hand up earlier and I'm sorry I
overlooked you um no that's that's okay
my question's been answered thanks okay
great all right so you've read uh
representative leyon has withdrawn her
motion and so has and the second has
been withdrawn by representative kushman
so at this point we'll we'll pass over
this bill and continue to next week uh
yes probably to the 14th because we
already have a bill continued to the
14th okay all right we'll continue HB
14th and then the last bill this morning
and for
be considered an executive session is HB
1693 and I would recognize
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman I move interim study on House
Bill
1693 I'll second second it I'll be very
second okay representative L do you wish
to speak to your motion um thank you Mr
chairman um the bill that was presented
to us would have replicated the
therapeutic cannabis program for
psychedelics I don't think that that the
correct approach however if we're paying
attention to what's happening both in
Massachusetts where they have a clinic
where they're using psilocybin um for
some of their patients and where New
Hampshire patients fall behind
Massachusetts patients for Access and if
we look at the fact that the Veterans
Administration is beginning to look at
siloc cybin and other psychedelics for
PTSD and other um other very important
very devastating illnesses I believe
that we should work on this so that we
can figure out how to ensure that
patients in New Hampshire are not denied
access to clinical trials or other very
very narrowly car carved out uses that
are consistent with the emerging
knowledge around psychedelics for these
you know life de life life impacting and
sometimes life-ending consequences um I
just want to make sure that we're not
hampering our veterans and that we're
not hampering um any providers who are
already providing this care out of state
who do have offices and office hours in
New
Hampshire discussion representative
Shapiro yes I'm I'm in agreement with
interim study I I
um I think that this is probably a good
idea um personally I had just had no way
to know whether this very long involved
bill is the best way to do it so I hope
um interim study will really involve
study so that we can figure out a way to
do this um in a way that's safe in a way
um having use of these psychedelics are
also having the helpful therapeutic
structure to deal with them um I so I'm
I basically agree I just hope that
interim study is really about um I don't
know if it's who it will be but people
really studying to to figure out the
best way to make this
available
representative Nel thank you Mr chairman
I I when I saw this bill originally um
I'm on a couple committees that have to
do with opioids and cannabis and um I
really think that we have significant
problems with both drugs that we really
need to solve and my gut Sense on this
bill was the last thing we need to do is
migrate down a third bill that
substantially more harmful potentially
than
cannabis um with that said when um am I
allowed to call you by name when the
Vice chair representative land I can do
it here I'm not going to get yelled at
like I did when I said that at the floor
okay
um um when she pointed out what she said
I mean I have a lot I have several
patients that are you know that use
psychedelics totally illegally and I'm
also very aware of other patients that
are in trials for very you know
refractory problems that I thought that
that was a really great strategy and a
really reasonable thing to do and I
don't think we should close the door on
that so I think in term studies are
great was a great solution for this
discussion representative Lon uh thank
you as a medical device analyst I
covered things for treatment resistant
depression I want to have that long of
different possible therapies before
people choose to stop participating in
life to be as many therapies as we can
get Because treatment resistant
depression is
terrible other
discussion seeing none motion is interim
study on HB 1693 FN I'll ask the
collector call the all representative
Lon yeah representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofel yes representative
Thomas yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative
Nagel
POF
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
frus representative Canon yes
representative n upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes represent Murphy
yes represent Palmer yes
representative taes yes and represent
McDonald yes 20 to
zero okay Mo consent okay there's no
objection we'll put that on the consent
calendar that concludes our executive
session for this morning we are
scheduled to resume hearings at 1 pm
thank you everyone we stand adjourned I
recessed
rather on the last one that
was a
chus representative Weber gets the gets
I pied representative
me
for
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs we
have four bills that we're going to be
hearing this afternoon the first one uh
is uh House Bill 1663 FN uh the prime
sponsor is representative Erica Leon the
vice chairman of this committee and I'd
invite representative Leon uh forward at
this
time thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um today I am here to
introduce House Bill 1660 3 um as we
discuss many times in this committee
privacy is important and we all know
that in 2018 we strengthened our
constitutional protection for privacy um
which states that an individual's right
to live free from governmental intrusion
in private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent in 2018
over 82% of New Hampshire voters approve
that amendment to the
Constitution in recent years there's
been a lot of misunderstanding about
what Hippa does everybody speaks to me
about how Hippa protects privacy but
Hippa does not protect privacy that's
not its main function its main function
is for portability of information
between different entities involved in
the health care space Not Just patient
care but the larger Health Care sphere
and about the accountability when those
bodies use that information outside of
what's prescribed in
law in what is unfortunately too rare of
a case but is the case here the federal
statute specifically states that if
state law is more restrictive the state
law has Supremacy over Hippa so this is
one of the areas where it is important
for those States who think that the
Federal Bar is too low on privacy to
make sure that their state laws reflect
their attitude we here in the live for
your die State have something that um is
stronger than many states um here in the
bill it's on the bottom of page two it
the person who holds your record or
should it be you the owner of your
medical record there are many reasons
why we need to share these records if
you think about the fact that you want
to make sure that you have coordination
of care and when you go to the emergency
room or to a specialist you want to
share your information um there'll be a
form provided later that shows what the
current transfer is from conquered
Hospital somebody um has else will be
introducing that later and we already do
have methods to make sure that we can do
it I haven't seen any forms that would
actually violate this because the
statute does not require you to
designate that I would only be going to
Dr Murphy and not anybody else in his
practice it would designate his practice
or designate any other larger entity
what this does do is that it makes it
harder to sort of Market your
information um we love data here there's
a lot of data we want but we're very
careful about personal privacy and how
we access that and we ran up against
that earlier today and run up against
that constantly every session uh right
now without more restrictive state law
any covered Health entities under Hippa
have pretty broad access to your
information so I have some language um
that had some help from um the Citizens
Council for health freedom I spoke with
them this Summer because Minnesota has
excellent privacy protection that is a
good model one that if we adopt should
be integrated appropriately into our
statutes but has been very functional
for many years and there is excellent
Healthcare in Minnesota there's it's
actually a hot bed for cardiac device
development you know if you're going to
need an ICD that's not a bad place to be
um so in my drafting of the bill I had
the big question do I do this as a
replace all because there are a lot of
different areas that have been deleted
from current law through repeals or do I
do it and work into the prior structure
deciding between the two I thought it
made more sense to be Co cohesive and
take all of this information
together but I think there also may be
some misunderstandings from people
behind me um that may or may not know
that some of what's included in this
already is New Hampshire law um for the
committee's benefit if you'd rather see
this as not a replace all but one that's
just amending the current statutes
that's something I could have drafted
with any other input we have so that we
can have a more apples to apples and
leave all the deleted sections um
previously the state of New Hampshire
had looked into setting up a health
information Exchange those were allowed
under the high-tech act they were funded
federally but New Hampshire never took
that money we never stood one up um I
know that many of these other issues
like the IIs was delayed for many many
many years because of privacy concerns
um so because of that I'm not surprised
that we never opened up a health
information exchange um in my dialogue
from the Department um I believe that
they found that it actually was not
going to be cost effective for the state
to do it so we work with private
entities instead and those sections were
repealed it may make sense to keep that
repeal in the legislative and the RSA
record going forward so that's one of my
reasons why I may pivot to changing that
ultimately the whole point here is we
need to make sure that people's private
medical records are their private
medical records there's already um
there's already something that allows
for people to release their records to
NEX ofkin when they're dead but the
question is do you want to make sure
that somebody can say remove certain
parts of their record you know hope on
I'm not making it an appropriate joke
but we're the health and human services
and elderly Affairs committee if there's
anybody who's really involved in their
elderly Affairs and they're also getting
checked for infections that may spread
um that may be something that they want
redacted from their record because they
may not want their children to know that
they had a highly social life in their
later years but we don't want somebody
who's afraid of that information being
shared with their kids to keep them from
getting that care so while it may be
more of a hassle to allow um it's in on
page8 starts at line 18 saying that
prior to death a patient may designate
their medical record or any portion of
it as private to not be released without
an order from a court of competent
jurisdiction it may seem like a hassle
but if this means that we can that sorry
I'm not going to go there if that means
that people can go ahead and get the
information that they need the healthc
care treatment that they need and not be
afraid of what it's going to look like
to their loved ones I think that that's
that's a worthwhile step so there's a
lot of different details on this you
guys know where to find me but I am
happy to any answer any questions and
I'm glad we're starting this
Weber thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you for your note about the fact
that you chose the reenact reenactment
rather than a replacement or a
replacement rather than a line by line
reenactment um I was wondering if
whichever form we uh if we keep this
form perhaps we could get a side bys
side comparison from our researcher as
to what so we have really clear Notions
for ourself as to what was in because I
started out immediately and thought well
about those copying costs and of course
that's exactly the same as the existing
statute so um I'm wondering if a side by
side might
be something it would be helpful for
me okay yeah all right thank you thank
you sure yes representative kofalt and
then representative TZ thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so um during the uh height of
the covid epidemic us
HHS carved out certain exemptions for
Hippa one of those was release of
information about covid infection to law
enforcement
or Emergency Medical Services who may be
coming into contact with a person who is
infected um would you be amenable to uh
something that
would ensure that that kind of
information could be shared if it is
necessary for the for the safety and
protection of of the individuals
involved well thank you for the question
I mean that's that's one of the areas
where we need to figure out where that
intersection is you know a lot of this
I'd want to look and see how we treated
things during the AIDS and HIV to see
what our reaction was because that was
very important to protect but also look
at our experience from covid so I'd be
very happy to look at that I just want
to make sure we take a multi-decade look
instead of just a multi-year
look representative TZ hi thank you for
taking my question just a quick uh
wondering uh can you explain the
illustrative example you use because I'm
not famar with children getting the
medical records of their
parents um yes so that is actually
already in statute that it would allow
the medical records to be released um a
lot of that I believe I I don't
understand the entire legislative
history in that and simply what I did
was allow them to redact part of their
record should they want to so a lot of
that was already within existing law um
I just think that it'd be very important
to be able to redact anything that you
view view as too sensitive uh hopefully
a provider if you're trying to redact
the fact that you've had ovarian cancer
as a woman young they may encourage you
to let your children know because things
like young ovarian cancer run in
families and that's one of one of the
reasons I would assume that we have the
ability to get your your parents medical
record after they pass um but that's
something I'd be willing to talk about
as well I just wanted to increase the
Privacy protections for that individual
in the scheme of what we already had and
I didn't want to take even though it
looks like I took a big red marker to
the statue sh I was trying to be rather
surgical as to what I added so I
apologize for making that six in one
half a dozen and the other choice to do
a replace all um but in my mind it was
clearer and easier to read but now I'm
recognizing the challenge I put you in
so I apologize for not having better
comparison
language representative palazov thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking uh
my question um my my biggest concern is
potential uh abuse of this uh uh
privacies laws to hide important
medical information from the public and
uh uh can you explain me more about the
the certificates how how how it came
about because um the way it reads in
Constitution it sounds like the Privacy
Is For Living people and suddenly we are
starting reducting the certificate and
closing them uh from the public and even
from state representatives and uh in my
view it it stops important
investigations about potential uh uh
epidemic data uh going on thank you uh
well thank you um so I didn't make many
changes to the section that allows the
medical records of the deceased spouse
of or next of kin uh so this was an area
that largely was there I'm not sure that
that really has a lot to do with how
it's disclosed with any other person um
but I I recog I recognize where you're
coming from on that and I'm willing to
have a discussion I just want to want to
look at sort of what we already have and
how to make sure that we're making it um
as strong for that personal privacy for
things where you may not get care for
potential sexually transmitted
infections or anything else that you may
be embarrassed by so I'm happy to have
the conversation offline on that
representative dep
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh my question is about
since I work in Vermont but on the state
line and we share all of the state line
facilities we have a mix of both in my
case New Hampshire and Vermont residents
and how how a hospital is going to or a
off Doctor's practice is going to deal
with maybe two sets of of
confidentiality rules um and
I mean I just thought of this I have no
idea whether it's going to be a problem
or not but I just wondered if you have
any perspective on that um well thank
you I would hope that the hospital would
choose to use the most personally
protective set of laws and just use
either Vermont or New Hampshire
whichever is more protective of personal
information um it actually would be
great um I'll probably take a look or
see if our researcher can look at what
Vermont's laws are on it because they
may have may have some great personal
privacy protection because I know that
they're also a very independent state
and maybe we can figure out something
that maybe they'll adopt after us so
that we can have a by state sort of uh
not officially but in essence have two
states standing together to protect
people's privacy so thank you for
bringing that up because we do have lots
of crossb um crossb
Merchant and thank you Mr chairman also
thank you for Leon taking my
question this is probably more for the
chair than it is you per se as a sponsor
of the
bill since we talked about this
in your testimony about Minnesota having
I went online and looked at it could we
ask the researcher to look at the
Minnesota law in comparison to this law
because if what's in Minnesota seems to
be
working then there may be a way to take
that as the model to build upon but I
don't understand enough between the two
or do I have the time to do a comparison
between the two so Mr chairman if we
could ask the researcher to compare this
bill to the Minnesota bill would be
helpful to me um thank you and I'll
respond to that as well I do have two
people that flew in from Minnesota who
will be testifying later so they'll be
able to start that conversation but I
think we should continue it on our own
as well so thank you and the researcher
just nodded so it's all set thank you
thank you other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you thank you oh representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um who are
the other entities that might be able to
um view someone's medical records under
Hippa if this bill is not passed well
thank you for that question um I think
that that's something that there may be
other people testifying who can better
answer that because but I do know that I
think there's something like 63
different groups of people not all of
them are directly involved in patient
care um some of them are involved in
research some of um the way that it's
defined under Hippa is actually very
very Broad and the number of covered
entities is a lot more than many of us
would assume so um I can I can follow up
by email on that but I think there may
be some people who are better prepared
to answer that so thank
you other
you uh just to remind everybody about
the policy that we have or the practice
we have here in the committee uh we give
the prime sponsor extra time because
they explain the background of the bill
why it was filed and so forth and then
we ask um everyone else to keep their
testimony down to three minutes so that
everybody has a a fair chance to testify
uh subsequently uh next up is a Patricia
Tilly from the Department of Health and
Human
Services I think You' asked if of
someone else but they had deferred to
so good afternoon thank you my name is
Patricia Tilly for the record I am an
associate commissioner at the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services um I have draw drawn the Short
Straw from the Department to provide
some information today on this very
complex and comprehensive
bill um as you've heard 1663 would
repeal and replace RSA
332i in its entirety and because it
requires such a careful legal and
subject matter review we cannot at this
time State definitively what the legal
data system clinical care and public
health impacts for the department will
be and for our Statewide Partners our
legal team has begun to do that side by
side but we will appreciate any
additional efforts from the committee to
continue to get some clarity in that
space um we know that others are going
to provide testimony that better
represents the impact to Health Care
Systems and health plans they will
provide their information and that said
I've provided this written testimony
that highlights some of the areas where
the department has questions and
concerns it's important to note that the
department is a unique test case for
these changes as we are both a healthc
care provider and we electronically
receive protected health information as
a state health agency we hold these two
distinct roles and so there's some
complexities here that have to be
managed about how we even talk
internally to ourselves as well as how
we talk to the the broader Community a
complete repeal and replace it could
fundamentally change not only the
processes our contract requirements and
public health functions it also could
impact direct patient care at New
Hampshire hospital Hamstead hospital and
Glen Cliffe home the proposed changes
are going to create some challenges for
the department and we'd be interested to
see if a state like Minnesota how they
navigated those issues especially with
regard to some of the um exceptions that
are built into Hippa right now of
significant concern to us are changes
from the current law conflict with
existing state and federal statutes
pertaining to communicable diseases
cancer and lead poisoning the department
is concerned that for all of these
reasons we are worried about a that
there may be delays in care and it will
impact patient safety and outcomes if
you want to waade into the detail um we
are looking that there are some
undefined terms such as health
information consent research there new
definitions have been M have been
created the current law defines business
associate use disclosure there are
several areas of the bill where terms
may not be consistently used and I think
that that's an opportunity for
improvement for um an an example of that
1663 creates a new definition of
business associate this is of incredible
importance us as we think about
Contracting in the state of Department
uh the department and how we contract
with our state agencies the while the
intent I know is been to broaden and
strengthen the Privacy protections the
lack of clarity potentially shifts some
legal liability to the department and
has the potential to increase costs um
by creating an unfavorable negotiating
position for the Department um which
will have to prove a particular scope of
work includes quote certain functions or
activities of a business associate it's
just complex and we need to learn some
more about that um one of the issues
that is Contin uh that we are
highlighting are the areas around
consent and new um definitions of
informed affirmation because this is a
new term it's unclear how to
operationalize or provide guidance to
our department business associates um I
think I heard that Bell right there I
will um wrap up by saying the proposed
language also significantly creates a
conflict with RSA 141c and may prevent
the department from receiving
information needed to stop communicable
diseases it was our understanding in the
bill one would need to consent to send
information to the department I.E
someone has ebola in a hospital they
would need to consent to send that to
the hospital a a child has measles and
attends Child Care um that family would
have to consent to send that information
to the State Health Department that
could put significant people at risk
okay any questions representative Seth
King thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony um throughout the second
part of your testimony it says HB 1664
is that just a typo typo thank
questions see none thank you thank you
thought also signed up to speak is Ben
Association good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Ben Bradley I'm the
vice president of state government
relations with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association we represent all
the state's acute care hospitals as well
as all specialty hospitals in New
Hampshire um the hospital Association is
opposed to HB 1663 and would like to
share a few of our concerns for the
committee's consideration first I want
to share that the hospital Association
agrees with the importance of
safeguarding protected health
information hospitals and and other
healthc care providers zealously guard
patient information and under current
state and federal laws and regulations
face substantial financial and
reputational penalties should they fail
to comply with existing privacy and
security requirements We Believe 1663
goes far beyond the confidentiality of
medical records and puts up barriers to
Medical Care that have significant
consequences to patients throughout the
granite state we understand the 2018
privacy Amendment to the New Hampshire
Constitution codified the right to
privacy the legislature should not be
empowered to enact laws that would
prevent patients from getting quality
care when and where they need it we
support the right to privacy the
Constitutional amendment was never
intended to inhibit timely access to
here this bill will confound healthc
care operations as it undermines the
three essential provisions of treatment
payment and Health Care operations
authorized by the federal health
insurance portability and accountability
act Hippa those three Provisions support
timely access to appropriate Health Care
especially for the most vulnerable
populations timely processing of
insurance payments on behalf of patients
and the supports and services Healthcare
entities employ to meet meet patient
needs and regulatory requirements
further this bill would complicate the
coordination and support of patient care
across state lines as many individuals
seek care both in New Hampshire and out
of
state Hippa authorizes healthc care
providers to share patient information
for the specific purpose of treating the
patient sharing information to and from
the patient's insurance carrier for
payment and for Health Care operations
the provider is authorized to share
their patients information for these
specific purposes without having
patients sign conf send forms each time
because exchanging medical information
for these purposes is essential for the
effective operation of our health care
System the removal of currently
permissible information sharing for
treatment payment and operations will
all healthc care providers in
New Hampshire including but not limited
to hospitals Community Mental Health
Centers Primary Care Specialty Care
dentists our doorway program federally
qualified Health Centers rehabilitation
centers and long-term care
facilities 1663 eliminates these three
critical Pathways and instead requires
consent for each individual provider to
send and to receive information about
their patients one example this would
mean patients would be required to
provide written consent before a
provider could contact their insurance
provider not just for payment but also
for prior authorization if a patient
does not consent to the provider sending
information to the patient's insurance
carrier the bill for that service could
be sent to the patient even if the
service would have been 100% paid for by
the insurance company you could start
wrapping up please I will on barriers to
discharge one of the unintended
consequences of this bill is that it
would further exacerbate existing
barriers to discharge disproportionately
impacting many of our most vulnerable
citizens we're also concerned about the
Bill's requirement for a provider to be
specifically named in the consent as a
result patients will not be permitted to
allow access to their records to an
entire practice or health system for
example if a primary care provider
refers a patient to a neurology uh
consultation the patient will need to
sign a release that specifically names
the exact neurologist who can access the
patient record should that neurologist
be unexpectedly unavailable no other
provider in their practice will be able
to see the patients charge start to
cover an appointment or to make time
sensitive decisions about care we
understand the intent of the bill um
however we believe RSA 332i already
affords these Protections in line with
the right to privacy Constitutional
Amendment and in tandem with HIPPA for
these reasons we can't support hb1 1663
and I'm happy to take your questions
thank you representative Merchant thank
you Mr chairman
also H have you as not you personally
but the hospital Association New
Hampshire reached out to your peers in
the state of Minnesota to understand how
this bill compares to their bill
no would
you uh we're happy to participate in the
questions seeing none okay thank you
chairman
also signed up to speak is Courtney
Health afternoon good afternoon um for
the record Courtney Tanner I'm senior
director of government relations at
Dartmouth Health um I want to underscore
the testimony that Ben just gave and
want to just draw a finer point on a
couple of different um couple of other
concerns that we
have uh first it's clear if House Bill
1663 would include or preclude Hippa
principles for example there are many um
there are many points in this uh this
bill is drafted where there is no
definition for example the term person
is not defined um and it's unclear
whether or not uh we would be using
Hippa defined um the Hippa defined term
as as person there are other terms that
likely are intended to be terms of art
but it's they are used interchangeably
in this bill for example medical record
health information protecting
information um without a definition and
um H using them interchangeably there's
a lot of questions and concerns about
the drafting of this bill we ALS there's
also um parts of this bill as drafted
that are just unclear so um for the
purposes of preparing for this for this
hearing uh we had to make some
assumptions and draw some lines but if
passed House Bill six six 1663 um would
really B com really burden an already
overburden Health Care system for
example this bill would require
accounting um uh accounting disclosures
so every single time a provider logs
into the EM an EMR um we made the
Assumption as the bill is drafted that
uh there would need to be an audit Trail
created this would even require
non-providers to um to document in the
EMR nurses um um pharmacist Care
Management PT respiratory therapist
occupational therapist what does that
mean for uh is it does that mean that a
pharmacist can't do a med check for a
patient that hasn't consented to access
of the medical
record even when sharing is permissive
there are questions about um whether
providers would be able to share within
the healthcare system so right now at
Dar Hitchcock Medical Center we have 86
patients that are clinically ready for
discharge but we're not able to
discharge them be for a number of
reasons whether that's they're waiting
for their long-term care Medicaid
application to go through don't yet have
a guardian for them we're not able to
share any information about these
patients unless they consent to that
treatment under he um 1663 and so we
have concerns that the bill I drafted is
going to to um require us to do more
than we're already having to
do uh I will just again just want to
underscore Ben's conc concerns that um
that he's raised we have grave concerns
about 1663 and um really would urge the
committee to it the Bill thank you
representative
Weber thank you I was I was just
wondering about that last statement with
respect to um patients who are no longer
medically required to be in the hospital
but are unable to be discharged for lack
of another place to go uh would this
mean that because a a patient for which
a guardianship proceeding had been
filed uh presumably can't consent to
anything you could not share information
about that patient with an appropriate
discharge placement until after the
guardianship had happened yes that is
exactly what that means so that means
that the appointment has to be made um
and a guardian a guardianship paperwork
has to be f
a person has to be found which we're
having a really hard time finding um
Guardians and then the appointment has
to be made yes so we in that time we
could not be um Consulting with
long-term care facilities or other um
organizations that could take these
patients which are more clinically
appropriate for the patient right thank
you representative kosman thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question um so now you've got me
thinking how are those handled with
there's a guardianship pending um how
are clinical decisions made during that
time when the patient can't
consent and you don't have a guardian in
place who makes the decisions during
that time so there there are um there's
allowable medical care for for emergent
um times but we cannot TR we cannot work
on transfers of care for patients when
there's no guardianship
placed follow up follow up um do you do
you utilize surrogates in that in that
situation where if they've named someone
to make those decisions during that time
that potentially I mean every
circumstance is different but there are
these are cases that are um pretty
complex mental health patients patients
experiencing dementia and so there are
Provisions that allow uh medically
necessary care for that for those
patients I have one more followup one
more followup so I'm just curious you
said you said emergent care but now you
say medically
necessary um which isn't always
emergent so I mean you could say that
prescribing a medication is medically
necessary but then someone has to
consent for that so are you saying that
the hospital right now is consenting for
orders like that for patients who are
pending a
guardianship well the hospital wouldn't
consent the hospital's providing care
right but who is consenting for the
patient in that instance
there there are circumstances that there
are there's allowable treatment for
medically necessary for medical
necessity care and I see do Dr Palmer's
trying to save me over
here representative
Palmer thank you CH Mr chairman um May I
just give an example so um we have the
same problem at Mount Ascutney but many
fewer patients and so they're different
levels but
so the particular one is there's a
patient who let's say there's a patient
who's been admitted with pneumonia they
have dementia they have no family no
nothing we obviously treat them and
continue treatment as long as they're in
the hospital so if you're saying is
there anyone consenting to treatment the
answer is no there's no one to consent
the patient is allowed to refuse so
often you know a patient will spit out
their pills and that's that's that's we
take that but what but the problem is is
that no other facility can begin to look
at this patient um let me rephrase that
right now we can send records to say a
nursing home to look at it to say oh yes
this patient would be appropriate for
our nursing home once they have a
guardian who can sign all the papers but
I guess the concern with with this bill
is if we can't start that process then
it puts things even further behind and
we we already have people who spend
months in the hospital waiting for this
process to go on and so they're taking
up an acute care bed that could be given
to somebody else and so you just don't
want to delay this any further by having
to wait for the court to to rule get a
guardian and then start the whole
process of looking for a bed that can in
itself even with somebody who has
appropriate guardianship um take months
yeah can I just can I go a little
further with that so we at um there's
only a very small handful of patients
that require a need a guardian at DM
Hitchcock Medical Center the the the
more concerning part of this bill is
also our inability to even start the
process for a long-term care Medicaid
application because we couldn't even
send and communicate with the department
and there are there's a lot more
patients that um are seeking eligibility
for long-term care Medicaid so that they
can transfer to long-term care
facilities
representative merchin and then
representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman also thank
you Mr cour for taking the question the
same question to yourself with Medical
Center being here at New Hampshire and I
know there's a couple fine facilities in
Minnesota what has the dmouth Hitchcock
system done to compare this bill with
what's going on in Minnesota to help
guide us because it seems to be working
in Minnesota I don't understand what's
they're doing that we may be learning
from we have looked at this bill as it
would apply to New Hampshire our ability
to practice and take care of our
patients here in New Hampshire so we
haven't looked at the Minnesota
law representative Shapiro and then
representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking this
question when um I I know that there are
already delays in discharging people and
um who no longer medically need to be in
the hospitals you I hear you saying that
this would um amplify those delays and
um so who who is
reimbursing um Dartmouth health for
people who remain in the hospital after
there's no longer a medical necessity
for them to be in the hospital but
they're
awaiting um placement that maybe don't
exist or maybe there's some kind of
delay in making that transition yeah
that's a great question so um those
patients right now are are at the
hospital and are safe although they're
not clinically appropriate we're not
we're not able to um access
reimbursement for those patients and so
after the Medicaid after their Medicaid
applications are approved and accepted
there sometimes is small retroactive
payment but not
always follow up follow up so does that
um represent a pretty significant hit
for the hospital it's hospital
uncompensated care for us thank you
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you so
much for taking my question um the issue
of patients who access Care on both
sides of the border is an issue for most
of this state because it's a long-
skinny state but um in the days when I
practiced law in in Vermont and many of
my elderly patients were going to come
to Dartmouth Hitchcock for um any s
sever
illness am I not correct that with
respect
to the wherever the patients come from
the law of privacy that would control
would be either the location of the
health care facility or the doctor's
offices so that all the ones am I not
correct in thinking that all the ones in
New Hampshire have to operate under New
Hampshire law and all the ones in
Vermont have to operate under Vermont
law no matter where their patients
reside yeah I believe I believe domicile
is the um is the
controlling I think you're right and I
think that would be a challenging for us
but it would also as you pointed out
would be challenging for other hospitals
on the main border and in the southern
part of the state
yeah representative Merchant if I can
follow up on that question Mr chairman
raises the question then it with tella
Health which state is going to govern
because you could have at least if a
patient goes to Vermont their physical
domiciled in Vermont but when you have
tella Health you can have a provider in
one state and a patient in another state
so which state would Trump that's a
great question I think that's why having
Federal um guidelines and parameters
creates uniformity and we would have
some concerns about this law
passing other questions representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um just
one last question thank you um does the
hospital ass Association have any
opposition to um beginning on line 26 of
the bill on page three um that section
332 D Roman uh 1 colon 3 about the
patients rights and all all of their
rights to the information I'm just
trying to pair down where actually do
health I represent Dartmouth Health um
so I'm on page three
line
[Music]
20 line 26 okay and just the patient
information section so I would have to
review this I mean of course we
certainly want to honor and respect um
all patient rights and um want to uphold
them at all times but would have to
review them I guess if you could repeat
the question um yeah if you need time to
get back to us on it um I was just
wondering if that specific section is
agre able to you or if it if you have
section uh yeah I would we would just
need some time to review the
implications of the section okay but
again the principle is something that
you know we always support patient
rights and privacy always thank
you other questions representative
Weber as a followup is it a concern to
you that we are creating new patients
rights in places other than the statute
that already covers patients rights and
therefore if the specific language we
use in the two different places are
inconsistent we're we're uh creating
issues for health care providers as to
what what they need to follow yes so we
did we did a lot of work in this
committee on our Patient Bill of Rights
a couple sessions ago and um we were
happy to roll our sleeves up with this
committee to do that work I do see a
couple statutory references that we
would be I I just need to review to see
what the implications of passage of of
this provision would do to the
operability of our current Patient Bill
of Rights yes consistencies are
important other
you also signed up to speak is Brianna
hankle with new futures
it's probably more appropriate I'm not
sitting up here
as
okay hello I'm Brianna Hinkle thank you
for listening to my test I'm the legal
policy fellow at new Futures new Futures
is a nonprofit nonpartisan organization
that works to solve New Hampshire's
problems with the policy change um new
future opposes HB 1663 because it
creates hurdles that affect treatment
payment and operations for healthcare as
have already been stated um one um one
issue that I'll focus on is um HB 1663
definition of informed consent would um
challenge hip
prior authorization definition prior
authorization according to the US DHHS
is a higher um standard than informed
consent and it needs informed consent to
um be part of it um one of the issues is
that if a patient leaves out or forgets
to consent to certain health conditions
it could lead to dangerous consequences
additionally this bill is especially
harmful for children with behavioral
health challenges because their team of
providers need to collaborate and this
will make it more challenging thank you
I can take any
questions okay uh any questions sorry if
I talk too fast no that's okay we like
Fast
talkers uh any questions at all I'm
you also signed up to speak is former
representative Neil
Kirk
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Neil Kirk I live in wear and I'm
speaking for myself uh I was the Prime
sponsor of uh the Constitutional privacy
Amendment and I'm very pleased to see
that this bill which I believe is the
first bill to come before the
legislature that attempts to deal with
the issues that that Constitutional
Amendment raises
the Constitutional Amendment affects
government access to personal
information not hospitals this bill
deals with both to the extent it deals
with hospitals the legislature is not
subject to any
constitutional uh restrictions on what
you can do to protect patient privacy
that's truly up to you but the bill the
the amendment deals with government
access to personal information and Pro
prohibits the government from getting
access to that information
unless the the government's access is
absolutely
essential to a government objective and
there is no other way regardless of the
expense or the time there is no other
way for the government to perform that
essential service without acquiring this
information that's a high bar to reach
and I think this
attempts uh despite some of the problems
that others have uh raised it attempts
to do that
um
the Hippa is is is involved in this
obviously Hippa has an exemption for
privacy issues the state can provide
higher privacy protections legally than
Hippa provides and hipper provision of
privacy is minimal at Best in terms of
patient privacy privacy it certainly uh
provides a great deal of security for
medical information but not privacy and
you've heard that distinction U
mentioned a lot of uh people who testify
here say we do everything possible to
protect the security of information but
that's not the issue before you the
issue is privacy that is to say who
should have access and under what
conditions um Health and Human Services
is a complicated Department because they
are both a provider as Miss Tilly said
and an insurer they provide in Services
directly through glencliffe for example
and they provide Insurance Services
through
Medicaid with respect to those I don't
think uh the Constitutional amendment is
is relevant because they are not acting
in effect as a government they're acting
as an insurer or a provider but to the
extent that they do Public Health work
and have access to individuals medical
records for anything other other than
those two insurer or provider functions
then the Constitutional amendment is
involved and that's where it gets
complicated good luck
um you you need to do something you you
really do and it's going to be difficult
but you might consider dividing the bill
into two parts one dealing with the
government access and the other dealing
with hospital and provider access to
patient medical records um I've I've
been involved in a number of bills that
deal with opt outs and opt-ins this bill
is not clear as to exactly what it is
needs to be fleshed out um I provided
the prime sponsor with a whole series of
of questions about issues that were not
clear in the bill and they need to be
clarified um ultimately as I say it's
complicated um I'd be glad to work with
you folks but this is a this is an issue
that does require your best efforts and
you're leading the legislative parade ra
on this there will be many other bills
dealing with many other departments and
many other functions of government where
access to personal information not just
medical information but driver's license
information and so forth is in the hands
of government and the question is is it
absolutely essential is there some other
way that the government function could
be performed other than having access to
this information so you're leading the
parade I wish you the best of luck and
um as I say I'll be glad to help you if
you need it thank you Mr chairman any
you also signed up to speak is Michelle
nhid good afternoon uh you've indicated
five minutes I'd really appreciate if
you keep it to three I will keep it to
three then okay thank you thank you very
much my name is Michelle heon and I'm
here on behalf of the New Hampshire
insurance department I'm the health law
and policy legal council there the
insurance department has some concerns
about HB 1663 in its current form the
definitions included in the bill are
very Broad and it's unclear to the
extent to which it's intended to apply
to the insurance industry health
information is defined in the bill in a
way that includes payment information
but there's very little um discussion or
mention of insurance or payment in other
sections of the bill the term use is
also extremely Broad and would um would
Encompass not only activities um
performed by Health carriers but also
other insurance companies Property and
Casualty Insurance company to the extent
that there was um some kind of accident
benefit associated with it it is unclear
how this bill could also impact claims
reporting requirements um specifically
to the Comprehensive Health Care
information system the chis there's a
slight carve out in the bill for DHHS
programs um but it's not clear if that
would uh cover the chis debt as
well this chis information is vital to
current efforts relating to price
transparency and Health Services and the
health cost New Hampshire Health cost
program there are also Federal uh data
reporting requirements related to health
data it's unclear how this bill could
impact those data requirements um so
that's another thing to keep in mind uh
I think others have made reference to
the term business associate and the
problems with that I'd also point out
that health information exchange it's
unclear if that's intended to include
Health Clearing Houses which include
insurers so um for these reasons the way
it's drafted now it would include
insurance and payment and if it stays
that way we think the insurance
department would need to provide a
fiscal note on this as well and we have
not been asked to do so as of yet
there's also finally one section in the
13 uh sorry 300 332
I3 paragraph if and I'm not sure what is
intended by this section but it's not
clear if they're trying to um impact or
restrict carrier's ability to perform
utilization review or um other Med
medical management techniques so um I
think that could be further clarified
and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any other uh
representative Weber I was just
wondering if you had some subed your
testimony either in writing or to the um
um electronic uh online online I have
not yet but I can provide it I it would
be very helpful because there were a
number of references that I didn't get
and I didn't get them down quick enough
to even know how to ask you again what
they referred to I am happy to make
myself available too if you want follow
up on any of these I do have two that I
can that I can inquire again uh you
refer
chis chis is that yes it's the
comprehensive healthc care information
system it's a program that's a
partnership between the insurance
department and DHHS it the requirement
is that all health insurance have to
report all their claims data to the
system it's used both by DHHS and the
insurance department for a variety of
reasons and it um we it's vital to um
not only price transparency but getting
a lot of very important information
regarding health cost and cost drivers
and it is um what drives our New
Hampshire Health cost program and
website and could I one more followup
thank you very much that's very helpful
and the other question was at the very
end of your testimony you were referring
to 322
I3 and that's as far as I wrote before I
got yeah it's page four St starting at
line six and it says subject to the
terms and conditions of a patient's
insurance plan and um well I I'll just
if I have the page reference I'll be
able to find it thank you yeah it's just
unclear what's intended there thank you
very much representative Shapero thank
you Mr chairman this is a followup to
the um representative's question the
chis is that does that
involve specific data or um identified
data or aggregated
data the data reporting requirement on
the carriers is very specific we have a
set of rules that has a I wouldn't say
hundreds but there's a lot of different
um data points and it is um patient
specific that data is confidential and
it cannot be disclosed publicly but
different agencies like DHHS and
insurance and Department of Justice have
access ACC to that information if we
were going to disclose that information
we could only do it in an aggregate form
and we cannot do anything that would um
include patient
identifiers followup follow up but you
get it is we have access to it it's
housed in a database I'm not exactly
sure goes beyond my understanding but we
at the insurance department do not house
it ourselves but we have access to it
you also signed up to speak is Eileen
Center good afternoon and thanks for
giving me some time and thanks for
giving this important bill the hearing
that I think it certainly deserves I
speak to to you as a over 35y year
registered nurse um currently a nurse
leader at Parkland Medical Center and a
bedside nurse for for many years as well
so in my comments today I really would
focus on just a couple things um
certainly the word confusion has been
used a couple times here today I would
add anxiety and burden um I'm not sure
what what types of PR uh protections
this bill will guarantee that aren't
already currently covered and maybe I'll
tell you a few stories about how that
would play out in the clinical
environment and I'm concerned about um
delays in care and I'm concerned about
the impact of the quality of care when
we sort of flip the tables and
substitute the word privacy for learn
how to manage your care and learn who
should access your care and who
shouldn't so as a recipient of care um
and when I care for family members I
trust the system um and there are some
things that I imagine patients don't
share with their providers
but in general I can't imagine what it
would be like to care for patients and
not have the full picture um an example
my husband goes to see his cardiologist
he decides he doesn't want him to see
the results of his sleep study or you
know how much alcohol he drinks from his
primary care notes I'm very concerned
that we've created a a system there that
isn't going to allow him to have great
care so that kind of confusion and
barrier is a worry to me um others have
talked about the state lines um
concerned about that I wonder um what
what a care team really means right I
want to take my daughter the
pediatrician but if I haven't
illuminated everybody in that department
or that team that can care for her I
don't want to wait for her to get the
care she needs um so those are a couple
key um concerns I have that again I
think play out at the bedside in a way
that could have very negative and un
unintended um consequences for patients
and families and might really undermine
um the true intent of this bill and
happy to take any questions thank you
any
questions our representative kushman
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question um so I
work I work in healthcare too and I'm
also a nurse and um I have found that
often we are already missing pieces of
the medical record um not every uh care
provider who has interacted with a
patient throughout their life um you
know reposit all of that information
into one central place where it's going
to be dropped off with the um you know
if you're transferring a patient you
know it's not going to be dropped off
with them um so since this is providing
protections for privacy and we already
have where how do you square weighing
the fact that the patient wants some
things kept private and that's their
right
and um and we already don't always have
the P the the big picture and we work
around that with um wanting
to um with saying that this how do you
square that where we we have that issue
already and in this case the patient is
you know they're asserting a right to
privacy yeah so I think I'd take the
second question first how I would square
that um you're right that's even with
all the work that's been done with
interoperability it's very hard for say
the Urology practice to know exactly
everything that's been done in your life
before you see them but they do have an
opportunity right now to gather um
relevant evidence and actually nurses
that work on my team do that you know if
you've had a CAT scan last month at
Dartmouth Hitchcock and you're going to
see Dr KES today I'm going to get a hold
of that because he's going to need that
if he's going to talk to you so that's
sort of understood that we don't have
the full picture we have the patient we
have our relationship with the patient
we have um for lack of a better word the
literacy the health literacy of the
patient to say here's what I'm concerned
about for you so in the case of my
husband it would be the cardiologist
saying I don't know if you're a Beer
Drinker but beer and a fib are linked
and that's probably something you want
to think about so you know my point is I
think we introduce artificial and
unnecessary barriers um in the name of
privacy
um yeah I don't know if that's answered
your question follow
up okay thank you representative palazov
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that information about refusal to take
so-called covid vaccine is used to
remove patients from life saving organ
donation waiting
list absolutely not
um I think you can Google uh time in
Newsweek and read a story about a family
at Parkland that we took care of um who
were M adamantly against vaccination um
we took wonderful care of that family um
and we honor we honor patient and family
wishes our jobs as providers are first
and foremost to uncover what's most
important to you as a patient and care
for you from that end so no followup
thank you for follow up uh and thank you
for taking care of all questions uh uh I
just want to note that my question was
specific about organ donation waiting
lists and so I do believe that things
like that
questions seeing none questions okay
thank you thank
you
Tibido good
afternoon you've asked for five minutes
again please keep it to three yes I will
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Helen Tibido and I'm also a
registered nurse and I'm the chief
clinical and Chief Operating Officer at
Northeast Rehabilitation Hospital
in um four locations here in New
Hampshire Portsmith Salem Manchester and
Nashua so we serve patients throughout
um our
state we provide intensive
rehabilitation services to patients who
suffered lifechanging illnesses or
injuries such as Strokes brain injuries
multiple trauma Orthopedic injuries and
for our patients time is of the essence
we all know the current challenges in
today's Healthcare en environment of
getting the patient to the right level
of care at the right time and we have
concern that H Bill 1663 could create
additional
delays as a rehabilitation hospital CMS
has regulations that require us to
evaluate patients prior to coming to our
Hospital currently we have a secure
release of information with the
safeguards provided by Hippa as has been
discussed to ensure privacy is protected
for these transitions of care
information is coming from the acute
care hospital to our intake teams and
then from those hospitals to insurance
carriers for us to be able to obtain
prior authorization for patients all of
this has to happen before a patient can
even be transferred into our care
currently this can take 5 to seven days
due to authorization requirements House
Bill 1663 could have a potential
negative impact act on access to care
the continuity of care and these
transitions that I speak of with
additional requirements proposed and
this bill could impede our ability to
provide this time sensitive care to our
patients and I would just like to share
the concerns of any delays specifically
related to time sensitivity with the
types of patients that we provide that
we care for so for example the American
Hospital Association the American stroke
associ ation recommend acute rehab for
stroke patients as soon as possible to
maximize brain recovery and that's
called neuroplasticity neuroplasticity
is the brain's ability to be able to
recover or re rewire itself in response
to an
injury the brain's ability to create
these new connections is the only real
hope to regain a normal life for
patients who many of you I'm sure know
who have suffered a stroke but
initiation of that intensive therapy is
time sensitive so delays in
rehabilitation in patients such as these
can lead to lifelong disabilities and
inability to return to their
home the timely transfer records is also
necessary to support our patients return
to the community to their home we share
information to our home health providers
to our primary care physicians to ensure
that the patients have the necessary
support in place to get home and to stay
home delays in our ability to do this
would further cause bottlenecks in
hospitals and an emergency rooms where
we know we have overcrowding at this
time so protecting health information
and ensuring patient privacy is
certainly a responsibility that we take
very seriously and I thank you today for
the opportunity for comments thank you
any questions representative pushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here um so I have a question I
I keep hearing that you know there might
might cause a delay in care and um I
could see maybe in those guardianship
situations where they're waiting for
someone who can actually make those
decisions and sign for the patient but
if we're talking about um discharge from
the
hospital don't you know the entities
that you're going to need to contact and
doesn't the social worker at the
hospital know the entities that you will
be contacting and couldn't you bring a
form to the patient and say do we have
your consent to contact these entities
sure I can um try my best to answer that
um we so Hospital May know where the
patient is going at a patient's request
because a patient is at the center of
their care so a patient may say I'd like
to go to Northeast Rehabilitation and so
now yes there would need to be a
consent proposed under the new bill but
it's unclear as to whether or not that
specifically needs to go to the actual
provider the nurse the physical
therapist that would be going into to
evaluate the patient so that needs some
clarity because we certainly function as
a care team and we may have you know
there's a group of people that could be
evaluating a patient so if it is one
patient it is a patient that is
consenting to a particular provider to
be able to evaluate them but that
changes the next day then there's the
burden of going back to the hospital to
the patient and then back to the rehab
intake as an
example thank you I think the way that I
read the bill was that it said
organizations
um but if we need clarifying language
and we can clarify that to to make it
obvious that it includes the enti
entirety of the staff and the care team
within an organization whether it's an
insurance company or rehab or or cute
care or Home Care um organization would
that um would you support that well that
would certainly assist to clar CL ify
and would be happy to engage in that
discussion but that would assist for
sure other
questions see no other questions thank
you also signed up to speak is Gina
Association and you have some copies to
hand out I do okay can go ahead and do
want you've U you've asked for four
minutes again I can make it in three
thank you thank you good afternoon Mr
chairman and members of the committee
I'm Gina balgus I'm the CEO of the
Granite State home health and hospice
Association which represents over 50
Home Care Hospice and paliative care
providers across the state our members
include visiting nurse associat iations
small privately owned agencies local
offices of national companies large soci
social service agencies and
hospital-based Pala of care providers
home care and hospice agencies are
committed to patient confidentiality
security of patient information and
compliance with HIPPA our organization
regularly provides our members with
training on Hippa requirements and we
believe that the existing federal and
state laws and regulations provide a
strong uh framework for protecting
patient information and privacy we
oppose House Bill 1663 because it
conflicts with the federal Hippa law and
will harm access to care for patients
our position has always been that
whenever Federal Regulations exist State
rules should defer to those just a
moment um respectfully we've before um
asked people to not read their written
testimony is there well I passed out the
written testimony as a favor um but I'd
like to be able to other have done it so
okay you can you can continue um our
position has always been that Federal
Regulations exist uh State rules should
defer to those Federal rules so that
conflict and confusion do not result in
unnecessary negative consequences are
avoided so home care and hospice
agencies are major providers of
postacute care especially for Medicare
and Medicaid beneficiaries and T for as
Medicare certified agencies time is of
the essence Medicare requires that for
home care agencies and hospice agencies
when a referral is made to them they
need to do the initial patient
assessment within 48 Hours of referral
from a physician or from a
hospital so it's really important that
the nurses get into those uh homes
within 48 hours for hospice agencies
while the requirement is 48 I can tell
you that most hospice agencies try to
get to the patient's home the day the
patient is discharged uh or within the
next day because access to care and uh
timely access to care is so
important so these requirements can only
be met if there are timely transfers of
information and that means that uh the
cop patients medical record can be
securely sent from the hospital uh or
electronically accessed um through an
electronic portal I'm really concerned
that the require ments that any type of
Health Care information being
transferred requires written consent
from the patient for each provider is a
major problem so this is this happens
all the time with home care agencies the
hospital case manager is attempting to
discharge a patient home they call one
agency so they're going to need a
consent from the patient to call agency
B but agency I mean to call agency a but
agency a does not have capab capacity to
take that patient within 48 hours so
then they have to call agency B so now
the case manager at the hospital needs
another consent signed to allow them to
contact agency B and agency C this
happens with uh independent case
managers who deal with choices for
independent patients covered by Medicare
they deal with this all the time with
discharging people home from hospitals
so that's going to delay care um on the
other side once that information is
conveyed the way that I read this bill
that in order for the Home Care Agency
to access say the electronic portal to
uh that transfers information between
say the hospital and the Home Care
Agency then the Home Care Agency is
going to have to get another written
consent for the Home Care Agency to
access the portal if you could start
wrapping up please so what that means is
that the Home Care Agency is going to
have to send a nurse to the our physical
therapist to the home first to get that
written consent they'll have no medical
information ahead of time because they
haven't viewed it they haven't had
permission to view it yet and that's
going to delay care as well uh people
have already addressed the interstate
problems that will create chaos and with
all due respect um the our association
uh does not believe that New Hampshire's
medical record Law record laws because
the medical record laws predate the
constittution amendment that it somehow
means that the existing law is not
protective and nor do we believe that
the Constitutional amendment requires
that New Hampshire law be more stringent
than Hippa especially if that change
creates new burdens for patients and
caregivers and certainly not if that
change in law in in um harms access to
care respectfully we ask that you find
this bill inexpedient to legislate thank
you thank you
you also signed up to speak is Ava Hawks
Society good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee thank you for allowing
me to testify today for the record my
name is Ava Hawks and I'm the director
of advocacy for the New Hampshire
Medical Society uh the New Hampshire
medical society and its members The
Physician of the the Physicians of this
state are committed to protecting
patient privacy and confidentiality of
medical records additionally such
steadfast commitment to privacy and
confidentiality are already required and
enforced under state and federal law
house B 1663 however will likely cause
more harm than good as it would make
significant changes to state law
governing medical records and patient
information under RSA 3
332i and would lead to a myate of
unintended consequences negatively
impacting access to care and as such the
medical society opposes this bill
houseb 1663 could significantly disrupt
the valued relationships our state's
Healthcare Providers and their
respective Healthcare institutions have
with their patients this disruption
would be as a result of the proposed
language in this bill conflicting with
current hip of flexibilities that allow
for information sharing with regard to
treatment payment and operations the
provisions of house B 1663 that create
additional and repetitive layers of
consent for sharing and receiving
information among providers insurance
carriers and patients would unduly delay
care in both urgent and non- Urgent
Healthcare instances additionally such
Provisions would also be to the
detriment of public health and safety
reporting measures already in place in
our state and I won't get into that in
my testimony as others have spoken to
that more eloquently particularly our
friend at DHHS Trish Tilly additionally
this legislation would severely restrict
the ability for providers who already
have existing relationships with
patients from accessing and reviewing a
patient's medical record reviewing such
information with other providers who are
already a part of a patient's Healthcare
team similar to a testimony you've heard
from from others this afternoon there
are too many examples to list here today
and I won't do that for you all since I
put 3 minutes on my time card and how
this would not only create barriers to
care but could inadvertently negatively
impact Health outcomes as providers
would not have the full picture through
access to a patient's medical record
when collaborative collaboratively
working with the patient to form a
treatment plan um I would Echo some of
the examples given uh by our friend Ben
Bradley with the hospitals Association
this earlier this afternoon uh we also
have concerns with terminology
throughout the bill being used
interchangeably as you've already heard
with some terms not having clear
definitions throughout the bill for
these reasons we would ask the committee
to recommend an expedient to legislate
as this legislation again could do more
harm than good in protecting granted
saders access to healthcare as this bill
would inadvertently limit or restrict
the freedom of our patients your
constituents receive medical care when
and where they need it I am happy to
take questions and I will do my best to
answer them I am not a doctor but
thankfully you Mr chair have plenty of
doctors on your committee so we do we do
thank you question questions
representative kachman this is just a
point of clarification are you an
attorney I am not okay thank
you other
you also signed up to speak is TWA
cchf
chair my name is Twila Braes I am I
wasn't even
close I am a president and co-founder of
Citizens Council for health freedom and
I am from the great state of Minnesota
and I have never been to New Hampshire
and I'm very happy to be here so um I am
also a former uh emergency room nurse
and so have practiced with lots of
patients so thank you for hearing this
important bill we support HB 1663 for
four reasons first privacy is the
foundation of freedom justice Lewis
brandise once wrote privacy protects the
right to be left alone in the exam room
this means non-interference also under
the hypocritic Oath a doctor promises to
hold patient data confidential to ensure
trust and Frank
conversations second Hippa does not
protect privacy as has been said here
already Hippa is considered a permissive
data sharing rule according to a 2010
HHS rule more than 2.2 million entities
including 1.5 million business
associates are permitted to receive
individually identifiable data without
patient permission if the covered entity
chooses to share it unless a state
Privacy Law requires consent that's why
this bill is so important and that's why
it does not conflict with HIPPA it will
protect patients from the data sharing
that's allowed by Hippa without their
consent so please see the 22 Hippa Harms
in your packet for more information and
I forgot to pass out but oh you already
did okay thank you we have them thank
you so much um third as we often say he
who holds the data makes the rules
outside access to private patient data
enables third-party control of the exam
room using corporate treatment protocols
patient and Doctor profiling and
penalties on doctors who go outside the
protocols to provide personalized care
to patients Hippa also allows medical
records to be shared Nationwide without
consent through the ealth exchange the
nation's largest Health Information
Network in which uh New Hampshire is
mentioned 16 times in uh 16 entities uh
fourth medical records are digital gold
opum insights the data analytics
subsidiary of United Health Group
reported revenue of
$8.9 billion in
2023 that's 29.8% higher than 2022 and
all they do is Health Data this access
is through Health Care operations a 400w
definition of 65 categories of
non-clinical Services New Hampshire
protects privacy rights through its
state constitution and the state law
that deems medical information to be the
property of the patient this bill add
details and guard rails to ensure that
patients can exercise these rights so
please note the exceptions in the
proposed Bill allowing timely treatment
and transfer without consent on page
four line 24 and Page four line 36 a lot
has been said here about having to get
consent and not being able to do
anything it's not true in this bill uh
Dr David braer mdphd the First National
Health it coordinator wrote in 2015 stop
wrapping up please stop wrapping up I
will just finish quoting him if I might
sure he said he was the first Health it
coordinator he said you can't force a
covered entity to give your data to
someone you choose and you can't stop
them from giving it to someone they
choose Americans don't own their own
health information and access to it is
controlled by others it's time to change
that and we agree and we're appreciative
of this Bill thank you so much thank you
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and also
thank you for taking the time to come
all the way out here from Minnesota TR
Loi
State and you actually did fairly well
as far as the weather is concerned so
hopefully brought it with you we'll take
all that you want in regards to what
I've asked
prior individuals who testify before the
committee has your organization or
someone that you know of done a side
by-side comparison to the State
Minnesota statute versus New Hampshire
statute that's being proposed here and
then number two is there any other state
besides Minnesota and the country that
has comparable U protection for privacy
uh thank you Mr chair and representative
Merchant um we have not done a side by
side but we have included for you in the
packet the second page which talks
particularly about the consent
Provisions in our law we also have the
you know the uh decedent language we
have other kind of language but this was
particularly about The Descent so that's
what we included we have had this law
for basically 30 years and um have had
uh but haven't known any other state to
have this kind of law uh you will notice
if you go to the male um Clinic notice
of privacy practices that they will
specifically say how the law in
Minnesota is different so that the
notice of privacy practices that male
clinic has specifically says in
Minnesota X in Minnesota X and about
eight or nine different Provisions
because it's it's different
protections
Mr chairman if I
could thank you is it possible or would
you be willing to send the committee
members a link to that Mayo site so we
could
actually find it and um look look
through it for those who wish to do
that uh yes Mr chair and representative
Merchant we also have a copy of the
maale clinic form and we would be happy
I think we only have one or two so we
would be happy to have you just take
copies of it thank
you we can ask the researcher to make
some
copies representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for uh for being here today and and
for taking my question so
um can you speak a little bit to health
information exchanges and the role that
they play in all of this because I
understand again this was one of the
areas that um HHS at a federal level
Exempted under covid and authorized
widespread sharing of information so can
you explain a little bit about the role
of health information exchanges and does
that impact privacy and if so
how so Mr chair and representative
kofalt kofalt
um I would I would say there are two
things at least uh that that brings to
mind one of them is actually in the bill
talking about health and human services
and you will see that in the health
information exchange language we don't
see anything in the bill that says for
an infectious disease when it's
otherwise authorized by law that that
information goes to the health
department I think maybe it was the
health department here that I heard
testifying about this idea that they
couldn't have the regular exchange of
infectious disease data um but we don't
see anything in this bill that does that
and in Minnesota we also have infectious
disease data that goes to the health
department uh the health information
exchange interestingly enough you might
be uh interested to know that in
Minnesota with our Privacy Law we have
specifically in our health information
exchange that the health depart
Department cannot um cannot be part of
it because they cannot see all the other
data that that's in the state health
information exchange unfortunately from
our perspective we were not able to stop
the health information exchange because
it is this broad sharing of data uh the
chis that she was talking about um
that's what we call an all-payer claims
database and that is where all of your
data goes to the government without your
consent identifiably right and so there
are some things even in Minnesota that
we're still working to stop but the
health information Exchange in Minnesota
can't access that uh that
exchange other
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for being
here and taking my
question so thank you is the only way
then
perceivably uh to not have currently the
government um the all payer claims
database the is in New Hampshire
the only way to avoid them um having
access to your private health
information is to not utilize services
covered by
insurance would that be
true Mr chair and representative
kushman um there was a case gobl Goble
versus Liberty Mutual uh that limited um
the necessity for I think it was um I'm
I'm pulling this out of my um head here
I think it was uh prohibited uh
employers from having to share this
information on the all-payer claims
database and so I think it really
depends on what you have in your state
and then how that's been impacted by the
Supreme Court decision for the
self-insured employers I believe is what
that uh lawsuit was about um but yes
that would be the only way if that's how
it is in your state that you could avoid
all of the details of your Healthcare
going into the into the government or uh
paying cash and going to a provider in
cash follow up thank you and then um
could you tell me again and the
committee again those page numbers that
you were talking about um in the bill
that alleviate the concerns about
transfer of care and and
delays uh yes Mr chair and
representative kushman uh page
[Music]
4 uh page four line 24 talks about the
the um the provider having a
representation uh of holding a a signed
and data consent from the patient
authorizing the release so that you
wouldn't actually have to have uh the
real consent at that moment you know go
to the patient and then the other one is
line
36 these are the exceptions in Minnesota
we call it break the glass so the times
where you can break the glass and get
access to the data and you'll see there
it says for a medical emergency on a but
then if you go to B It also says to
other providers within related Health
Care entities when necessary for the
current treatment of the patient and in
addition to that I think it's really
important to look at the definition of
Provider because I have heard a lot of
the testifiers saying that they'd have
to get every individual's name it would
have to be very specific to every
individual practitioner but that's not
how we see the law written and that's
certainly not how it's written in
Minnesota so you know whatever you want
to pick a very large Health Care system
in this State it's got a lot of
different doctors nurses you know
whatever in it but you're you're giving
the consent to the it can be to the
entire institution every doctor in it
it's not a specific to one doctor one
share thank you representative Seth King
thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking questions I'm
a little confused on some things I'm
hoping you can uh clear up for me um
when Hippa if my memory sures me
correctly I was a little young at the
time but when Hippa first came around it
seemed like there was a lot of
opposition to it because it was too much
regulation and it was going to really
hamper the medical industry from
basically doing its job and correct me
if I'm wrong but if I had to imagine uh
Citizens Council for health Freedom
probably would have been against Hippa
when it was being debated originally um
but now I'm reading your hand out here
and it's sounds like your biggest
complaints with HIPPA are that it's it's
too it's it's too liberal in what it
allows the industry to share uh within
itself and so it sounds like this bill
and what you're promoting is like Hippa
on steroids and I'm just curious how we
how I wrap my head around the idea that
on one hand we're against Hippa because
it's too it's too restrictive
and it's going to rise up costs of the
industry as a whole but then on the
other hand uh we want more of that I
don't know I'm just I could be very
confused on this if you could help clear
that up for me thank you uh yes uh uh Mr
chair and representative King so I think
that given your what you said about you
know the history of HIPPA which which
was
1996 and the law said that Congress was
going to within 3 years actually
Implement their or enact their own
privacy statute right and they had a
several hearings but then they didn't
and the law said that HHS could then um
write the rule so they wrote the rule
and it came out I think proposed in 1998
or
1999 uh and then it was finalized but it
wasn't finalized uh before 50 more than
50,000 comments came in it was like a
record comments of people opposing it
because it took away their consent
rights and so actually the Clinton
Administration reversed for the final
Rule and the Clinton Administration put
in consent for payment treatment and
Healthcare operations they put it back
into the final rule then President Bush
was elected and the industry came to the
Bush Administration and said please take
that
out and so and so they the rule was
opened up and the consent Provisions
were removed
and so we do not have consent today for
all of the sharing and just like Dr
braer said you can't stop them from
sharing it with whomever they want and
you know this this uh the definition of
healthcare operations I mean 400 words
long it's it's like everything in the
kitchen sink and they have nothing to do
with giving care to a patient in those
Health Care operations and so I'm not
positively sure how you see the bill as
giving more access to data when it
actually gives the oh yeah the bill
gives less yes so that's what that's
what we support is is consent and we
actually support optin which is consent
versus opt out which is
desent and I guess the other thing I'd
say is you know you have a state who has
said that that the medical records are
the property of the patient and look at
anything else you own if it's your house
followup um thank you for the followup
um was the was medical was the medical
establishment and and were patients
privacy rights better protected before
Hippa was the world a better place
before
Hippa um Mr chair and uh representative
King so privacy was protected before he
Hippa like I've I've done the whole
history of HIPPA so I know everybody who
wanted the data right they wanted the
data from uh governments to the data
industry to health plans to everyone
wanted the data right and so what Hippa
did was it allowed it to be digitized
without patient consent and then the the
um 2009 law that mandated the electronic
health record allowed it to be sharable
easily uh without consent and so these
two together took away patients privacy
rights took away their control and I I
just remember here's something that I
think you can all kind of relate to I
remember talking to a physical therapist
and she said you know because I hip in
the electronic health record I get I get
to see everything so I know that my
patient has had this sexual disease and
that sexual disease and I know he
doesn't know that I know it but I do
know it because it's all available to me
so that representative Merchant then
representative
Palmer thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question I noticed in
the handout that was provided to us on
20 Hippa harms at the end of it there's
a authorization form from the conquered
Hospital could you explain why it's
there so I can understand how to
interpret the reason for for being there
thank
you uh yes Mr chair and representative
Merchant we just thought we should look
and see what um what's being done in
hospitals today for sharing the
information and this seemed to be one
form that's already there I'm sure
you've got lots of hospitals but one
form that uh specifically gives the
patient the ability to to share data and
the uh back and forth looks like a back
and forth form to us
one it says disclose medical information
the other says obtain medical
information from so from that comment is
it my then to interpret that this
authorization form is a consent form and
something you would
support what the organization would
support um uh Mr chair and
representative Merchant this seems to be
quite an a a consent form it's not a
desent it's a consent
thank you representative
Palmer my question has been answered
again okay thank you other
you no other questions thank you very
you I have a pin card here for um and I
think Roger go I believe it is but it
says judiciary House Bill 1082 so I I'm
assuming it's it's just a misplaced card
I have no other pin cards for this bill
no one else has signed up to speak on
House Bill
1663 I'm seeing no one uh raising their
hand on the blue sheet in the back 15
people did sign up in opposition and I'm
sure many others signed up online both
for and against uh with that I am going
to close the public hearing on hb1 1663
and I going to open the public hearing
on HB
1067 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Reed representative Reed
in the
room I do not see
her
please
good afternoon representative Reed uh
the floor is yours uh for the
introduction of House Bill 1067 thank
you Mr chair and thank you honorable
members I appreciate the fact that
you're running about 45 minutes behind
you're all very tired I appreciate your
uh patience and endurance um for the
record my name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 that's new market and new
fields and the bill before you is HB
1067 um I did present a very similar
Bill last year to you all so I will be
um going through my story as to the
Genesis of this bill and we have uh
quite a number of people willing to test
ify to largely similar stories um so
last year I told you that I've never had
a regular period in my life um and I
didn't really know why I was told that
you know as long as I had a few a year
I'd be fine and um it wasn't until I
started bleeding for like weeks and
weeks in a in a row um that I got
diagnosed with
PCOS and uh I was told then that one of
the treatments could be a hysterectomy
um and that if you're not going to have
kids you really don't need your uterus
it only is a risk for cancer you don't
need your fallopian tubes which are also
a risk for cancer 90% of ovarian cancer
starts in Fallopian tubes and you don't
really need your cervix which is only
just a risk for cancer so I asked for
the hysterectomy but I was told no no um
I was 26 when I got diagnosed uh that um
no you are too young you don't have
children yet you're going to want to be
a mom one day I said no I'm definitely
sure that I don't in fact my husband got
of a sectomy
um and they said no no you're going to
change your mind because they didn't say
it exactly like this but the culture the
tone is very much all women want to have
children that's your role in life so I
was pretty frustrated but I kind of
didn't realize this was a cultural wide
thing among uh the profession and I um
went to over the next 12 years six
different doctors all of them told me I
was too young and would definitely
definitely changed my mind one day um by
the way my husband didn't have this
problem with his elective
vasectomy I will say that they asked me
as his wife whether or not I was okay
with it and it was like a one- day thing
in and out done and his was elective not
medically needed right so then I got
really bad I bled for a year straight
every day of the year for over 365 days
I bled and in another bout I bled
heavily so heavily that the only product
I could use were adult diapers um for 4
months straight I did what is called uh
shedding a cast where you essentially go
through a dilation of your cervix and
give birth to a mold of the interior of
your uterus which was extremely painful
I was on the phone with 911 when it
happened because I had been in pain for
hours um and then finally at the age of
38 I was told I was old enough
finally so I had suffered for well over
a decade something like 15 years before
they finally gave me uh my medically
needed Hy direct to me but I still
thought this was just something that was
really happening to me didn't realize it
was a culture-wide thing until I came
across online groups of so many women
and I will say that the bill is written
in a very sex neutral language but this
does predominantly affect women for
cultural reasons um that had similar
stories and stories much much worse of
mine one story of a woman with with
uterine cancer with uterine cancer
begging saying I don't want kids please
take my uterus and the doctor
wouldn't
so um and by the way uh there are a
number of OBGYNs who do support this
legislation I just wanted I only got
this this morning from uh an OBGYN in
New Hampshire I just wanted to quickly
read it to you hi reped I'm a board
certified obstetrician gynecologist in
New Hampshire who proudly provide
sterilization to my adult patients
regardless of their age or number of
children I applaud your efforts to
ensure patients and our state are able
to access the reproductive care they
need with HB 1067 I appreciate you
protecting pH the Physicians who provide
sterilization services to younger adults
by excluding regret later in life as a
potential cause for litigation which is
the third section of the bill I'll get
to that I know other Physicians who have
previously declined to perform
sterilization on younger patients due to
their concerns for future litigation if
those patients do do regret the
procedure later in life and I am happy
to see that you have considered this in
writing HB 1067 thank you for your time
in reading this and in advocating for
the reproductive autonomy of New
Hampshire residents Morgan Jenkins mdfa
cogg
um just because I got that just uh this
morning so the three parts of the bill
the first part um says that if a patient
has and and unlike last year the only
opposition we had in testimony to this
last year was someone objecting to the
idea that was any patient and it should
be a patient 18 years and older and
that's why I fixed in this language so
any patient 18 years or older who has a
medical condition for which um a med
medically advisable course of treatment
may include sterilization the The
Physician shall not deny the procedure
on the basis of age number of children
or the physician's perception of the
patient patient's future reproductive
desires despite the patient comments to
the contrary so the physician can deny
on any other basis they can deny based
on payment they can deny based on the
physician's personal uh religious
beliefs they just can't deny based on I
know what's better for you then you
do uh the second part says that if it's
elective only related to a medical
condition that the doctor doesn't have
to do it but they do have to refer them
to a doctor who will do it and accepts
the patients's form of of
payment um and then the last part holds
harmless the doctors who do this if they
get a a medically a assigned medical
waiver informed consent saying that I
understand I'm going to be left sterile
and can't have kids therefore the
patient won't be able to come back later
and say hey I can't have kids um and and
there you have the bill um
the only argument I got from committee
members last time around was the idea of
well isn't this forcing doctors to do
something we don't really want to force
doctors to do something and um I I've
taught for four years I adjunct taught
um American government and one of the
things that keeps coming up is the
conflicting freedoms conflicting rights
so oftentimes we have to weigh freedom
for whom rights for whom and in this
case in this particular case you have
someone who's chosen a profession which
has many legal restrictions on it right
this isn't going to be the first you
know attempt at making or first time
making a doctor do something for example
there's mandatory reporting requirements
um there's all kinds of things that
would fall under uh uh malpractice for
example so you choose that profession
and you get paid well and get clout in
the community and what have you versus
someone who cannot choose to not have
that medical condition someone who can't
choose a body that's healthy so in this
case the inherent right for a person to
control their body I think comes first
takes precent before someone's right to
do something when they've chosen a
profession that has inherently has a lot
of power and therefore a lot of
responsibilities tied to that P tied to
that power the analogy here um just in
closing is if for example a doctor and I
think there was a time and and there's a
lot of studies that show that maybe this
today but there was a time when doctors
might intentionally for cultural reasons
deny patients Care on the basis of race
but we decide that that's actually wrong
and we we say actually no you can't do
that this is no different because this
is a cultural problem that doctors are
not pulling themselves in and regulating
themselves and and honoring people's
inherent choices on whether or not they
have children um for those who are
concerned about about abortion this does
obviously reduce the uh numbers of
unintended pregnancies and therefore um
and therefore the the desire or demand
for abortions and um the last thing is
that again it's sex neutral language um
men I I encourage the men to imagine a
doctor refusing you let's start with the
elective refusing you when you say I
would really like a visectomy and the
doctor's like m H I don't know I don't
know if you can make that decision or
not now imagine you have cancer and it's
actually a medically needed treatment
and now the doctor's going I know that
you could potentially die and in fact
women have died from this but I'm still
going to say you don't have the right to
make the decision on whether or not you
want children in the future so because
of that I think it's necessary to re
this unfortunate aspect of our culture
in and with that I'll take
questions representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions can you give us a refresher on
what happened to this bill last year did
it get um ited on consent calendar did
it go before the Full House
thanks I believe this committee held it
over with the comments held it over for
a while before voting on it with the
comments that they really wanted to to
talk about it and then not having U
Amendment language before them that made
everybody happy uh unanimously agreed
with the deadline looming to go ahead
and itl it we pulled it off we tabled it
for the specific reason of bringing it
Forward other questions representative
Weber thank you Mr chair I will note
that the tabling vote was
to8 um my question has to do with uh
simply the payment aspect because in
your testimony this time you said that
part one the first paragraph paragraph a
has nothing to do with payment and that
you could refuse to do the treatment for
payment reasons you just can't impose
your own values upon somebody who is
asking you for a procedure uh that they
want uh but then in Part
B if it's only an elective procedure you
have provided that uh a physician ref
refusing to do the treatment the
procedure must refer to a physician
who's willing to conduct the procedure
and who accepts the payment patient form
of payment and I'm wondering why that's
the
responsibility of a
um of a physician who is simply refusing
to do elective surgery as opposed to
um it would seem to me that the bar
would be higher for for uh medically
necessary treatment that it would for uh
elective treatment and why is elective
treatment the responsibility of a
physician to find somebody who would do
it for whatever payment you can offer
them thank you for the question
representative and I I do appreciate the
point um the point of doing this was to
prevent a patient getting caught in the
loop with a presumably a doctor who has
cultural biases against that patient who
doesn't want them to to be sterile
because they see that that person is
person's worth in in culture is as a
brood mare for lack of a better term and
therefore kind of intentionally or maybe
without um giving it due diligence
referring them to other doctors who feel
the same way and then that patient
getting kicked around um and not being
able to find a doctor like I said I went
to six different doctors and I still
didn't get an okay until I was 38 so
that that's the reason that's there
however if the committee feels strongly
that that doesn't need to be part of
that I think that um having the rest of
it in place would be a vast Improvement
for a number of of people men and women
but mostly women in this state and they
are here to tell you so thank you
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um thank you for bringing this issue up
it's very important
um I'm a physician and I have a question
um because I'm trying to understand my
responsibilities here I don't do
hysterctomy so you're safe for me um I
would also I no longer have a uterus so
I'm safe from you what's that I no
longer have a uterus so I'm safe from
you we're both safe yay so
um I would argue personally that if the
doctor doesn't want to do it you
probably don't want that doctor to do it
but I will ask you this question I I
tell patients all the time I I'm not
willing to do that procedure on you and
um some of those procedures I am
competent to do um I do agree with you I
all I have a library of Docs I know who
will do it and I do make those referrals
but what I'm trying to understand under
part one are you are you holding me
liable if I say I'm not going to do it
but I give you another name of somebody
that that can so knowing that I cannot
ask you a question um my I'll just Muse
aloud that I would say any good doctor
as I expect that you are when they say
I'm not going to do that procedure it's
for medical reasons because it's kind of
risky and that is completely fine in
this um the only thing that would be
forcing you to do is to to not deny on
the basis of age number of children and
some doctors in this state actually are
requiring one male and one female child
before you even get a um a hysterctomy
which is weird um and um and the P your
perception of the patient's future
reproductive desires when they're
telling you otherwise so what I would
say for a physician who culturally just
was really you know upset with the idea
that they would be sterilizing someone
because they really thought that that
person should have children in the
future is that they can say well I'll
give it to you because it's medically
advisable if you want it but I want to
let you know that I personally don't
want to do it and I'm happy to refer you
to a different doctor that's still fine
thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you represent re Pi on the
question I'm still wrestling with this
bill as it did last
year
this is a free World um you're right
there's a issue of parents patients
rights physician
rights but at the end of the day the
patient
has the right to seek a physician who
will do the per to do whatever they're
looking to do as long as the physician
agrees to it because it's not going to
be harmful to the patient but what I'm
trying to get to is that we have freedom
of
choice and strong so therefore if you
don't have a physician that is going to
perform what you think should be
performed there's nothing to prevent you
as a patient to go to another physician
I could see the physician making a
referral and knowing within the network
as Dr Nel re Nel said who you could go
to but again at the end of the day
patients have freedom of choice just
like the Physicians have freedom of
choice and I'm looking at and saying why
am I taking a freedom of choice away
from the physician and giving it all to
the
patient so I mean not to be facius but I
I hate to break it to you that we we
don't live in a free world we have lots
of we have 64 titles of law actually if
you put them up side by side it's like
64 Bibles basically um I know as I got
on my committee a big book of of laws
that pertain to my committee that you
also get get that so there's a lot of
laws that that constrain what we can do
and doctors as I already stated rightly
because they have a lot of power rightly
have a lot of responsibilities to uh use
that power um in ethical ways so again
the analogy here is should we let
doctors have the freedom to deny certain
races care when they need it and it's
not you made a statement that well if
the patient comes in and they just think
that they should have this this is not
that's not this is the doctor actually
says this is a medically advisable
course of treatment for your condition
so this is situation where a doctor is
saying yes you have this terrible
condition whether it be endometriosis
PCOS um pmdd cancer any number of
conditions and yes a hysterectomy would
fix that but it would leave you sterile
and you wouldn't be able to have
children and that's the downside of it
and then the patient goes that's fine
that's not a downside to me and then the
doctor goes well I'm still not going to
do it so how much Choice do you have
when you don't have any providers who
are willing to do it I just testified to
the fact as others will
I spent 12 years looking for a doctor
who would do it so I don't know how
that's Freedom of Choice when I can't
find a doctor who's willing to do it
because of those cultural
biases well um you know representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um my concern with the bill last time
and this time is that the drafting with
respect to both um referrals and the
doctor
responsibilities and in particular the
limitations on
liabilities all give me certain concerns
and I wonder how you would feel if we
came up with a bill that simply started
at at paragraph a and said a patient who
is 18 years of age or older uh has a
medical condition for which a medically
advisable course of treatment may
include a procedure that leaves the PRM
sterile the physician shall not deny the
procedure
solely solely solely on the basis of age
number of children or the physician's
perception of the patient fusal
reproductive desires despite period and
just have that be the
bill I mean that would still be an
improvement over the current situation
um I do think that the medical community
and not that I normally would just
Advocate on behalf of of someone else
but I think that they in particular
would really want as that OBG Wayan that
I read the email from um want part C and
part C just to be super clear only gives
um takes away the right of um civil
Civil Right of action for the
sterilization itself so not for if they
left forceps in you or they messed up
something else um it's only for the
inability to Bear children in the future
so the answer to your question is yes
that would your suggested Amendment
would still be an improvement in the
lives of many in this state um I don't
know that the medical community would be
terribly okay with removing C but it's
up to the
committee other uh representative Nagel
are you raising hand no representative
mazour thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question did you you mentioned
that um this is already legal for men is
that correct
like is something like place for men in
practice men i' so I've barely heard men
um having any issues getting vasectomies
Beyond perhaps like well is your wife
okay with it and then it's fine but a
lot of times that even that doesn't
happen but I've never ever heard of a
single instance where a man has been
prevented from a medically necessary
treatment on the basis that no you're
definitely going to need to produce more
sperm in the future thank you follow up
follow up yeah so if so why why why is
the why wouldn't the title then be
relative to a woman's right to
sterilization treatment because it it
should be everybody's right even though
in practice I don't see that happening
but I definitely don't want to exclude
men for whom it might happen like it
should be everybody's right to have a
medically necessary treatment or
medically advisable treatment if they
understand that the risk of that
treatment or the effect of that
treatment is that they won't be have
biological children but they make that
decision and they sign that they're
making that decision thank you thank you
other
Nan I might be opening a can of worms
but thank you open it um so can someone
over
18 can a young man over 18 go into a
doctor's office and say I would like to
be sterilized I mean certainly of course
a young man can go into their same day
vasectomy clinics um I if you're going
to ask next what would the physician say
to that it would depend on the physician
would and So currently could a young
woman not go in and um asked for tubal
liation so are you getting to the
elective or the medically advisable
piece elective okay so um yeah a woman
could and there's nothing in here that
makes a doctor do the tubal liation okay
I um followup question I just remember
last year um it didn't sit right with me
that a woman could go in with a
perfectly healthy uterus and demand that
a doctor take it out because it would
occur to me that doctors usually don't
remove functioning organs and love a
comment you know whatever take the ear
off it's ugly you know body dismorphia
kind of thing you know it's I agree with
you on that that's why this bill does
not force someone with a healthy uterus
or some a doctor to honor the wishes of
someone with say a healthy uterus or
healthy male reproductive organs from
removing it nothing in the spill forces
that I'm I'm very glad to hear that and
I'm glad that that's clear it's very
very clear it's for elective the only
thing a doctor would have to do is if
their reason for denying it was on the
basis of um number of children or age or
what have you then they would give a
referral to a different doctor but
that's all thank you for answering my
question and thank you for bringing
forth this very important Bill thank you
other
you also signed up to speak is
Mueller good after thank you Mr chair
and the members of the committee I
appreciate the U opportunity to briefly
testify I really don't like sharing my
uh personal situation in situations like
this but for the record I am one of the
people who chose to make sure they
cannot have any more babies by um you
know when I reached a certain age I felt
that I just was not at an age at which I
was able of being a good parent through
18 more years and I didn't want to take
the risk we may uh have to be in that
situation so
in regards to an earlier question of
course I would like to be included trust
me I would not have taken it kindly if
the physician of told me Daniel I'm not
so sure you won't change your mind maybe
you should come back in a few years and
we can talk about it so absolutely if a
bill is made it should include everybody
regardless of the fact that most of the
times this happens to women protections
have to be equal I will also say that if
we use the word solely in the on the
basis of age number of children and so
wait we all set okay thank you proceed I
appreciate it so if we use the word
solely in here that opens the door to
somebody who really wants to do it just
on that reason to find another minor
reason why they have a concern so it
would probably weaken the bill and lead
to uh you know considerable
opportunities to uh get around it but as
the primary sponsor was saying honestly
the current state is pretty rough so you
know if we can move this forward and
measure it later to see how it works
everything would be good I would
definitely suggest that paragraph C is
really needed it is important to protect
medical providers from people who say I
know exactly what I want do it and then
come back two years later and say I
really didn't mean it why would you let
me do that if we mandate The Physician
do this paragraph C has to come attached
to make it clear that you obey the law
and you did what the law required there
cannot be liability just because
somebody says now I want to have babies
after asking for a sterilization so to
me that should not be gone but what this
comes down to honestly
is our job as legislature to decide what
discrimination is okay because we all
discriminate in Legally acceptable ways
and what discrimination should not be
legally allowed and obviously there is
already federal law you know you cannot
discriminate based on race and so on and
so forth but to me somebody who says I
just don't think you have the ability to
make that decision for yourself you may
change your mind in a few years to me
that crosses the line into the type of
discrimination that I think the
government has an interest in not
allowing because we have to respect the
ability of people to make medical
decisions that affect themselves and
their own body and I really do feel that
this type of decision as much as we may
not like it sometimes when it happens as
long as the patient is a sound of mind
and they have a medical need and so on
they should be allowed to do
it I last thing I want to say is that I
was in the same hearings last year and I
just wanted to acknowledge that you know
the primary sponsor made an effort to
include some of those suggestions and
concerns and address them I think this
is a better Bill than what was in front
of the committee last year and I would
encourage you to give it serious
consideration including if you feel that
an amendment is needed working with or
working among yourselves to amend it so
that we can move this forward and not
have to bring this pressing issues year
after year let's find something that
works and hopefully make things better
thank you thank you thank
you I hear representative Merchant thank
you Mr chairman so are you in supportive
then
of sort of a requirement that the
physician who likes not to do the
procedure needs to make a referral to a
position who would is that what versus
we try understand that because there a
mandate for them to do it versus them
making a referral I understand this is a
significant concern among Physicians but
I would like you to consider the
scenario in which somebody can just say
no and then everybody else can say no
what good is a law that says that you
have the right to do this if no medical
provider will ever do it for you I think
that also and I know you are more
qualified in the medical standards than
I am that at the end of the day when
treatment is needed a physician may say
I may not be the right person but please
you know find some you know I can
recommend you to somebody who does but
even if you are not completely
comfortable if you are the only person
who can do that for that patient isn't
there a medical duty to you know do
something to help them I I think it's a
very complicated ethical question and I
understand your concerns and uh frankly
again if that's some that's the only
thing that holds the bill back and
everybody can support it while cleaning
up that language I would really support
anything that moves this forward in the
hope of you know improving things as
much as we can and reserving the right
to you know look at the data later and
decide if further changes are needed but
I think that we do need to stop the
practice of just saying I think you may
change your mind I'm just not going to
treat you other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is
Manion thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm not a co-sponsor on this
but I actually I ethically believe what
uh what this bill stands for uh so I've
been uh dating the same girl for 10
years I found her uh you know in the
early days of internet dating and on my
profile I said I I don't want children
uh so i' make that very abundantly clear
up front I didn't I didn't want children
uh 10 years later we don't have children
she didn't want children um I never went
to get any of these procedures because I
I've been aware of the stigma where it's
like you go in and and a lot of times
they're like well did did you check with
your spouse did you really want this you
should check with your spouse can we
call your spouse like I've heard these
stories secondhand so this entire time
I'm just like watching the clock and be
like what so how old do I have to be
before I can just go do this without
having to get like hassled by the doctor
over my age and whether or not I
actually want children or not like I
knew over a decade ago I didn't want
children so that's that's my defense of
this bill I think these individuals have
done a good job talking about the the
details of it but I'm happy to take
questions any questions
representative
Lon uh thank you Mr chairman um in
clarification is that men that you've
heard um that have been asked those
questions yeah I'm coming sorry to sound
sex I'm only coming from the male
perspective here well thank you it's
good Insight because I didn't know that
that happened to men as well yeah thank
you thank you other
you also signed up to speak is
representative Josh
Oella
thank you and thank you uh for uh
listening to my
I had a
vasectomy in when I was 26 I think 27
don't hold me to it it's about 10 years
ago I didn't keep I didn't know that I
would need to uh I wasn't planning to
testify on this today so I wasn't I
didn't you know go check my medical
records we won't hold you to it okay
um so it's been about 10 years um and
kind of like the previous speaker I at
26 27 already knew what I
wanted and
I had that same kind of stigma that if I
did it too early that I was going to get
denied and if I tried to start asking
that question too early um
and uh so I think I would have got it
sooner if I had known such a law was on
the books like hey if you if you're um
I'm not as in favor of mandating I think
that we could just say you know if a
patient who's 18 years of age of older
wishes to have a
sterilization uh the doctor shall not uh
deny the patient without referring them
as essentially to to a POS physician
that would do it um I think that that
even that language would have made me
much more willing to talk to my doctor
about it earlier um and um I was single
at the
time they didn't have anyone to ask as
far as like getting approval it wasn't
done in the state so I'm not sure if
it's uh specifically New Hampshire
problem but um they just asked me was I
sure how long had I thought about it
would I open to you know did I want to
save some sperm or or anything and and I
said you know it was mainly like my
belief and how child should be raised
and the responsibility and the
undertaking that that took and that you
know I date people that have kids and so
I can love children that are not
biologically related to me and so I
would be happy to adopt if I ever
thought that I was in the ne in the in
the the um in the frame of mind or in
the station in life that I could be able
to afford and and give the child the
things that I think that they deserve
and so um I you know expressed all of
that to the doctor and they were like
okay that's fine and so I didn't get a
whole lot of push back that you may hear
from some other people and I'm not sure
if you know I was at you know 26 is not
necessarily super old so um maybe it was
a stigma thing or maybe it was it was I
had it done in Seattle Washington so it
was maybe it was a cultural thing in in
in so I'm not exactly sure but that's
that's kind of my experience with it and
so I'm happy to take any questions if
anyone has any thank you representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I'm sorry this
you may not be the perfect person for
this question but you're sitting there
so sure um so I really struggle with the
concept of legislating like single
medical events and and and I'll give you
an example why I kind of see a slippery
slope here and I will give you a Dr
Murphy example that we see every day so
a person walks in in their 30s 40s with
osteoarthritis of the knee end stage
they have a BMI over 40 you tell me if
I'm going wrong and they say they want
their knee replaced if you were in your
first year of out of residency and you
did that surgery and you had to take
your boards they would give you a lot of
grief right so in other words you're
being told to not do that but the
patient wants it there is a medical
indication but there's a couple of
issues that go against it so in your in
your conscience you're saying no right I
don't see these things as being
different at all and and that's why I'm
struggling with this concept of going
down a slippery slope that we start here
and then we go to the next procedure and
procedure thank you sorry but the
question is are we or aren't we I mean
you know and and why are we looking at
One S single thing and are we creating a
potential a problem here um I think that
that there's a lot of problems in our
medical industry don't get me started on
that sorry you're prob not the person
ask question but but I do think that
there is kind of a question and kind of
going back to what I kind of thought
about just the ability to just refer to
some to another physician um I think
that sometimes it's hard definitely in
this climate where there's very it's
hard to you know get an appointment it's
hard to find a doctor that is accepting
new patients and there's like a lot of
hurdles to um
those those things and so if we can help
F facilitate um more of an ease with
within the medical community that sell
like you got an appointment here I'm I'm
not going to you know just send you out
on the on the open road trying to find
another one that will accept a new
patient or something like that then you
know you're not stuck stuck looking for
12 years kind of a thing um for another
patient or for another doctor and maybe
maybe you know those conversations with
those different doctors will will bring
up some evidence that may change the
person's mind I don't know but that's uh
I think
that essentially just saying no Hit the
Road Jack kind of a thing is um kind of
Le yeah it's wrong and should they
should just you know be helped either
either um not by that necessarily
physician I don't necessarily want to
force the doctor to do it but thank you
yeah uh representative Shapiro thank you
Mr
chairman
um I'm wondering if you might not think
that we're conflating two very different
kinds of situations um
the um sponsor of the bill told us a
story about
um a medical problem that was ongoing
severe um where she suffered for a long
time and then suffered longer because
she couldn't find a doctor to
um do a procedure that doctors were
telling her would solve the problem
and no offense but your situation being
that you felt some discomfort with
walking into the doctor's office at 26
since and what would they think of me if
I asked for uh a vasectomy um it seems
like we're conflating two very different
kinds of
situations and one where there might be
legitimate reason to have a law
um but do you really think there should
be a law to protect you from being
uncomfortable in that
situation um
thank you for the question um I think
that both situations are kind of covered
by the bill so it's I don't think I
think it is addressing two situations
one medically and one one uh
voluntarily um and I would not
necessarily say that we have to have a
law that addresses my you know concerns
that I didn't want to go to the doctor
that's not absolutely necessary would it
be beneficial absolutely that's why I'm
here in support of them the legislation
what um I don't think that it's uh you
know going
to be harmful in any way to to help stem
that kind of sentiment in the public
that that they will be looked at kind of
sideways if they go too young but I'm
I'm I don't think that this is you know
going to save lives thank you other
questions representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions I know you're not uh you don't
speak for the New Hampshire Liberty
Lines but you do have an A+ rating I'm
wondering do you think they'll be
supporting this bill even though it
coerces doctors to do things maybe
against their will thank you thank you
for for the question and and in my
testimony I did kind of illustrate a way
that the bill could um could be amended
that would just essentially require
referral and not actually requiring a
procedure or something like that I think
that um
patient patient choice and patient
um uh access to things I think that
would be um definitely in alignment with
uh you know freedom and
liberty so I think that depending on how
the bill is amended by this committee or
not amended by this committee it will it
will come out uh based on that I think
thank you other
also signed up to speak is repres
here is she out in the hall she's been
with us most of the most of the day well
we'll catch her after the next represent
okay actually I don't see any other
represent
um
apparently uh I handed it up may have
it's on that piece of paper right there
I believe right that one there 1077
there we go oh okay sorry about that I
put it in the wrong spot representative
Lauren seelig thank you so much and
thank you to the committee for allowing
me to testify um I am very much in
support of this bill and I just want to
explain why um when I was in grad
graduate school a long long time ago um
I discovered joyfully or not necessarily
joyfully that I was allergic to latex
nonoxinol 9 and the birth control pill
um my Midwife referred to me as a
contraceptive nightmare because I was
left with one option which would be
abstinence as the only method that I
could use for birth control at that
stage um you know and and we found
creative measures for a long time um I
married later life I was in my early 30s
when I got married and I had my children
at 35 and
37 I I actually should back up a second
three days before I conceived my second
child I was diagnosed with a condition
and told I was probably not going to be
able to get pregnant if I did I wouldn't
be able to carry a term and blah blah
blah three days later I conceived my
second child who was very healthy
teenager at the moment um but I was also
clear at 37 that I was done having
children you know like I was glad to
have two as long as they both emerged
alive I was good life was good I was
done so at my four-week appointment of
confirming I was pregnancy I said this
is so great I'm pregnant how soon after
this one is born can I have my tubes
tied and they said you're really high
risk let's talk about it later I said
well how much later they said well let's
wait until we get you through your first
trimester so at my 12we appointment 15we
appointment 17we appointment all the way
to my 41-week appointment and yes I do
mean 41 weeks um I was asking how soon
after this child was born could I have
my tubes tied
I went in for that appointment to get my
tubes tied 6 weeks after she was born
the doctor turned to my husband and said
are you okay with
this I looked at the doctor and said I
don't care if he has other children he
just can't have them
here and and he's like so you're okay
with him having children with somebody
else I was like yeah at that point we
probably won't still be married but that
is his prerogative if he chooses it I'm
done and the doctor said well are you
absolutely certain
and I looked at the doctor and explained
that either he could do the procedure as
he had promised he would and make sure
he done it correctly or I would be very
happy to take his house his car his wife
whatever else he owned or believed that
he owned to ensure that I could have
this procedure to end the challenges of
trying to make sure that I had
contraception right because I was clear
that I was
done um in the time since then I'm now
in my mid-50s I have had ongoing
cyclical problems of cyclical migraines
that sometimes debilitate debilitate me
for two to three days at a time um and
it's all with my menstrual cycle I have
mood swings and all those sorts of
classic things I'm 54 I'd really like to
be done with this process I have been to
seven different gynecologists and asked
please can I have a hysterctomy because
I'm done my tubes are tied it's not
about contraception anymore take the
crap out so all my other symptoms will
stop still waiting to find one who will
agree I did finally manage to get an
oblation so at least now I'm not
hemorrhaging blood every
month just a little because I get to be
one of the lucky 3% um this bill would
allow someone like me who was married
had children and very very clear that I
was very very very done having children
of my own out of my uterus to get a
procedure and find someone who would
help provide it and if that doctor is
not willing to ensure that they help me
find it Doctor Who is and that's the key
it's that it's if if you know you Dr nle
are like okay I'm not a gynecologist and
I can't provide gynecological services
but I do know a gynecologist who does
that let me make sure to connect you
with them so that you can get the please
start wrapping up your testimony that's
what we're asking for okay thank you any
you also signed up to speak is former
bwood still
here oh huh the numbers are CL oh
they're all mixed in okay all
right let 167
167 all
right too many similar numbers that's
what it
right all right let's try this
again
um
Smith thank you Mr chair and
committee uh I am no one in particular
from Manchester New
Hampshire and I wanted to take time out
of my day uh for you to hear my
testimony in favor of this
bill
um
I I'm just trying to think and I'm
curious about exactly how or why uh any
reps if they do believe this that they
believe that it is
the appropriate duty of the
legislature to decide what is the
appropriate conduct for someone to do
regarding their own body um this bill is
fundamentally about bodily autonomy and
an individual's ability to decide to do
with their body as they so
choose
um in the language um there was brought
solely uh regarding the basis of age
number of children or the uh
physicians's perception of the patient's
future reproductive
desires um I think that would be an
inappropriate change to
make
because even if it is not
solely related it can lead a physician
to making a
decision uh to treat or not treat that
is in conflict with the desires of the
patient now if we lived in a world where
it was unnecessary for myself or my wife
or my daughter to uh get the permission
from a physician to get this procedure
done if I could go to the nearest CVS or
7-Eleven and get it done I I don't think
this would be an issue but this is an
issue because uh we must seek the
permission of these Physicians uh to do
this and so it's not a clearcut issue I
have no desire to force Physicians to um
do things that they don't want to do or
procedures that they find unacceptable
or uh unconscionable and that's why this
bill has an out for them to provide to
people who are seeking this someone who
will do it
um
so I'm willing to take any questions
related to this bill um or my
perspective or my testimony related to
it thank you any
you also signed up to speak speak is
Phillips good afternoon again thank you
um Emily Phillips uh Rockingham 7
Fremont New Hampshire and I apologize I
was out of the room tending to other
bills so I'm not sure what was covered
but I support this bill I believe it's a
a liberty issue body autonomy medical
freedom I just I I read the bill and and
representative from New Market right yep
okay brought me in on this and I said
absolutely uh we should allow people to
make adult decisions with their bodies
I'm not sure to the specifics and I
don't know what the other amendments
were suggested from prior speakers but
just in general I support this and I
would hope that everyone would allow um
adults who choose to sterilize
themselves to do so so that's kind of
where my position is I'm sorry I'm a
little flustered thank you yes any
questions representative South King
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking questions um I
have a lot of respect for you and um
your opinions and uh but I'm just I'm
still wrap trying to wrap my head around
this one because um you're concerned
about individual body autonomy um which
I agree with completely now if there was
some sort of law in New Hampshire
statute that prevented somebody from
getting this kind of care then I would
say that makes sense but there is no law
you do have that legal freedom but you
know doctors are individuals too and
they also have a right in my opinion to
deny care quite frankly I know this
isn't going to be agreed with by anybody
but I think doctors should be able to
dis to deny care for any reason
whatsoever and they shouldn't be forced
to you know tell um somebody where to go
get that care so I'm just curious how as
an individual doctors are how you're
concerned about their rights or not
concerned about their rights but you're
only concerned about the patient's
rights I don't know it seems like both
PE both both people have rights here so
I'm just curious how you square that
thank you thanks for that conundrum um
so I mean I'm always for the individual
first right so I and I and I know we're
talking they're both individuals but
this is a provider issue so I don't know
the whole history on how uh the
representative of New Market came and I
didn't missed her beginning of her
testimony but I feel like if this is a
real issue and it's happening and
there's people here to testify for it um
there's obviously some sort of lapse
there as far as what seems reasonable um
as far as access to these proced
I I did want to mention I should have
mentioned it in my earlier testimony but
um when my husband had a vasectomy um I
had to sign off on it as as his wife and
I don't think that's a law um but that
was something that the doctor was
requiring because I don't think everyone
has had that same experience this was
like eight years ago but they had me
sign off giving acknowledgement or
permission or something of his decision
um which may be arbitrary and it may
just be that practice but I I just think
that's interesting because ultimately
that's his right right so I just I I
don't know this seems like a Bill of
Rights we're not paying for these
procedures or any of that so this is why
I'm supporting the bill um I I still I
lean on the side of the patient as far
as the power perspective of who's got
the more power here I mean doctors have
the authority to turn down patients and
if you're going from Doctor to doctor
provider to provider seeking a service
that you medically need I mean that's
that's hard right because you can't
perform your own sterilization and we
don't want people doing that um so it's
like if you can't find someone to
perform this I just I guess I just side
on the the individual on the patient
side for this one I hope I answered your
question
but other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
vardi is Jade valard still here oh there
hello um hello um I am here today in
support of this bill
um trying to kind of wrap my head around
about some of the questions that you
guys have been asking pertaining to this
bill um I support this bill because um I
think it's really this is an issue with
taking
quite frankly women's pain seriously um
I am a mother of two I have had issues
with my period since I was 12 years old
nobody's ever taken it seriously I've
taken endless birth control I've changed
diets I've done Exercise I've done
everything under the sun it was
miserable um I knew I was wanted to have
children so I did not pursue anything
that would permanently hurt me and my
chances of pursuing that someday um I
had two two beautiful little girls um
after our second daughter was born um
not even 3 months out my husband was
granted a vasectomy because I was done I
could not do it anymore um my I my body
could not handle the
pregnancy and rightfully so I didn't
think I could handle more than two kids
um so right away no questions asked my
husband was 30 years old at the time
granted his vasectomy got it within
weeks whatever done I have
however um have been mentioning to
doctors for years and years and years I
mean we're talking 20 years now of I'm
miserable I can't function I'm in tons
of pain I need
help um my gynecologist who ended up
giving me the surgery this summer I love
her I've seen her for over 10 years she
delivered both of my children when I
first brought um the hysterctomy to her
after having my second child she
straight up said said to me you're too
young and I'm like what does that mean
and um you know I brought up I said I
understand I am young but I've have had
two children and I am miserable let's
talk about quality of life here you know
um I understand the you want to preserve
a healthy body I understand that you
don't want to take out you know things
that um serve a function and it no
longer served a function for me um it
was just so shocking to have my own
doctor say well you're too young I'm 30
years old I have two kids like whatever
so for the last for it took me 6 years
of going mentioning to my doctors
getting increasingly more sick as time
went by before I was finally granted a
Pity hysterctomy and what do you know 6
months ago it happened and my health has
improved so much turns out that the pain
from the endometriosis that everybody
was denying that I didn't have that I
actually did um was causing so much pain
so often I developed psychical vomiting
um I was developing autoimmune disorders
um I really had no life I had to plan
taking care of my children and working
with my husband who works full-time
because I'm a St home mother when he
could be home to take care of the kids
and help me because I am stuck in bed or
I'm bleeding I'm vomiting I I'm just I'm
I'm done I can't do this um please start
wrapping up what I think that this bill
is going to do is give these women who
really need a leg to stand on um a
little bit more support from their home
state with their doctors that listen I
understand you you have concerns for my
future and what you think I want but
honestly for a woman who is in her 30s
her 40s like much of these other women
who already had children it's still a
problem and I really think that there
needs to be a law for patients stating
this that okay I understand your
concerns for my future I am telling you
I need this I want this please perform
this for me thank you uh any questions
representative Shapiro yes thank you Mr
chairman thinking ahead about the
possibility of an amendment I'm trying
to figure out whether your situation
fits
in um A or B um so in your situation
even though you were F into a I had
endometriosis okay so even in your
situation even though you were being
denied the
actual surgery you were being told that
this was a medical solution to the
problems you were having right so um
even if this bill was amended to include
a but not B it would include situations
like yours I I mean if we need to
separate the two then yes absolutely I
think that a is the more important
portion of this for the medically
necessary being denied on these
assumptions but I feel like Part B lumps
in with that there should be no reason
why you can't make a choice over your
body when a stranger you see one time
you know once a year is going to tell
you yes or no for you thank you any
other any other
Sykes good afternoon Representatives I
spoke with you last year specifically
that I kind of have a general idea of
what doctors do since my family's in do
a lot of doctoring I would be an
elective hysterctomy
because since I was a young child I've
had zero desire to have children and I
strongly believe all children should be
wanted more than anything else in the
world and with the wave of anti-abortion
legislation if for some reason I ever
became pregnant it would not be through
my own will um I have no partner and I
have no intention of ever having
one and if I could not get an abortion I
would rather commit suicide than have a
child because I have so many medical
issues in my family no child should be
cursed with that in my opinion and I
don't wholeheartedly want a child if I
want a child I'll go to adoption
services say you know looking for a
child Foster find a kid great that way I
have a child but I don't have to deal
with the damage that it will do to me I
don't have to go off my medication I
don't have to potentially lose my life
because I got pregnant and had a kid and
it killed me like I don't that is not in
my thing however I think most most
important the most important factor in
this bill is that it will not hold a
doctor liable for performing these
procedures um if you change your mind
because from the gynecologists I have
spoken to multiple begging them for
hysterctomy back when I could they have
all said no because of
liability because there's a Hy there's a
history of forced um sterilizations
there's a history of X Y and Z all ended
up with we just can't do them now
because what if you come back and so by
having the specific wording that
protects gynec that protects the
gynecologist from any regrets later I
think it would make it so that people in
my situation who don't necessarily have
a
dehab dehab issue but are genuinely
scared to ever have children and have
zero desire to have them have an
opportunity to have an elective
procedure that is no different than
getting your wisdom teeth out or your
appendix out because you get infections
frequently but just not enough to have
it burst you know there's a lot of
elective procedures people do that
permanently affect your body that
doctors are quite willing to do and yet
you won't get rid of the thing that
causes me pain every month that I have
to deal with bleeding every month that I
have to deal with all uh emesis every
month I mean sorry but I I I
not a fan of the
uterus and I'm happy to take questions
any
you excuse me also signed up to speak is
Lauren
Fitch good afternoon my name is Lauren
Fitch I'm a writer an advocate for the
free and a lifelong sufferer of
endometriosis who moved to New England
for grad school we met last year at this
very same hearing tooth loss stroke high
blood pressure loss of gray matter in
the brain internal bleeding and the
highest cause of death for women my age
worldwide am I speaking of tubal
ligations and hysterectomies no I'm
talking about
pregnancy I got my period at the age of
N9 by the age of 12 I was in so much
pain that I was passing out my mother
did what any mom would do and put me on
hormonal birth control that's when my
life changed I developed chronic
depression and anxiety both things I had
been free of before I started hormones
at the age of 25 I decided to stop at
the age of 26 I had to go through
experimental treatment for treatment
resistant depression though I am cured
now my endometriosis remains I have
tried every birth control Under the Sun
yet whenever I approach a doctor in the
entire New England region three
different states by the way to help me I
get the same response have you you tried
an IUD what about the Depo yeah I have
the IUD made me dissociate for a year
straight and the Depo shot almost made
me stop
breathing as a journalist I've spent the
fast past five months interviewing women
over 50 about their decision to stay
childree the biggest question I asked
them was this do you regret it not a
single one
did I am not here to make people who
want kids childree but I am here to ask
for compassion for parents who have had
as many children as they can handle
cancer patients women like me with endo
and women who simply like me never felt
the call to be a mother I said last year
Parenthood is beautiful but only if you
want it for me it would not be I finally
found a doctor to do my surgery but I
have to go 600 miles
away if I was 28 and single and walked
into an IVF Clinic regardless of ability
to love care for and financially handle
a child I would be applauded and
celebrated my doctor would say nothing
why is my choice demonized when I would
argue it's
responsible only I know my limits and
only I know how I suffer I have many
friends with wonderful children but I
cannot do what they do this is a
bipartisan issue my entire family
consists of bluecollar workingclass
Republicans and they love this bill I am
a registered
Republican I suspect there are issues
that I would agree and disagree with any
of you about but the truth is I was
raised with the American values of
freedom and personal responsibility
wouldn't it stand to reason that the
Live Free or di die state would uphold
those values as well while I love seeing
your faces I really don't want to have
to come back here next year the only
doctor that should be interested in a
patient's personal life is their
therapist please don't let other women
suffer and to answer your questions
actually I do fall into both paragraph A
and
B I will come back as long as I have to
but I Leave You with this today you have
the choice to make a historic decision
to do the right thing and to end the
suffering of hundreds if not thousands
of people but it's up to you if you will
I can take any questions that anybody
has thank you any
questions I'm seeing none thank
you hey no one else has signed up to
speak on this bill uh four people did
sign up on the blue sheet in the back in
favor and one signed up against and
represent way are you looking up the
online and we'll find out how many
online signed up and a lot more people
are playing from home 60 people signed
in to support and four to
oppose okay with that I am going to
close the public hearing on HB 1067 and
open the public hearing on hb1
1607 I wish those two numbers didn't
have to come that close together those
bills didn't have to come that closely
together uh but um once again recognize
the prime sponsor on 1067 uh excuse me
cordelli I'll run over to education
behind
yes
sure
care we are going to take a f five
yep
we
in this
legislation first uh section um on the
top of the page deals with baby boxes um
and we will have a representative uh uh
coming behind me who will explain what
baby boxes are and uh why they're
avaluable
uh second is the
um is the um number of days um which
you'll see beginning on line
14 um of the legislation where we expand
the number of days uh for the uh age
that a baby can be um surrendered at a
safe haven location um to from 7 to 61
days and thirdly um the uh
part that I'd like to uh talk about is
the uh exclusionary rule which is on the
bottom of the page Roman 2 uh that
continues on to the second
page um exclusionary rules provide
anonymity and the elimination of fear of
Investigation for a parent who is
surrendering a uh baby at a safe haven
location it is based on the 14th
Amendment to our constitution
and was originally instituted to prevent
uh searches and seizures in violation of
the Fourth Amendment and to provide
remedies to defendants whose rights have
been infringed um this was used in the
development of the Miranda
warnings it is not uncommon to be used
with the safe haven law in approximately
17 States anonymity for parents is
expressly guaranteed in Statute in 39
States Safe Haven providers cannot be
compelled to provide identifying
information for um uh providing
identifying information and 17 states
provide Insurance of
confidentiality for even voluntary
information that might be um presented
by the um by the by the
parent
um
I will point out that the exclusionary
rule is intended to uh prevent
um cases in which a parent might be
prosecuted um if identified when uh
surrendering the baby for some prior um
outstanding warrant or crime of some
sorts the whole intention with this is
that we want the B
to be surrendered live to a safe
location where the baby can be cared
for a parent in crisis as we've seen in
uh several recent examples here in New
Hampshire
um we want the baby alive and it um the
prosecution of a parent is
secondary uh to the life of the baby um
we have the uh example um just a year or
so ago of the dolphin Ace case um in
which the mother surrendered a baby to a
hospital in
Manchester uh the um Hospital find that
found drugs in the system of the baby
contacted uh the police um who did an
investigation and um found prior crimes
committed by the mother um in including
um a former child who was found uh
deceased we don't
want that mother Danielle in this case
who said that she wanted to give up the
baby and
and we want her to be able to do that
without fear of being prosecuted from
some former for some former offense um
the option would be unfortunately
possibility of having her baby dumped in
a dumpster if she was afraid of being um
investigated for a prior crime um I've
given you several
handouts um including some statistics
from the national Safe Haven Alliance um
another uh about a Kentucky couple I
just happened to hear this interview on
the radio driving home um a week ago
with this couple they had just just
adopted a baby in
Kentucky the baby had been deposited in
a baby box in Kentucky 2 years ago and
this couple had been contacted to as
foster care parents for that child and
now we're adopting the child it was a it
was a heartwarming story and so this is
an article about that um there's another
article about uh over the past decade
six children under the age of two have
died of
overdoses could we have saved those
children If the parents had taking them
to a safe haven location and the final
one is the most
disturbing um infant remains found in a
Massachusetts recycling facility that's
exactly exactly what we are trying to
prevent with Safe Haven law and with the
expansion of the safe haven law we want
we want the the live baby rather than
Prosecuting a mother or a father for
some crime um that is the uh main goal
of this and I think that should be all
of our goals to save that baby's
life and let
um whatever um situation the parents are
in um take care of themselves um we have
you know the drug epidemics the
opioids
um it's very
common um for um us around the country
to see stories of parents who are um
abusing their child because of their
addiction and um if that parent in a
Moment of clarity can decide that they
want their baby to be saved and not be
in danger uh from what might happen
during a drug episode um and have a safe
haven location or a baby box um to uh
surrender that child I think that's
that's what we want to see happen um
with this and I'll just add that
um uh it's a a little bit personal for
me I was adopted at a very young age
from a New York City orphanage but I
working on this I couldn't help but
think if my parents were in a different
circumstance es could I have ended up in
a
dumpster and so it um I'm glad to be
able to present this bill to you I I
think it's um very important expansion
of our um Safe Haven laws that are uh so
valuable uh here in New Hampshire and as
are others around the country thank you
very much thank you before I turn it
over to the committee for questions um I
have a couple of my own uh this is
basically in Le of the old uh the old
idea of leaving it on the the baby on
the doorstep or something like that
right it's a much more modern
sophisticated safe concept basically yes
so dep safe havens are at a 24hour man
facilities such as a hospital or
firehouse and you'll hear from someone
about uh um a newer method that's um
gaining some popularity around the
country in terms of baby boxes um they
have several names the other question I
had uh I've gotten some calls on this
and perhaps all of us on the committee
have about how unsafe these are how
dangerous these baby boxes are um U one
person that I've talked
to describes them as a converted Pig
Troth uh I mean look I'm looking at a
pretty impressive array of of sponsors
and co-sponsors here all of whom I have
great respect for so I I I find it
difficult to believe any of you would
sign on to a bill that that um provided
such a thing but I've gotten some pretty
damning comments and I just want if
you've heard any any of these yourself
and what's your reaction might be uh I
have okay emails and phone calls um as a
number of people um some behind me have
have received um and this is one
particular gentleman uh from
Massachusetts um I think I've spoken to
that gentleman yes right um and and uh
he has been uh wherever uh legislation
is proposed like this he has been
reaching out to people and even going to
hearings um there are restraining orders
in against him in numerous States
Indiana I know for one we have copies of
of that um restraining order um and
that's why we have um um because of some
of the threatening nature of some of the
letters that I know I've received um we
have notified security and um even
provided them pictures of him in case he
um wanted maybe cause a scene here but
um yeah I I uh give him no Credence and
I don't I think people around the
country um realize um uh who he is and
what he's doing thank you other
questions representative Weber
I know you touched on this in your
testimony but I am very
troubled at the idea that I at the idea
of with an extended time
frame adding in the provision that's not
in current law that allows for a handoff
of a child
um without any kind of accountability
for what has happened to that child in
the meantime and I know this is an
argument that we got regularly when we
talked about perhaps needle exchanges or
people trying to dispose of illicit
drugs and protections that we made for
them to get to where they needed to go
to do what they needed to do uh but what
I am concerned about is what we do about
the infant who is a month old and a
parent simply loses
it causes
considerable harm physical harm to that
child short of death but physical harm
to that child and then simply uses this
law as a way of being
of avoiding the liability for the harm
that they caused and that is of great
concern to me
um I speaking for myself um I'm more
interested in Saving that that baby um
we as in your case you've said that baby
is alive maybe has um some injury or
something but if that mother or father
had not given up that baby isn't it very
likely or certainly a possibility that
that baby would end up dead being in
that house continually rather than being
uh surrendered at a safe haven location
where that baby is now alive and can be
um possibly as we saw in that Kentucky
case um eventually adopted into a loving
family um so for me um I'll choose um
life of the baby over uh prosecution of
the mother for this crime uh who you
know maybe uh you know could be
prosecuted for other crimes in the
future uh based on other other
circumstances but uh for me I I come
down on the side of saving that
baby other questions representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman um in
regards to um line 29 on page one the
part about
um
excluding legal ramifications for um
Behavior under pursuant to this law this
may be splitting hairs but does that
mean that um the fact that
they dropped off their child
um according to this law cannot be used
against them as some kind of evidence of
bad character to um to um using a a case
against some other wrongdoing that they
had done correct but it doesn't mean
they can't be pursued criminally for
some
other via some other means right right
some other comes to light um uh for
instance um in that dolphin's case um
where a prior child um died um isn't it
likely that at some point someone would
realize that child is missing just like
in the harmony um case we've been
reading about eventually someone
realizes that child is missing what
happened to that child where is that
child and so they were um investigated
and are being prosecuted for that via
another Avenue other than um uh giving
up a baby at a safe haven
location thank you representative Seth
King thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking questions 61 days is an arbitrary
number can you explain to me how you
came up with that number and also if
more amount of time to surrender a child
is better um why not more than 61 days
there must be some sort of curve going
on where you know the longer the better
and then all a sudden too long is too
long and so you stopped at 61 can you
explain the reasoning behind that thank
you thank you um there are various ages
in all 50 states um the seven days that
we have in statute now um I think is the
lowest number in New England at this
point uh several of the New England
states are now up to 30 days um I know
there are several states that um one
state in in fact in fact um is a year um
for surrender of a baby so we tried to
be um somewhere um in the middle and we
thought that two months um was a
reasonable number and there'll be
another um representative to talk more
about the uh number of
days other questions representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair also thank
you canell taking the question on line 7
it says 24 hours a day I assume that
also means 365 year round and not 5 days
a week and number two is dealing with
law enforcement a fire department when
you have an all alarm fire and literally
you empty the firehouse there's nobody
there so I'm concerned if all of a
sudden we have a box even though it's
alarmed that if someone's not there what
do we
do
um as you indicated that that box is
alarmed and um it's uh almost like an
incubator so um there certainly can be
hours that that baby would be safe in
that baby box and there'll be someone
else to talk about baby boxes also um
but um in that Kentucky case I think
that the baby was um in the baby box uh
possibly for uh 20 some OD hours so um
there is a it's a very comforting
environment um heated and it's uh um
meant to be a safe haven for that baby
time follow up thank you it makes me
feel a little more comfortable the other
question I would have is that when a
child has many children that have been
born to a mother with an opiate
dependency and therefore the child
becomes opiate
dependent what do you do with the
children that are left in a baby box
that are opiate dependent who need to be
taken care of because you're not giving
that baby to another human being giving
it to a box and 20 hours is a long
time um yeah I I I think 20 hours would
be um ex extended length of time I'm
usually there within an hour or two and
since it's a a man facility um and the
alarm goes off there usually will be
someone readily available to go and um
baby other
questions representative Seth King thank
you again Mr chair uh thank you for
taking another question mine sure can a
woman who surrenders her child to a baby
box or otherwise um can she ever get
that child
back um um I I believe it's an actual
surrender of the child so she would need
in order to probably go go through and
get adoption paper and or you know go
through all that process okay follow up
follow up um have you ever seen any
examples where maybe a mother is coerced
by let's say the father into
surrendering the baby to a baby box and
then later has regrets and wants it back
and can't get it back have you seen
anything like that thank you I I have
not read of situations like that not
that you know I'm not sure if it's
happened but uh I have not seen any
examples of
that other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is
Pearson thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Mark Pearson and while I hold
a number of titles one I really cherish
is Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs chairman ameritus which I share
with a couple of people
here I'm not going to duplicate what
others have said or what I know others
will be saying I will just simply limit
my remarks to the change in the safe
haven age this bill of course is asking
to change the age limit from 7 days to
61 days that's line 15
just in New England Maine Vermont
Connecticut Rhode Island have all
extended their safe haven age limits to
at least 30 days and we are seven days
at present looking across the country we
discover Missouri's age limit is 45 days
Kansas Louisiana South Carolina South
Dakota and Texas 60 days and a few even
higher than that
we see the trend and I humbly ask the
committee to help n Hampshire join in
with the others in expanding the age to
days in my new assignment in the house
uh they are trying to turn me into a
lawyer so here's a bit from that the
question of
protecting from prosecution let me give
you a few
parallels what about evidence
obtained without a search waren that's
out now we may say that evidence would
convict a bad person but yes what
about charging in anywhere just because
the police feel like it and don't have a
warrant most people would agree it's
better to let some evidence that was
truly probative go by the way side in
order to keep
warrants as our rule of action the book
called Rules of Evidence 280 Pages the
500 section speaks of privileged
communication between doctors and
patients priests and penitents
counselors and
clients now you may know in the course
of your
professional capacity certain things
that might help Justice flow
better but would it be right then for
you to report these certain things I
know there's
exclusions that would have a chilling
effect on people seeking professional
help I live this one in two
capacities so there is good precedent
and good reason around to say yeah it
would really be nice if we could nail
these bad parents for what they did to
the little baby they've dropped off but
as the previous one giving testimony
said
wouldn't that have a chilling effect
wouldn't it be more likely the parents
would kill the child and bury the child
than drop the child off alive even if
damaged so that's my testimony Mr
chairman thank you our representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking this question you know as
well as
The Logical reason for not um excluding
this is this act as evidence of
wrongdoing in some other case because
you don't want to deinen divize a person
from actually saving their child isn't
the whole idea of this that it's also
Anonymous and that people in most cases
won't know who that parent or parents
are this I believe is true but there are
ones who might
suggest I don't know I'm speaking
hypothetically here hidden camera right
and this says no you don't do this any
more than they would bug your office or
my
confessional representative
notam thank you Mr chairman um how many
children have been dropped off at a safe
haven box in New Hampshire in the last
year or the last five years well as you
know I'm a processed person not a detail
person so I'd best let somebody who
actually knows the answer answer that
sorry okay no that's fine all right
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking
questions um are you concerned that um a
slightly opposite question of what I
asked earlier are you concerned that um
uh a baby may be um forfeited by one
parent and the other parent was UN un
unwit you know unwitting that it even
happened and unwilling that it would
happen and then they lose custody as
well
I'm as concerned about that as I am
about one parent beating the child
against the wishes of the other one or
one parent taking the child out of State
against the wishes of the other one yeah
I'm concerned about that and I now am in
children and family law and the uh
special committee on reformer family
court so believe me I've been hearing a
lot about that yeah it does concern me
sometimes there's a lot of good with a
little bit of negative in there and um
other
you also signed up to speak is
dry thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee uh for the record I'm
representative Margaret dry serving
Sullivan district 7 which is Newport
Unity Charlestown planfield and
Cornish and I'm here today in support of
this bill because I am fairly certain
that I am the only person in the room
who's ever responded to a baby left on a
doorstep about 20 years ago before the
first baby safe haven bill um made its
way through the legislature um as an EMT
I was called to uh a report of a Child
Left Outside um it was a day like this
it had snow it had uh barely double
digit temperatures Bleak
day and um my first thought is a toddler
who had at nap time maybe snuck out the
door or somebody who'd been locked out
of the house uh when we got to the house
it was two older women sisters who had
heard something at the front door and
opened the door and found a baby in a
car seat um they brought the baby into
the police chief that responded said uh
Margaret you have nine kids how old is
this
baby I said I have no idea yeah um it
had still had bit umbilical cord so it's
like within this you know but my babies
are small this baby was large it was I
said I I really can't tell um it didn't
really matter the important thing was
the baby had been found and was alive
and uh and what I learned from this and
I can apply to this bill is
um it took me a while to say I am in
21st century New Hampshire why is this
Dickens England thing going on in my
neighborhood and uh I'm was one of the
first people to testify on the baby safe
haven bill because that was such an
immediate experience for me at that
point but I'm thinking that um so many
things could have gone so wrong that
afternoon and um to have a Haven place
even if it's a box is much better than
someone's doorstep if they don't know
you're there uh on a day like
this and the 7 to 61 days again 61 seems
an like you threw something at the wall
and that's where it's stuck but um seven
is too short I mean it's not fair to the
people receiving and it's really very
difficult to to estimate if you have no
but given the fog that some new mothers
go through um I would say two months is
not too bad to make a decision um and
certainly uh better than the alternative
and that's why I would like to see this
bill pass and I would be happy to
entertain any questions thank you any
you
also signed up to speak is
paternal you've indicated five minutes
if you could keep it to three that'd be
great it's probably really not five
minutes okay thanks I try not to do that
to people um thank you and good
afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee for the record I'm Katie
peternell representing Carol district 6
wolfboro and Tuftonboro I will be
specifically referencing section one of
House Bill 1606 which pertains to
enabling a local hospital law
enforcement agency or fire department a
facility that is staffed 24 hours a day
to have a device or container installed
where an infant can anonymously be
placed for
relinquishment the purpose of including
this device in the bill is to offer an
opportunity for anonymity for the
relinquishing parent there is no
taxpayer funding or requirement for a
safe haven location to install one of
these boxes installation would depend
entirely upon Comm Community involvement
and
fundraising there is currently only one
manufacturer of such a device the safe
haven baby box we are not advocating for
a particular device however since this
is the only product currently on the
market these are the only experiences we
can really reference Arizona does have
baby drawers but they are installed and
built during construction or
renovation the device is installed into
the side of a building with exterior AC
access for the relinquishing parent and
interior access for staff the current
product includes a packet of information
for the parent on where they can receive
help for drug addiction human
trafficking domestic abuse their rights
after relinquishing a child even help if
they should decide to keep their child
before they put it in the Box um the
intent is to assist all involved in the
situation to find the help that they
need we certainly don't a parent
relinquishing their child is not the
optimal situation we would far prefer
parents to keep their children and offer
them the help they need to to take care
of their child after the child is placed
in the device and the door closes it
locks so now the parent can no longer
take the child back they've made the
decision the alarm sound inside the
building and staff can easily access the
infant on the inside of the building the
device is clear ventilated plexiglass
and the infant is visible to passing
staff so you have two safety mechanisms
you have alarms that immediately go off
and if somebody should be walking by and
it's a staffed facility um they'll see
the baby so to date all relinquished
infants have been retrieved within 2
minutes so that that should alleviate
some fears about the baby being there
for any significant amount of time and
the drawers operate similarly but I
haven't been able to find anything about
I haven't been able to find an actual
picture of the box I actually just found
notice that they were available last
night and it's too soon to or too not
not enough time to contact and get all
of that information um two possible
issues that should be clarified with
these devices um they are not medical
devices so they are do not need to be
certified by the um US Food and Drug
Administration and there is a heater
inside the box that circulates room air
and the same heater is used in the
drawers in Arizona as well as in the
baby
boxes so in conclusion these boxes offer
a layer of protection to the
surrendering parent by ensuring that
they can anonymously relinquish their
child honestly I can't even I'm sure any
of you who have been parents or you
don't even have to be a parent the
thought of saying here is my baby take I
can't take care of this child that would
be one of the hardest things to do um no
matter what your circumstances so with
this box you can say you you know you
can just put the baby in and walk away
and leave it at that so it would be far
better to have a baby relinquished alive
in one of these devices than to find a
child dead somewhere because of some
form of abuse this is a loving and
caring option for babies who otherwise
might suffer in other
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you for taking the question um
it's nice to hear about the two-minute
retrieval of a child that's for me is
very accompaning one of the things I
want to follow up on representative Seth
King's comment I'm looking back if you
look at
line uh 22 to
23 if you have a situation where you
have one parent that wants retribution
if you will against the other parent and
takes the child and puts them in the
child's safety box if they report that
child is missing would that then
curtail the issue of the child being
abandoned by both
parents yes thank you
yeah other
questions I don't see any thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak our attorney
Susan larabe and John Williams from the
Services
chairman McDonald members of the Health
Human Services LD Affairs committee for
the record my name is John Williams I'm
the legislative director for Health
Human Services and with me today is good
afternoon my name is Susan laraby I Am
The General Counsel for DCF I am the
chief of legal regulation and uh
legislatively aison thank you and we
appreciate the opportunity to come
before the committee I know we're down
for 3 minutes you it's been late in the
day so we're going to get right to the
point uh we're here to provide
information to committee uh in terms of
the access we certainly um understand
and appreciate the sponsors for the bill
why they're bringing it Forward uh as
you're probably aware there's currently
already in statute uh around the safe
haven and attorney larby certainly can
address questions and part of her
commentary she has prepared to discuss
that but I just want to make it really
clear where the department has some
concerns they want to bring to the
attention of the committee uh if you uh
we're fine in terms of the access uh
issue and expanding the time frame for
which you can uh drop off a child seem
to be reasonable in legislation and
consistent with current law uh as it
relates to the uh safe havens our our
concerns are with section four of the
bill uh on the new Roman paragraph 2
starting on lines 29 and it goes
proceeds to the following page all the
way through uh lines two uh what I do
have prepared in this came as a work
product working with at least
representative from the Department of
Justice to give us some guidance as well
as working with attorney laraby and our
staff at DCF uh if we're going to point
out a problem with the bill we want to
come prepared with a solution for it now
I'm going to say this is the department
solution it doesn't represent anybody
else's idea of what a solution to this
bill might be but we want to put it out
there for the committee's consideration
so I do have 20 copies of the proposed
language that we'd like to circulate and
then if attorney larby could walk you
through the rationale as to our concerns
are as well as why we think that this is
a a balanced perspective in terms of
addressing uh an amendment an amendment
that we would propose that we actually
would be supportive of uh the uh
language that we're proposing not what
is in the bill so with that yes thank
you as attorney uh Williams um addressed
already it is the issue of what we have
been term hearing today is called the
exclusionary rule and again I believe uh
representative Pearson used the term
exclusionary rule and then gave some
analogies to that in terms of
exclusionary rule is used often when it
comes to wrongdoing wrongdoing though on
behalf of the state when it comes to
violations of search and seizure
constitutional issues not violations by
actual perpetrator and this is what that
would do it would give the perpetrator
blanket immunity as to what some of you
have already addressed to physical abuse
of a child by saying hey I released that
child to a safe haven or a hospital or
now a possible uh Safe Haven box
therefore I am immune from any criminal
or civil liability that stems from that
investigation and that would have
horrific results in terms of we can take
a scenario where evidence obtained the
way it's written evidence obtained as a
direct consequence of the parent acting
pursuant to this chapter that is very
broad that can mean that until this baby
comes into the custody of DCF and
involves law enforcement pursuant to
this St
statue that anything happening prior to
that baby the perpetrator would be
immune from accountability we would have
a baby possibly severely injured and
then dropped in a safe haven box or
placed with a safe haven entity or a
hospital and that would be incon
consistent with what we're trying to do
protect children and hold offenders
accountable if you all remember and I'll
address the the 2003 legislation first
it already allows for anonymous uh
surrender of the child by stating in the
sorry uh the child's parent or parent
shall not be required to reveal
personally identified valuable
information so that is already Allowed
by Statute furthermore in 2003 it
already excluded or excluded at that
time criminal liability for the crime of
endangering the welfare of a child for
parents who surrender their CH children
to a safe haven or to a hospital by
sorry
no person acting in accordance with the
provisions of RSA
1322a the safe haven law shall be guilty
of an offense under this section so yes
they're wrongdoing for dropping the baby
at the safe haven would be already
protected under 6393 they would not be
found criminal Li liable for the offense
of endangering the welfare of a
child and just to give a little bit more
context um we dcyf does not keep data as
to the specificities as to how many
children have been surrendered uh to
Safe Haven or hospital or a hospital but
I did do some digging and asked the Bure
bureau chief of field services as well
as Deanna Baker the uh Department of
Justice Attorney in Charge um of all
169c cases and based on their
recollection they believe that only a
handful about five cases since 2003 have
been babies that have been relinquished
none of those babies have been
relinquished to a safe haven based on
their memory the relinquishment was to a
hospital
setting um and again we believe that the
amendment that we presented today would
have the effect of protecting the parent
from being filed against is how we
phrase it held accountable for the
action
of abandoning that child so therefore
they already have criminal um no
criminal liability for the act of
Abandonment now they would also under
our Amendment not have a civil uh
petition filed against them for
abandonment how it works right now is
that according to the law the way the
law reads and well as policy with dcyf
the parents um the child comes into d CF
temporary custody well they have to have
legal authority over the child so they
seek basically an exp parte order by the
judge to put the child into legal
custody and proceed by abandonment DCF
can certainly proceede under a 463
limited guardianship of this child and
not um file against a mother who is
trying her best to do the right thing on
behalf of this child to relinquish her
rights and then it will go through the
normal Court course as you mentioned the
normal course for limited guardianship
would still include looking for the
missing parent if there is a missing
parent where is the father that the
father want to relinquish his rights as
well you know doing the full circuit
investigation that this child deserves
to get timely permanency whether it be
with a kin or a relative and not punish
the mother for doing the right thing and
relinquishing her rights but of course
holding an offender accountable if that
offender physically abused that child
prior to relinquishing their rights and
not saying hey I have blanket immunity
according to this uh
statute thank you thank you any
questions representative Merchant it
clarification If the child is
left
anonymously how is anyone going to track
down the parent because they're supposed
to be anonymous so therefore if you know
who the parent is you don't have an
anonymity anymore so I'm trying to
understand when you talk about being
anonymous how do you protect the amony
anonymity of the parent at the same time
take care of the child because in
essence you've broken
that first so chair chairman uh if we
could respond because it's getting later
in the day currently under the law this
law is not trying to change anything as
it relates to the uh keeping Anonymous
the information so that we're not here
on that specific issue really and we
just want to if we're going to land on
one issue that we do want to uh um um
respond to is the Department's suggested
uh change and why it makes some sense
the current Provisions that you see in
Roman 3 is is exactly like attorney
Larry B was commenting it gives blanket
immunity for all all criminal offenses
that could be caused to that child prior
to the delivery of the child we as a
department are on the side of thinking
to ourselves this may not be a good
policy to promote in our state that you
can get immunity because nowhere else in
state law do you see this kind of
immunity granted and in fact the
Department of Justice if you had further
consultation with them they're very
hesitant ever to even open up immunity
so the current law already contemplates
some level of a balancing act of the
appropriate amount of immunity that
should be provided uh in those
circumstances our feelings are that as
well as intended as this legislation is
and we completely understand the
position of the folks who brought this
measure forward we think it goes a
little bit too far in terms of giving
complete immunity for whatever harm was
caused to that child prior to that child
being delivered so our hope is that your
committee will consider and whether this
goes to a subcommittee or you can do it
like a great way just people working
together uh that we're proposing the
language that you see here which is a
briefer uh one sentence very clearly
language and I'm going to ask attorney
larby to uh uh explain that read it and
explain it and I think that that would
likely answer the questions why we're
here today and what we'd like to leave
you with and I see rent kful but if it's
okay I can have um attorney Larry be if
it's okay with represent go you explain
the
amendment go ahead is okay sure I think
I already did in terms of there's
already a provision in the endangering
and Welfare of a child statute that a
parent who surrenders their child
pursuant to this chapter will not be
held accountable or not be charged for
endangering the welfare of a child and
then this amendment would clarify that a
parent acting pursuant to this chapter
shall not be subject to a petition under
RSA 169c the child protection act abuse
and neglect alleging neglect
solely based based solely excuse me on
the actions described in this chapter
again clarifying that the state can
proceed with a tempor orary uh
guardianship of this child by other
means rather than going forward with um
an abuse neglect petition against this
parent and again uh to clarify a little
bit what representative Merchant said
the statute already also includes that a
child's parents or parent shall not be
required to reveal personally identif
identifiable information and that would
remain I believe that's not part of the
bill representative kofalt you had your
hand up a moment ago yes thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question so can you clarify um it it
sounds like you are saying when you keep
referring to blanket immunity it sounds
like you are saying that there's no
distinction between excluding certain
evidence versus excluding any and all
evidence and and it seems to me that
exclusion of evidence is is is not
tantamount to blanket immunity sure um
so I'm I'm I'm struggling with this one
a little bit and and I guess as part of
that I will point out that um we do
offer immunity through um I'm not sure
what the status of the safe stations
program is at this point but but there
are other examples in which we offer
immunity to people who have a substance
abuse problem for example and come to
law enforcement and say I need help so
um so again my question refers to the
the distinction between exclusion of
evidence versus blanket immunity you're
absolutely right thank you for the
question is that it's written as an
evidentiary rule as an exclusionary rule
but it's written in a way that can be I
believe misc we believe misconstrued
because it's so broad saying evidence
obtained as a direct consequence of the
parent acting pursuant to this chapter
shall be subject to an exclusionary rule
so therefore because many of these cases
again these are the most vulnerable
members of our society right nonverbal
infants seven days old and well if this
bill passes uh two months old so they
can't tell in any other way what
happened to them so it is their bodies
that speak for themselves when this baby
is found so this is saying that because
the way it says direct consequence of
this action the relinquishment of this
child that's how it becomes in the
purview of DCF of law enforcement of a
hospital who now can care for this child
pursuant to the safe haven law has as it
already stands so therefore you could
make an argument if you are a defense
attorney or a parent attorney or you
know that hey
we have blanket immunity based on the
strict reading of this common law common
language that saying evidence obtained
is a direct consequence that's basically
all evidence of that baby because that
baby became uh germine to a an
investigation due to the B baby being
placed in a safe haven box or a safe
haven ENT entity or a
hospital so it's very expansive and I do
we do view it as basically giving
blanket immunity to IR doer follow up
thank you um so so that kind of leads to
I guess the fundamental problem which is
um if if the objective is to take away
any fear or disincentive barri and if we
believe that a child in the custody of a
hospital and eventually the state is is
preferable to the the child in the
custody of of an abusive negligent or
incapable
parent then is it not appropriate to
offer some some level of assurance that
you can do this without being without
the fear that we're going to come after
you because I mean and and and I'll just
put it in very very blunt terms which is
like your choice then is between like do
you would would you prefer
um a a child in custody who who can who
can be safe from this point
forward um and hold somebody
accountable versus hold somebody
accountable but the the child may be
dead I mean I that really is what it
comes down to for me is the question so
I I understand the objection and the
concern I'm trying to understand how you
square that Circle sure and I that's why
I think the amendment reconciles that
because you already have that the parent
will not be held Criminal liable for
endangering the welfare of a child for
the action of surrendering that child
and now with the amendment you would
have a parent not facing a petition for
Abandonment for their action of
child representative
uh I think you had your hand up a moment
ago thank you Mr chairman and I just
wanted to be clear because what I was
handed is the amendment is not
particularly clear um the
first
1332a for liability is that the language
in the current statute or the language
in the bill if we can address that the
the first reference is actually what is
currently in the legislation okay the
one that says proposed amendment we need
to be clear no it's not in law it is not
a law it's the amendment in the in the
bill this is House Bill 167 that's what
I said in the bill yes not in statute
correct and then our agency's proposed
amendment in other words our solution we
didn't want to come to the sponsors or
this committee without that part I got
that's your proposed solution to it I
just wanted to know whether the first
part was current law or currently in the
Bill thank you representative mour thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question and it's off of what
uh representative Merchants send before
is how can you how can this amendment go
into effect as it was mentioned before
if the delivery of the baby is
anonymous like how how would you enforce
this if if it's you don't know who the
parent is who dropped it off sure we
don't need to enforce it that this is
just saying that if a parent chooses to
drop off a baby and give their name so
when the state reaches out to that
parent they know that they're not
reaching out to file charges against
them they're reaching out to assist them
in surrendering their
child follow up follow up so I believe
isn't the point though of these safe
havens Anonymous so why would that
parent give their name in doing that
it's minor saying the ones that have
been used have given their names because
they're at the they're in a hospital
setting and they have surrendered their
child at that time sorry follow you said
so I I would be interested in hearing um
you mentioned the hospital settings but
I would like like to hear evidence of
Safe Haven boxes being used outside of a
hospital setting if there well there
safe there are no Safe Haven boxes in
New Hampshire yet okay but and or
keeping that data I think I heard it
before that that data wasn't being
kept well there is no Safe Haven box
there's Safe Haven entities okay um that
are I'm sorry referring to the original
statute um Safe Haven is defined as
means of church which is attended by a
person or a police or fire station which
is attended by a person or a 911
responder at an agree transfer location
and that's what I'm referring to so you
do have information of babies that have
been dropped off at those no it's my
understanding again this because we
don't keep data this is just going to um
with my questions to the field
administrator who has a wealth of
Knowledge from her you know two decades
working since it's been past as well as
Dina Baker the same a couple decades
with uh doj um that they were not
because it says hospital or Safe Haven
so it's the hospital setting that the
five or so have been relinquished to
yeah uh representative Merchant did you
have your hand up then representative
Weber I
did thank you Mr chairman it's been a
long day in regards to the liability I'm
trying to understand this so what the
Department's trying to propose or is
proposing for an amendment is to narrow
down
the exclusionary basically we're talking
about child protection act that's what
we're trying to exclude and I don't know
enough about the law and looking how
it's written now about the direct
consequence if I'm taking my child to a
safe haven and stop at the convenience
store and Rob it because it's a direct
consequence of my dropping off that
accountable I it's far you somebody
who's good at attorney could try to make
the argument I'm trying to get
and and and chairman McDonald and and
just in responding to that um our
concern with the bill with the amendment
in the Bill is that it's so expansive
that there would be an unintended
consequence that a individual could
perpetrate harm to a child and be be
precluded from being prosecuted for that
offense that's a policy decision for you
folks to make because I completely do
hear the other side of the conversation
but we are concerned about granting
immunity from prosecution for people who
harm children and that's what are I hope
we can be left with that one statement
and why we're proposing what we're
hoping is a suggested amendment that
would at least address the issue of
removing some of the stigma or
disincentives for dropping off a child
and and this was worked on very
thoughtfully this was not just I mean we
have a wonderful attorney with to
attorney larby but also with the
Department of Justice internally with
our folks so a lot of thought did go
into trying to come up with a compromise
rather than just coming in here and
please striking the remainder part of
the bill we really did try to make an
Earnest effort to to meet that Delta and
I didn't know if attorney larby had
anything else she loan to offer
representative
Weber so I'm trying to figure out
procedures afterwards because at the
moment my understanding is that the bill
requires something even even though it
it confers anonymity it does require
what I would consider a warm handoff you
have to give
it to a person of course um and there
needs to be an insurance that this is
not a missing child that's why law
enforcement's brought in here's my here
that's a whole another question and I've
got a lot of questions about that and
you'll be glad to know I'm not going to
answer ask any of them tonight but my
concern is tell me what the procedure is
for
DCF when a firefighter EMT calls up and
says I've got this baby who looks real
young and we just were handed it or
found it in a box I don't care about
that
aspect uh we don't know the parent name
we don't know if the person who handed
it to us is the parent we don't know who
this child
is that child goes to DCF what does DC
do at that point sure so and I'm talking
about the legal procedure I assume they
find a foster family immediately and the
child is safe or in the hospital or
whever the kid needs to be but what's
the legal procedure and they immediately
notify a judge on call the on call Judge
to get what's called emergency interim
relief pursuant to the 169c statute and
that would give them protective
supervision SL legal custody over that
child to then emergency place that child
because they have actual legal right to
do that place that child in an emergency
setting if there's no if it's truly
Anonymous it would it would go you know
the baby would go to a foster uh care
for emergency situation and then the
investigation would begin where the
police would be looking to see who this
baby is is this baby
missing if there is no 169 C case
anymore they would then immediately seek
that through what's called an expar
emergency uh Limited guard uh I'm sorry
temporary guardianship under the uh RSA
uh of guardianship which is
463 again just to get legal authority
over that child this is exactly what I'm
asking you okay sure and then that would
begin the process of having uh the
process making sure that this child
truly is legally free for adoption and
beginning the either termination of
parental rights if there if there is no
parent then going straight to
termination under with with surrender
and again allowing that child to have
permanency which at the end of the day
is the goal right safety first and then
of course permanency that shot so
followup the followup is what are the
Protections in that
process for ensuring that
um one parent
hasn't simply not been told and and you
know there may be cases where the parent
simply hasn't been told that they're a
parent yet sure uh or alternatively that
a person who is not a parent thought it
might be a good idea to have a baby of
their very own and then realized it
wasn't a good idea at all and they want
to get rid of it and then not have
consequences and I agree wholeheartedly
we want that baby to be somewhere safe
but absolutely how do we ensure that
this baby that has arrived anonymously
is truly free right that that that the
other
parents who may not have been involved
in the decision to
surrender um have an
opportunity because of course it would
still be it would still of course and
thank you for the question it would
still be a screened in case and there
would still be a full assessment of that
child because there's many like you said
just a beginning of um questions about
this child is this child truly being
surrounded Ed is this woman a victim of
domestic violence and felt that this was
the best case scenario for this child do
we need to get this mother hooked up
with Services if this mother is not
Anonymous do we need to find a putative
father or an actual known father to have
him surrender his rights um was this
mother suffering from postp especially
because we are moving in up to two
months is this woman mother suffering
from postpartum depression and was
acting in a moment of acute um uh you
know depression that she does not want
to actually surrender her child so as
you mentioned there there's a host of
issues that are going on that would
still be vetted investigated and
assessed thank you representative Lon
and then representative Shapiro um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you very much
for not only being here but staying here
this is really important and I
appreciate the time uh my question is
we're going to end up probably somewhere
in the middle on this evidence of crime
somewhere between that and somewhere
what where what you have because that
should already be within the ability of
the department to not pursue this
neglect based on dropping somebody at a
safe haven as we try and figure out what
that sweet spot is which one do you
think we should give more precedence to
the idea of being able to prosecute the
the parent or making sure that the child
is alive and not we're not finding the
baby's the child's body somewhere which
one should have the ultimate goal
here for so many reasons that's a very
difficult question to answer because the
end of the day of course the life of the
baby is Paramount the safety of the baby
is Paramount we are all in this room
because we are victim centered
especially to our most vulnerable
children our babies however those babies
are if these babies are injured or
even killed by an
offender I can only speak on behalf of
the division was a former prosecutor I
can also say that there should be
offender accountability for horrific
acts against
children thank you it's just trying to
figure out where that line is so that
we're not sacrificing a child for a case
or a case for a child right and each
case is case specific so why have a
blanket immunity you know as a as a
former prosecutor I made decisions all
the time when it comes to you know uh uh
pre-trial settlements or what evidence
is going to be used in court because
again but at the end of the day to have
an exclusionary rule for somebody
that the state did nothing wrong so
exclusionary rules are built on the
foundation of we have a constitution we
have laws and when those laws are broken
we have What's called the fruit of the
poisonous tree so that certain evidence
cannot come into the trial the state did
nothing wrong the state is trying to
protect the child thank you that's
helpful thank you representative Shiro
are you all set okay anyone
else saying no one thank you thank you
time thank
TWY I was going to say good afternoon
but I think I'll say good evening
instead uh Kevin swamy from conquered
New Hampshire I serve as a pastor uh at
restoration for Square Church right here
in conquered New Hampshire just about
four blocks down the road that way um
I'm here to speak just on behalf of uh
the the bill as it stands in favor of uh
we are our location is registered and
signed properly as a safe haven location
here in New Hampshire um During certain
hours when we are staffed and um I'm in
favor of the extension from the the
shorter time frame to 61 days um
specifically because there are
opportunities where and what we've heard
as examples so far are always the worst
case scenar uh worst case scenarios
abuse neglect you also have parents and
because all we've heard really is the
mother but we've also got to take into
account there may be a father who is
trying to care for their infant after
having lost a spouse during child birth
and so there are issues of on on both
sides of the equation where they are
trying their best to do what's right for
this child and just realize that it's
beyond their
bandwidth and to give them the
opportunity to be able to surrender the
child 61 days the expansion of that time
frame allows for their best attempt and
even in some where they're in isolated
Community or I don't even want to use
the word Community isolated and don't
have a community around them to support
them we all understand like it takes a
village and there are some people who
are isolated there are some people who
are all on their own um don't even have
extended family that they can turn to
and and so to have them have the
opportunity for giving it a try and then
realizing I've I've come to the end I
can't do this and to be able to
surrender the child giving that
extension of time frame as well as the
worst case scenarios I deal Hands-On
with those in um unhoused uh scenarios
as well as those that are dealing with
um substance misuse um
and there are there are issues that come
into play and we want to create the
opportunity for life we want to create
the opportunity to give these infants a
a an opportunity for extension of their
life to be able to thrive and so I'm I'm
in favor of the expansion I I won't
speak to anything else of this bill I'm
just I'm in favor of expansion of the
time frame thank you open to any
questions any
questions representative
Weber okay of had your hand up well I
kind of had my hand up because the
question that I have I think Cuts both
ways uh one of the concerns that I have
with the focus on the
surrender is the potential
lack of interaction as as you would have
if the parent was directly involved with
a Child Care Agency where the child care
agency is required to to try and help
that parent parent and parent
successfully and and that's what our
child care um you know our abuse and
neglect statutes are are aimed
towards so part of me is also concerned
about are we denying the
family another opportunity to continue
as a family
when a decision made in
despair uh overtakes them particularly
what brought it to mind was your mention
of people who do not have Community to
moments and I'm not sure which way that
cuts but I'd love your thoughts on it
well and so you're speaking to a pastor
you're speaking to a Shepherd you're
speaking to someone who the first
response to anyone that walks through
our door is going to be love care and
compassion and so we're going to do
whatever we can if you've got a parent
who comes in who is desperate and at the
end at the ends of their their end of
the rope with the infant and they they
don't feel like they have the capacity
we're going to we're going to do what we
can to extend love care and compassion
to that parent and offer assistance that
we can um to Define and determine do
they truly want to surrender this child
or with the ability of having Community
around them could we help propel them
into uh a strong family unit help help
to support them with parenting skills
come around them that's that's going to
be our first response right away if they
still are at that place where they say
I'm sorry I can't do this I just need
you to take the child then we're going
to do
that thank you no any other
questions seeing done thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is former
representative Phyllis
Woods who's been waiting very patiently
back
there thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm appearing as the um
Prime sponsor of the original Safe Haven
bill that ironically was passed and
signed into law exactly 21 years ago in
2003 in
February the um testimony that you heard
from a representative dry was one of the
impetus behind this bill but there were
other
instances of uh of Abandonment uh
primarily at the time there was was a
woman that had gone to an emergency room
hemorrhaging and it was reported that
she had currently given birth at she was
renting a cottage in Hampton Beach and
so the police were dispensed there and
searched the property and found the
infant that had been left in the corner
of the outside
yard so we were very very pleased to
head have so many sponsors on both sides
in the house and the Senate uh to pass
this bill I want to point out uh to just
answer a couple of things that have come
up it was the intent certainly of this
legislation that the relinquishment
would have been
Anonymous uh and it does say as was
pointed out that the parent or parents
relinquishing the child should not be
required to reveal personally
identifiable
information unfortunately that didn't
guarantee their anonymity so I think
that this is uh an effort to be able to
guarantee uh the
anonymity things have changed
considerably over the last 21 years and
now we know there are children that are
being born of of the homeless Community
people that are addicted people that are
uh woefully
um um not qualified to be able to parent
the child and the unfortunate incident
that happened where someone was
identified when they brought in the
child and then prosecuted was the
impetus of behind this change that I
think is required and that is to put um
the um provision uh with this enabling
legislation that they they would be able
to put uh a baby safe haven box uh and
and this does not require that it be a
specific box it would be a receptacle
that would be um installed in um a uh um
an appropriate um facility that is U man
24 hours I I was opposed to this change
originally because
uh I had a lot of questions about the
safe haven box and I contacted the
manufacturer and the um the the whole
Safe Haven nationally to who answered a
lot of the questions that you you would
have naturally um the the child is
generally um found within one to two
minutes they are safe people cannot come
in after and take that child um so I
think that that that is a a very uh
wonderful opportunity for someone who is
fearing prosecution to be able to come
in sight unseen and relinquish that
child I hope that all of these other
questions will um not take your focus
off the main purpose of this and that is
to save a child that's the most
important thing thank you do you have um
is there other any questions for
representative
Woods looks like you covered it pretty
well okay I will say by the way that
this legislation originally passed by an
overwhelming bipartisan majority I think
the vote was something like three 345 to
45 so I hope it will I hope these
revisions that are bringing it up to
date uh and I think are needed I hope
that they will also receive your
bipartisan support support to save the
babies thank thank you very much good
again also signed up to speak is Shannon
action thank you good evening members of
house healing Human Services committee I
appreciate you giving me this time and
for you sticking
around um I want to mention three
different scenarios in which babies
would be helped by the expansion of this
law when we think about babies who could
be saved or helped by this bill we're
not just talking about the obvious
scenario of a baby abandoned in the
woods for one thing children who die of
abuse or neglect in New Hampshire are
usually not AB abandoned by the elements
Outdoors any infant who dies of abuse or
neglect might have been saved by
stronger self Safe Haven protections
just last month for example a wrongful
death suit was filed over the death of
14-day old Matlin kittner a summersworth
baby who allegedly was accidentally
suffocated on a couch as a result of
drug abuse babies like Matlin will only
be helped if their high-risk parents
always have a stronger incentive to
surrender them rather than to jeopardize
their lives secondly we should ALS Al
remember suspicious or unsolved infant
deaths we can assume that some
unexplained deaths are usually caused by
abuse or neglect if there is not enough
evidence to prosecute them again
stronger Safe Haven protections can only
increase the odds that these babies Will
Survive third infants who would
Otherwise Die are far more are far from
the only beneficiaries of the bill there
are many babies in our state who will
not die as infants but who are still
clearly better off being surren render
than remaining with their parents
particularly in the time that we have
right now with the opioid crisis think
of the death of 5-year-old Elijah Lewis
for example Elijah was not killed as an
infant these are all cases in New
Hampshire by the way it would have been
better for him to have been surrendered
as an infant than to remain with his
parents for the short life of horrific
abuse if we don't act to strengthen our
laws babies facing all these realities
may be worse off hospitals and law
enforcement may have repeatedly acted in
a way that disincentivizes parents from
using our law this bill will assure
high-risk parents that even if Hospital
staff report them to the police using
our safe haven law will not lead to
their arrest for nonabandonment
crimes every criticism that you're
hearing today or read of this bill
implicitly assumes that if babies cannot
be safely surrendered they will be
safely raised in a stable home this is a
false Choice with no relationship to the
world of reality no baby who is left by
his parents with a stranger or in a box
would have been better off with his
parents if if better off if his parents
had kept him solely out of the fear of
the
police I also want to just speak to this
exclusionary rule and that um that
although um that because we need we need
this exclusionary rule because of the
circumstances that I just mentioned that
it needs to save lives but an in
exclusionary rule is a well established
Concept in Fourth Amendment law every
single state and federal trial court
regularly applies an exclusionary rule
and you can and you can ask any criminal
lawyer about it what I just I don't
understand this idea that that somehow
that the alternative is that the baby is
going to be in better hands we're in a
dire situation here with this child and
um I also just wanted to answer
representative Merchant's comment that
he made about the 24-hour like if all
the firemen left to deal with a fire
well then they wouldn't be an option for
this law they it has to be 24-hour man
so that would be irrelevant and then
please start wrapping up okay and then
somebody just asked the question about
um the number of them and we are only
because the state doesn't report these
they're not keeping the statistics on it
we can only go by what's in the media
and that's why it was stated earlier
that we think that it was about four of
them so does anyone have any questions
representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman uh based on
what you've heard so far I must say I
was horrified when I saw that baby box I
thought I had this picture U now I
remember 20 years ago when
Morin Moody and I were working on things
like this it's a long time
ago we with would you support the
chairman uh forming a subcommittee that
would be able to uh clarify some of
these issues so that we don't lose this
opportunity 20 years later to do
something well that doesn't mean you
have to serve on it well I wouldn't be
serving on it because I'm not a
legislator but um but I I feel as though
it's pretty straightforward this
exclusionary rule I don't know that
there's a whole lot to talk about
because it seems like there's even like
a bipartisan understanding of what the
alternative is and that the baby box
might seem barbaric but the alternative
is even worse so it is a safe space
24-hour man so um I don't know that
there's really a whole lot to discuss
about it to be honest with you if I felt
like that there was something that was
truly controversial that really needed
time to unpack then yes I would but I
don't know that this is one of them you
how able we are to find issues and talk
about it I just believe that this is
extremely important and don't want to
lose the
opportunity that was there 20 years ago
and and it's uh clearer now and the
chairman has the authority to form a
subcommittee um um rather than than and
so that we can go to the floor with
a very well produced piece of
legislation well I'm glad that you're
concerned about it because babies have
been abandoned since the beginning of
time and so we just have to meet that
now for today's needs using technology
to our advantage for example other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you so
much I also do I do have my written
testimony and I will pass that out and
in my written testimony I have um the um
references to all of the articles that I
mentioned in my testimony and if it's
helpful I can also email it to you where
there's Live Links because in in writing
I can't have the live link so if that
would be helpful I'm happy to do that
okay sure thank you okay right thank you
um no one else has signed up to testify
on
hb67 on the blue sheet in the back 10
people did sign up in favor and one
opposed and U representative Le do you
know the online U yes online mirrors
real life we have4 in support and three
opposed I don't mean real life but in
person okay okay with that I am going to
close the
public with that I am going to close the
public hearing on
hb67 and I'm going to open the final
bill of the day for HB 1604
dfn and uh the sponsor is uh
Cornerstone I think they still doing I
mean not very sanitary
so I wasn't sure if that was an
appropriate thing for me to do but I
thought no that's
okay I'm very willing to serve on a
that um could I just ask as a
preliminary matter he says please note
represented uh Amendment
0323 and I don't know whether that's
been handed out or
not representative d uh the amendment
you refer to in your testimony has that
been distributed
yet no and I I my plan was to just do it
at the exact session but I'm going to
talk about the amendment here and it was
what it's very simple is to eliminate
number three
okay that was the thing I emailed out to
everybody the other day oh okay yeah
that's right I did see I'm sorry I
didn't realize you needed to have that
for today bills I do want to speak to it
as as an unamended Bill though okay go
ahead you may begin thanks um this has
been an absolutely amazing day um we're
all here for a reason um my reason is I
believe we have a Health Care system in
distress and one of the reasons I ran
for office was to try to do something
about that um this morning I was able to
testify in a bill on prior authorization
reform which has been about an
eight-year project for me so this is
also a big issue for me as well as you
know um I'm David Nagel um I'm a state
representative representing gilmington
Guilford and a slice of
lonia um I also specialize in um
physical medicine and rehabilitation I
work with people with complex
disabilities and I advocate
whoa you know when I sing at church and
caner the first thing I do is tell
people to silence their cell phones
although most people crank them up
higher so that they don't have to hear
so um I also advocate for the rights of
patients I've been doing that for a long
time and I travel all over the country
part of the process that I was involved
in was to write this book and um this
book was about Pain Care policy the
United
States the concept of electronic medical
record reform is throughout this book so
it's clearly an important issue for me
um before we begin I wanted to say two
things number one is I I have to I you
know we're here to advocate for somebody
right so in my life I've gotten 11
standing ovations and the saddest thing
is I kept count but I've had 11 of them
two of them were because of something I
did nine of them were because of
something I said and what I said was and
this is I in nine different states I
said if I had my way I would take the
electronic medical record as it exists
now I would throw it to the bottom of
the ocean and I would never bring it
back and the first time I said that I
thought I was going to get it was a
bunch of family practitioners and I
thought they were going to throw Rotten
Tomatoes at me and i' life would be over
and Dr Palmer would probably say nasty
things about me and all that turned out
they stood up and universally applauded
and I was like totally surprised by that
cuz I felt like I was alone in my
feelings about this and it turned out
that I wasn't the last time I did it was
in Dallas Texas about 2 months ago and
this group is just a a a lay group there
were no Health Care people in this group
at all and then they proceeded to tell
me the horror stories of they've had
about being on the other side of the
electronic medical record totally
unsolicited because it wasn't even the
topic of why I was there so it is a big
issue to a lot of people the other thing
is the amendment is going to remove the
third item in this bill um um that's
based on a discussion I've had with
several stakeholders um I'm going to
still talk to that
section but it it needs work and that's
why it's going to be removed and the
final point before I begin I I already
did begin but um was that this bill is
not just about doctors um I want to say
that right out front anybody who
provides a health care service that
requires prior authorization for that
service is included in this bill and the
reason why I say that is as you know
integrative care is very important to me
um Chiropractic Care acupuncture things
like that those are people that that
really do want to be included in the
insurance market and um they don't have
the money to create to have an
electronic record frequently so that's
I'm I'm speaking on behalf of them um
also I think we've talked about the
doctor patient relationship a lot today
um and it's one of the most important
things to me in my life I have two books
in process on that um any public policy
intervention that we do whether it's an
electronic record a prior authorization
needs to First think about what the
effects are on the doctor patient
relationship and if the intended or
unintended consequences adversely affect
it we need to think twice about it the
other thing is I will go to my grave
saying the worst thing we've ever done
to healthc care in the last 30 years of
Reform is kill Private Practice it's
always been the Bedrock of American
Medicine and we've watched it get
destroyed and my concern is that prior
authorization that we talked about
earlier today in electronic medical
record which we're talking about now
have both killed Private Practice to the
point that 80% we had 80% in ducks in
private practice 30 years ago at the
beginning of Reform now we have 15% and
it's
dropping um anyways with that said in
1981 um I was asked to um take a
position I was pretending I was an
attorney and um on on the concept of
computerization in medicine in 1981
computers didn't exist there was no
internet but there was this Vision that
we might need it I willingly took the
opposed point of view and I argued the
seven points that are in this handout
that I don't want to repeat right now
but basically what I said was that I
viewed that if this is not done properly
it would create a wedge between the
doctor and patient it would create a
crisis in humanism in health care it
would create unnecessary and excessive
cost it would threaten the existence of
Private Practice it would empower people
other than doctors to manage what we do
um and it would P present an unnecessary
challenge to doctors on what's most
important the needs of the patient the
needs of the computer the needs of the
employer I would argue that every one of
those things has happened as a result of
of of these things that we're doing
these days um it doesn't have to be that
way um interestingly I didn't know this
till yesterday but the electronic record
was it probably wasn't first envisioned
by George Bush and but he's the first
one who articulated it in his uh State
of the Union Address in
2004 in which he put the novel idea that
by computerizing Health Care records we
can avoid dangerous medical mistakes
reduce costs and improved care he was
implying that we could facilitate
communication between the doctor the
patient and all the providers together
and I thought wow what a great idea and
I thought you know retrospect ively if
that's the way things turned out it
would be wonderful unfortunately that's
not what's happened beginning with the
development of meaningful use in 2009
which was referred to earlier today by
the the woman from Minnesota and all the
adverse effects of meaningful use um
which I'd be happy to explain in
questioning if you want me to um
basically what meaningful use said was
it was it was created um as a means to
um to use an electronic medical Rec
record that was subsidized by the
government money was given I think the
only people that really benefited with
the tech companies that sold this stuff
and then what they did was they mandated
that we as doctors would have to ask so
many questions all about data collection
basically public policy type questions
so when you go to your doctor and he
asks if you feel safe in your home
that's where that comes from um there's
a whole list of them um and the carrot
and the stick and that term is has been
used over and over and over again and it
was actually used in our public
deliberations on on on prior
authorization which I find offensive was
that they would withhold 15% of your fee
if you didn't
comply um and I personally find that
insulting U and inappropriate but that's
functionally what they did in the end
the way these things developed it was
not at all about communication it became
fragmentor what it did was it and even
when these plate gu would come sell this
software to you the first thing they
would say is this is the way to maximize
your billing this is the way to maximize
your Revenue it was nothing about
patient care and then it was all about
data collection um and and and how to
get data for other people the problem
with it was you I was in part of the
national pain strategy and and the
people that I was with were all public
policy people academicians and they're
all looking at me looking and saying we
can we need data on pain so we're going
to throw that into meaningful use and I
promptly raised my hand and I asked how
many of you are clinicians here now one
person raised their hand and I looked at
them I said you have any idea what
that's going to do to the time I have
with my patient I'm there to deal with
the problem they come to me with not the
concerns that you have and that's the
way the whole process is
evolved
um I'm going to read something I know
representative kushman may not
appreciate this but she's not here so
I'm going to do it anyways um so
this person not real long is it no no
it's it's that paragraph right by the
way there's an 800 page report on prior
authorization and we're going to stay
late I'll read that whole thing to you
but anyway so um Dr Eric toppel I'm
proud to say he's a fellow University of
Rochester graduate um um and I Google
his name to find out who he is he's
actually one of the most cited doctors
on the planet but his big thing is is is
uh you know you know is yeah so um I'm
gon to just read what he he
basically represent did you have a I
have a question
sure we're hearing a huge amount of how
we got here yeah um
and I'm wondering I'm almost there I'm
wondering if we could get fairly soon to
the issue of how this is going to help
because we are where we are and how is
this going to change it all right cuz
getting here we're here y so what I need
to know is how is this going to fix it
and how are we going to overcome the
things that I'm thinking might have come
up if this had been heard by the
Commerce Committee rather than the that
works for me sure I'll let you read that
on your own I will read one
sentence um they're pathetic they're the
worst software in existence they've
really taken us astray and given us the
the whole digital era Bad Name they're
uniformly hated by patients and doctors
and they're the single worth part of
deteriorating the doctor patient
relationship so that's where we are
hp64 is a very real solution to a very
real potential
problem we have no control over CMS but
today SE because of activity that we've
been done doing for eight years they
decided to reform prior authorization I
would like to use this as a way of
getting them to reform the electronic
medical record I'm fully aware that the
insurers in our state do not require an
electronic medical record for providers
now we have a real fear that there's
going to with the oopz of Health Care
meaning that that's the biggest word I'm
using
today so what we do know and and has
been predicted by a lot of people in
healthcare economics is that we're
seeing a world in which we're going to
have a couple of insurers and a couple
of Health Care providers who will have
the ability to come into this state and
dictate to us how we do things and we
won't really have a choice that was the
whole point of putting this in
legislation there's three parts to this
bill the first part is just to Define
electronic medical record because I
think it's really important we Define
it the third the second part is the part
that I want to keep and it's the most
important part to me first of all
no public or private Health carrier can
ever require that a health care provider
use an electronic medical record the
reason why this is important is I've
worked a lot with the Chiropractic
associations and they don't a lot of
their providers don't use them they want
access to insurance so that they can
provide for people that are lacking in
resources but they don't want to have
you know the minute you go to that you
have to develop a platform which is
extremely expensive and that's what's
really killed private practice is they
can't afford it so that's one of the
concerns we have is to protect them and
protect the doctors who would like to go
back into private practice of the ones
who are still there secondly you cannot
withhold any portion of a provider's fee
for not using an electronic medical
record third that they cannot require
any specific format of EMR and the
reason why that's important I don't know
if you've ever had a chance to look at
your medical record I see them every day
yesterday I looked at a 31-page report
from the VA hospital that said virtually
nothing I mean I couldn't figure out who
the doctor was what the reason they were
being referred for a lot of the primary
care offices use similar templates that
tell you virtually nothing it's useful
in useless information except it answers
the the the questions of meaningful use
and that was why I wanted to get away
from this policy that you have to ask
patients very specific questions
and um the uh so that's the format and
the the fourth part is that they cannot
require that you ask those specific
questions um and the whole goal of it
was number one is to try to get a
Renaissance and return to Private
Practice which may be a pipe dream but I
still think it's important and number
two um is that we can protect the
alternative integrated providers who
we're going to hopefully as we go
forward with bills like HP 66 to give
them the power to be part of the health
care dialogue without excess cost and
without putting themselves at risk and
having to join these oligopolies and I
will tell you um that the minute you
join one of those you very quickly find
out that um you tow the
line your job is about production
Revenue production it's not about
patient care that's a secondary thing
and yeah you can try to do the best you
can I'm a dinosaur I'm really lucky I
can do anything I want but I'm also
about to retire and leave my practice
I've already noticed the doctors that
are replacing me are expected to produce
and I would be happy to give you a
million horror stories about that but
that's the whole purpose is to try to
restore back to Medicine the joy of
medicine which we all started out with
and also to give us the ability to
practice as we see fit and not try to
stuff everything into a 10-minute visit
7 Minutes of which is palliating the of
the computer um what else do I want to
tell you does that answer your
question I have a question when you
finish but I'm sorry I did interrupt you
so no I don't care I'm glad you did I'm
used to that what started there was
really help yeah no you I mean I was
pretty much all the ways there anyways
um um I mean that's I think that's
pretty much all I wanted to oh yeah the
other part was the the third part that
I'm eliminating um we've already heard
about this part
elsewhere um I we have a huge problem
with medical misinformation in the chart
um the problem with a doctor patient
relationship is you tell me something I
filter that then I dictate it into a Noe
or draging into a Noe or whatever and
there's a an interpretation process that
goes in there sometimes the information
gets in there is inaccurate or harmful
and there needs to be a process by which
a patient can look at their record and I
in my second book we actually have it's
called The Art of Keeping your doctor
human but there's a section in there
about how important that is to know
what's in your record because you can be
harmed by what's in there I see it in my
world over and over again so the purpose
of this part three was actually
to there there is a way to do it now it
doesn't work and that was what I wanted
to get at the problem is this is I will
totally acknowledge very poorly written
not tremendously well thought out um I
thought that it was amendable but it's
probably not and I think it's open to
further discussion over the course of
the year we've already put together
think tanks or group ad hoc groups to
sit there and try to solve these
problems we we did that with prior
authorization we did that with pain
management and I would like to just do
that with that section and not
considered as part of the bill at this
time now I'm done representative Weber
Shapiro so thank you very much for that
explanation and we're treading into
areas that I know nothing about because
nor these kinds of bills go to Commerce
uh which may be a good thing or maybe a
bad thing it's a good thing because I
don't have to think about them but my
question
is your goal is absolutely
wonderful explain to me how this is
going to
ensure that autonomy is returned and
that docs simply aren't going to be
picked up but docs who don't use
electronic records the insurance
companies are just going to say
well um sucks boo to you so I'm there's
a disconnect there that I'm not
understanding it's all about money and
it's all about cost so I have a friend
of mine he's like the worst meanest
person in the world and the reason why
is because he's always smiling and happy
and I'm really annoyed at that and so I
asked him why are you always smiling and
happy when the rest of us are miserable
and he said the reason why is because he
he he went what they call he went naked
what that means is it has nothing to do
with net you know what I mean I get so
what it means is that you basically you
go without an electronic record um you
go out with all the cost like you when
we went to the electronic record and
prior authorization you wouldn't believe
the staffing needs that we needed to
cover that and and so he doesn't need
all that staff he doesn't even need a
computer at all he still writes his
notes on by hand and he spends all of
his time with the patient with their
needs first and foremost and he said you
know what I'm the for the first time in
years I'm a real doctor and and I don't
feel those pressures outside of me and
so I don't expect every doctor and he
doesn't have malpractice insurance
either you know he didn't he went
totally naked and um so the but what
happens is when you go that route number
one is you know there's an epidemic of
Dr burnout and the EMR is actually
considered the number one cause of Dr
burnout so if you can at least I I I I'm
not sure that I think you can make the
electronic record workable I just think
the as Dr toppo said it's not workable
the way it is um and he's a smart guy
and he's very well known and if he can't
make a change I'm concerned that maybe
what we're doing here won't either but I
I you got to
start I follow up follow
up so I get all that but as I read this
I'm thinking that the actual consequence
is that um you know we've had any number
of
bills um for people to set up practices
that are just cash only practices and
they don't take any insurance and
therefore they shouldn't have to take
anybody who doesn't have you the the
means to pay there's no provision for
charity care of or whatever we call it
now um what I
concerned about with this bill is I
don't see how this I mean is is your
friend who goes naked does he take
insurance at all or does he just not
take insurance well the way they do it
is that the patient submits the bill
themselves he doesn't submit it for them
yeah I see and and the other um shoot I
was going to say something really
important anyways anyways it'll come
back come back so the the the the rest
of my question is I'm still not
understanding how oh I know what I was
going to say just passing this bill
which says they can't require it means
that suddenly we will go back to
1957 which had a lot of good easy ways
to practice medicine and a lot of people
were doing really shitty job of it
anyway so I will answer that with a
statement um um most doctors like to
make Simplicity out of complexity
physiatrists make complexity out of
Simplicity and and and this is a this is
part of a bigger a bigger approach you
know to just do this by itself had some
effect but not a not a lot the prior
authorization thing that we presented in
the Senate this
morning that was part of a bigger
approach you know the CMS thing that was
released I mean this is a multi-prong
strategy of which this is just one part
each part by the themselves probably
accomplish very little it's the
collective hole that's important so
identify all the elements of medical
care that have gotten us away from where
we need to be is z
right okay yeah representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman I have a
closet full of handwritten records
locked away in file cabinets in my house
and um I have a lot of sympathy for your
description of the electronic medical
records and it pains me when um the
Community Mental Health Center that I'm
on the board of all of a sudden there's
all this talk about how everyone wanted
to quit their jobs because of the old
electronic medical records but now they
have a new one that's going to like be
completely different and effective and
save their stuff and I wonder I I'm very
doubtful and they spend millions of
dollars on it as well so my question is
um twofold one is this a um isn't it the
reality that there are still a number a
lot of practitioners like I was as a
mental health practitioner in private
practice that there are still a lot of
practitioners that don't necessarily um
use electronic medical records and that
if this and if insurance companies
started requiring it it would wipe all
those people out so isn't that isn't
your bill effective for those people I
mean my bill was both bills even the
prior authorization Bill earlier today
was designed to be broad um we were very
careful to make sure this wasn't just
about MDS it was about everybody because
I mean I really think we we need to look
I'm sorry this is probably getting a
little off topic but like we need to
look at healthc care as an integrative
whole and and we're not doing that and
you know we pay pills PE pay doc people
to do pills and procedures but not to
provide care I I that's a problem so we
need to give people as many much
incentive as possible to care for people
um most doctors will say like you know I
mean I'm so busy like figuring out what
button to push on a computer that I'm
not really thinking I and I don't want
to be totally negative about the
electronic record I it has potential
just not the way it is and Dr toppel I
read his quote I mean I he said
everything a lot better than I could say
it thank you other
questions staying n thank you thank you
thanks for listening so
late he Al I also signed up to speak and
he's been waiting over there so long is
former Senator Andrew Hosmer from
Health you you've been here all
afternoon I wasn't sure which bill you
were going to speak on I was just
enjoying myself and listening to this
good to it was great it's nice to be
here it's my favorite committee to come
to believe it or not that's anyway for
the record my name is Andrew Hosmer I
represent um New Hampshire's nonprofit
Health insur Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare
and um I appreciate you taking just a
minute um we are we are neutral on
representative Nagel Bill and what I
appreciate about representative Nagel is
we often have many productive
conversations about a number of issues
in regards to health care so we would
look to continue to have those right now
and first of all I just wanted to make
clear that Harvard Pilgrim healthcare
does not mandate um the use of
electronic medical records um it is our
firm commitment that the appropriate
level of care at the best time and the
best place helps achieve the best
outcome for our patients it's what we
live by um and we also Harvard Pilgrim
recognizes the value of private
practices particularly those that serve
our rural areas areas of New Hampshire
um however Harvard Pilgrim does highly
recommend that providers use an EMR to
ensure that patients benefit from care
coordination across the Health Care
System uh while we do not require which
system a provider uses or how much data
they choose to put into the system uh
Harvard Pilgrim understands the best
care for our members is to be able to
quickly send data back and forth um
through um um to multiple providers if
necessary uh for example one issue that
has come up over the past is um uh they
do not want patients being dispensed
drugs twice because we cannot see their
prescription has already been filled by
another provider something that EMR has
helped uh uh providers track as well as
helps insurers and carriers to track as
well um also it's critically important
that someone receiving Emergency Care uh
the use of electronic medical records um
allows the provider to look at things
like prior conditions of the patient
allergy to antibiotics pre-existing
conditions or Pharmacy interactions so
um I think also this committee should
consider as well in which direction is
CMS moving not saying it's the right
direction or the wrong direction they
are moving towards more Reliance on a
electronic medical record system um and
if this were to be enacted would we be
in conflict with the federal law and
would we lose lose the the um the
relevance of of this Statute in the
state I'm not really sure the answer to
that right now
but we would just suggest that as you
consider to consider as you continue to
consider this that you take some of
these issues into consideration I'm
happy to take questions right now um and
if I can't answer them I'm happy to
share them with my client as well thank
you Mr chair and thank you members of
the committee thank you any
questions saying none thank you good
evening good
evening also signed up to speak is uh
Ben Bradley from the New Hampshire
okay is that AA Hawks okay AA Hawks from
Society sorry to keep your folks so long
no thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for your Indulgence uh and
good evening uh and thank you to my
colleague Ben I am helping facilitate an
advocacy update for some Med students at
six o'clock so and it's on was right I
hope it's close by It Is by Zoom So in
theory it is um so for the record my
name is Ava Hawks I am the director of
advocacy for the New Hampshire Medical
Society we are here in support of
Representative nigles Bill house b604 as
amended I believe I indicated that on my
pink card um and I'm sure representative
Nagel circulated that Amendment um I can
say confidently that representative
Nagel is probably one of our most
passionate members about uh electronic
medical records and their need for
reform and we we support the language in
sections one and two and hopefully that
was under a minute thank you all and I'm
happy to take
questions any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you have a good evening a good
zoom and last but not least Ben Bradley
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association thanks Mr chairman uh for
the record Ben Bradley New Hampshire
Hospital Association um just wanted to
register our uh on the record our
support for hp64 as amended I appreciate
the representative's focus on this uh
matter uh small medical providers are
essential to a robust Healthcare Network
especially in the more rural parts of
our state happy to take your
questions any
questions representative Palmer um I
probably should have asked this earlier
but
um my limited understanding since I've
been working in a hospital is that um
when the mun fuel use and all of this
came out and I have a lot of the same
objections that Dr Nagel does
but that um that CMS does take
a pays less if you're not using an EMR
and I and that's I guess one of my
questions here is whether that is
something we need to look at as we go
through this
bill it's I guess the same thing as what
somebody raised earlier about conflict
with with the federal government on
where this bill goes I'm um I'm not
aware of that stipulation from CMS but
I'm happy to look into
it other
questions seeing none thank you Mr
Bradley I have no one else signed up to
testify on uh
hp64 FN uh Christina did anybody sign
or
yeah uh three people signed up to speak
uh one four and two uh excuse me three
people signed up uh on this bill one in
favor two opposed and how many online
online we had four in support and one
opposed
and with that I am going to close the
public hearing on
hp64 FN that was the last bill are
noticed for hearing today so we are done
uh and we stand adjourned until next
all